THE SENATE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER FIVE ON CORRECTIONS,
PUBLIC SAFETY. JUDICIARY. LABOR
AND TRANSPORTATION WILL COME TO
ORDER. GOOD MORNING. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARING
HERE IN THE CAPITOL. I ASK ALL
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE BE
PRESENT IN ROOM 112 SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH QUORUM AND BEGINNING
OUR HEARING. TODAY'S HEARING
WILL COVER THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL ACROSS
CORRECTIONS, PUBLIC SAFETY,
JUDICIARY, LABOR AND
TRANSPORTATION. WE WILL BE
JOINED BY REPRESENTATIVES FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE,
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE,
AND DEPARTMENTS. AGENCIES
COVERED BY SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER
FIVE. THIS IS AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING, SO WE ARE NOT TAKING
ANY VOTES TODAY. THIS HEARING
WILL START WITH LABOR, WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT, EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION, PENSIONS AND
RETIREMENT ISSUES. THEN COVER
PUBLIC SAFETY AND JUDICIARY
ISSUES AND CONCLUDE WITH
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES. WE WILL
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER WE
COMPLETE DISCUSSION ON ALL ITEMS
TO ENSURE WE HAVE TIME FOR
EVERYONE, EVERYTHING. ON TODAY'S
AGENDA, WE ARE ASKING PRESENTERS
TO KEEP THEIR TESTIMONY UNDER
FIVE MINUTES. I WOULD ALSO ASK
MY FELLOW COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
KEEP THEIR COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS CONCISE. WOULD ANY OF
THE MEMBERS LIKE TO SAY ANYTHING
AT THIS MOMENT? GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING. SO
BEFORE WE BEGIN DISCUSSION,
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM
CONSULTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. SENATOR WAHAB HERE. SENATOR
WAHAB HERE. SENATOR DURAZZO
HERE. SENATOR DURAZZO HERE.
SENATOR NEWMAN, SENATOR SOURTOE
HERE. SENATOR CIOTTO HERE. WE
HAVE A QUORUM. THANK YOU. THE
CONSULTANT NOTES A QUORUM HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED. LET'S BEGIN
WITH OUR FIRST ISSUE. OUR FIRST
ISSUE IS GOING TO BE AN OVERVIEW
OF THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL. ANDREW MARCH AND ASTON
FOSS OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, AS WELL AS CHAS ALAMO
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. ISSUE ONE COVERS THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS FOR LABOR AGENCY ED
THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD
AND DIR. FIRST, WE'RE GOING TO
GO AHEAD AND HEAR FROM ANDREW
MARCH OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. HELLO, GOOD MORNING,
ANDREW MARCH, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. SO I'D LIKE TO START
OFF FIRST WITH A GENERAL
OVERVIEW OF THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL, SO, AS NOTED
BY THE GOVERNOR ON FRIDAY, THE
MAY REVISION IS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO BRIDGE THE
ADDITIONAL SHORTFALL THAT HAS
DEVELOPED SINCE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET. LIKE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET, THE MAY REVISION IS A
PROPOSAL, AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE MAY HAVE
ALTERNATIVE, AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE, TO COME TO A FINAL
BUDGET AGREEMENT. ONE THING THAT
IS MAYBE DIFFERENT FROM PREVIOUS
YEARS IS THAT THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES A BALANCED BUDGET AND
BUDGET, YEAR AND BUDGET YEAR
PLUS ONE WHERE WE FORECAST A
SIGNIFICANT DEFICIT. SO IN ORDER
TO PREVENT US FROM COMING BACK
NEXT YEAR AND NEGOTIATING
FURTHER REDUCTIONS, WE'RE
PROPOSING A BALANCED BUDGET AND
BUDGET YEAR PLUS ONE, AS THE
GOVERNOR STATED, NONE OF THESE
SOLUTIONS WERE MADE LIGHTLY,
THIS IS A DIFFICULT SITUATION
FOR US ALL. AND WE DIDN'T, WE
WOULD PREFER NOT TO BE IN THIS
SITUATION WHERE WE'RE MAKING
THESE REDUCTIONS, BUT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO COME TO A
BALANCED BUDGET, WITH OBVIOUSLY
SOME REDUCTIONS. SO NOW, MOVING
ON TO SOME OF THE, SPECIFICS
FOR, THIS SUBCOMMITTEE, THE MAY
REVISION INCLUDES $40 MILLION IN
NEW REDUCTIONS AND PROPOSES TO
REDUCE $215 MILLION PREVIOUSLY
PROPOSED FOR DELAYS AT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET, IN THE LABOR
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AREA,
SOME OF THESE MAJOR REDUCTIONS
INCLUDE $150 MILLION REDUCTION
TO CALIFORNIA JOBS, FIRST, IN
ADDITION TO A NUMBER OF
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS, WHICH ARE
DETAILED IN THE AGENDA.
ADDITIONALLY, THE GOVERNOR'S.
THE MAY REVISION PROPOSES
ONGOING RESOURCES FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS TO IMPLEMENT CHAPTER
LEGISLATION THAT WAS CHAPTERED
IN 2024 AND IN 2023. AND,
RESOURCES FOR DEPARTMENTS AND
ENTITIES WITHIN THE LABOR AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY TO
RELOCATE TO THE NEW LABOR AGENCY
BUILDING, WHICH WAS FORMERLY THE
NATURAL RESOURCES BUILDING.
ADDITIONALLY MY COLLEAGUE ASHTON
WAS WITH ME TO SPEAK TO SOME OF
THE MORE GENERAL STATEWIDE
REDUCTIONS, INCLUDING THE 7.95%
OPERATIONS REDUCTION AND THE
VACANT POSITION SWEEP. GOOD
MORNING, ESTÁN OF DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, TO SET THE STAGE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET, WE BROUGHT
FORWARD A TEMPORARY PROPOSAL TO
CUT SAVINGS ASSOCIATED WITH
VACANT POSITIONS FOR 1.5 BILLION
762.5 MILLION GENERAL FUND THAT
PROPOSAL MOVED FORWARD AS PART
OF CHAPTER NINE, STATUES OF 2024
OR AB 106, AS PART OF EARLY
ACTION DURING THE MAY REVISION.
WE'RE NOW PROPOSING THAT WE
WOULD MAKE THAT PERMANENT BY BY
INTRODUCING NOT ONLY A FUND
AUTHORITY REDUCTION, BUT A
POSITION AUTHORITY REDUCTION IN
25, 26 AND ONGOING, THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD RESULT IN
APPROXIMATELY AN ELIMINATION OF
10,000 POSITIONS, ADDITIONALLY,
THIS WOULD BE CONCURRENT WITH
THE STATE OPERATIONS REDUCTION
THAT IS PROPOSED. THE TWO ARE
DISCRETE PROPOSALS. THE MAY
REVISION ASSUMES 2.1 BILLION IN
GENERAL FUND SAVINGS FROM
STATEWIDE OPERATIONS. REDUCTIONS
IN 24, 25, AND 2.7 BILLION
GENERAL FUND SAVINGS IN 2526,
AND ONGOING, THESE PROPOSED
REDUCTIONS ARE FOR STATE
ENTITIES AND ARE NECESSARY TO
ADDRESS THE BUDGET DEFICIT AND
ENCOURAGE DEPARTMENTS TO OPERATE
MORE EFFICIENTLY AND TO MAINTAIN
EFFECTIVE LEVELS OF SERVICE.
FINANCE WILL WORK WITH
DEPARTMENTS TO, DETERMINE WHICH
AREAS WITHIN SUPPORT BUDGETS CAN
ABSORB THOSE CUTS AND MODIFY
ITEMS OF APPROPRIATION
ACCORDINGLY. I'M AVAILABLE FOR
COMMENT OR QUESTIONS AS NEEDED.
THANKS. LEO GOOD MORNING, CHAZ
ALAMO WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE, BEFORE TAKING
ANY QUESTIONS ON THE SPECIFIC
PROPOSALS, OUR OFFICE WAS ASKED
TO PROVIDE SORT OF AN EARLY
ASSESSMENT OF THE OVERALL MAY
REVISION PACKAGE, AND SO I'VE
GOT A FEW NOTES HERE TO SHARE AT
THE TOP, ALTHOUGH A FULL
ANALYSIS OF THE MAY REVISION IS
UNDERWAY AT OUR OFFICE, WE WILL
HAVE SOME INITIAL COMMENTS
PUBLISHED LATER THIS WEEK, AND
OUR FULL ASSESSMENT PUBLISHED
LATE NEXT WEEK. I CAN SHARE SOME
SORT OF EARLY FINDINGS OR
THOUGHTS ON THE MAY REVISION
PACKAGE, FIRST, WITH RESPECT TO
REVENUES, THE MAY REVISION
PACKAGE REVENUE LEVELS ARE ABOUT
$10 BILLION LOWER THAN THE
REVENUE LEVELS PRESENTED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY BUDGET. AND
THIS REFLECTS SOME RECENT
WEAKNESS IN CASH COLLECTIONS,
ESPECIALLY FOR THE STATE SALES
TAX AND CORPORATION TAX, OUR
OFFICE HAS ALSO VERY RECENTLY
PRODUCED A REVENUE FORECAST, AND
IT IS SOMEWHAT BELOW THE MAY
REVISION REVENUE NUMBERS. SO
THOUGH WE BELIEVE THE MAY
REVISION REVENUE ESTIMATES ARE
REASONABLE, WE THINK THEY'RE
PROBABLY A LITTLE BIT TOO HIGH,
TURNING TO SORT OF THE BUDGET
ARCHITECTURE FOR THE MAY
REVISION, IN OUR VIEW, THE
PACKAGE PUTS THE STATE ON BETTER
FISCAL FOOTING THAN THE STATE
WAS ON WHEN THE JANUARY
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WAS PRESENTED.
AND DESPITE THE REVENUE
DOWNGRADE THAT I JUST MENTIONED
AND THIS IS PRIMARILY FOR TWO
REASONS. THE FIRST IS THAT THE
MAY REVISION MAY REVISION
PACKAGE MORE SUBSTANTIALLY PULLS
BACK ON ONE TIME SPENDING, IT
DOES THIS BY CONVERTING SOME
DELAYS THAT WERE PROPOSED IN THE
JANUARY BUDGETS TO REDUCTIONS.
THIS HAS THE EFFECT OF IMPROVING
THE OUTYEAR FISCAL PICTURE, AND
THE MAY REVISION ALSO REDUCES
RELIANCE ON THE STATE'S
BUDGETARY RESERVES, MEANING THAT
THOSE RESERVES REMAIN IN THE
POCKET TO BE USED IN LATER
YEARS, AGAIN IMPROVING THE
STATE'S FISCAL POSITION, AT THIS
POINT, SORT OF EARLY
OBSERVATIONS, WE THINK WE HAVE
TWO MAIN AREAS OF EXPOSURE GOING
INTO NEXT YEAR THAT WE THINK
THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE SHOULD
HAVE TOP OF MIND WHEN IT
CONSIDERS THESE ITEMS. AND THE
FIRST, AS I MENTIONED, IS WE
THINK THAT THE MAY REVISION
REVENUE PACKAGE IS PROBABLY A
LITTLE BIT TOO HIGH. SO THERE'S
SOME DOWNSIDE RISK, MEANING THAT
BY NEXT SPRING, WHEN WE'RE ALL
TALKING ABOUT THE NEXT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT WILL COME
OUT IN JANUARY, THE REVENUES FOR
THE BUDGET YEAR MIGHT BE
SOMEWHAT BELOW WHAT'S INCLUDED
IN THESE MAY REVISION ESTIMATES.
AND THAT MEANS MORE CHALLENGING
DECISIONS WOULD BE HAVE TO BE
MADE NEXT SPRING, SIMILARLY
RELATED TO THE POTENTIAL RISK OF
MORE CHALLENGING DECISIONS IN
THE SPRING, WE POINT OUT THAT
SOME OF THE REDUCTIONS PROPOSED
IN THE MAY REVISION MAY BE
CHALLENGING TO ACHIEVE. AND
SPECIFICALLY THE OPERATING
SPENDING REDUCTION ACROSS THE
BOARD OF 7.95, THESE TYPES OF
REDUCTIONS ARE OFTEN TAKE TIME
TO MATERIALIZE. DEPARTMENTS HAVE
TO FIGURE OUT EXACTLY HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO APPROACH THESE
TYPES OF REDUCTIONS. AND IF THE
SAVINGS DO NOT MATERIALIZE, THAT
IS, IF THE SAVINGS ARE ON SORT
OF BUDGETARY PAPER, BUT NOT IN
PRACTICE, MATERIALIZE, THE
POSITION THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE
AND THE BROADER BUDGET COMMITTEE
WILL BE IN NEXT SPRING WILL BE
MORE CHALLENGING THAN THAN IS
PRESENTED HERE IN THE MAY
REVISION PACKAGE, THOSE TWO
ITEMS TO KEEP TOP OF MIND. I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. AND
I'VE ALSO, JOINED BY MY
COLLEAGUE WHO WHO CAN ANSWER
SOME MORE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE OPERATING REDUCTIONS
PROPOSED IN THE MAY REVISION.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES, DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THIS PANEL?
SENATOR SARAH, FIRST I WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT THIS PANEL IS IN
COMPASSING THE ED THE ALL THE
WAY UP TO ISSUE TWO. CORRECT. SO
ALL THE PAGES IN BETWEEN. THANK
YOU, FIRST, IN REGARDS TO
REVENUE ESTIMATES, BOTH YOU CAN
WEIGH IN, WE HEARD SALES TAX. WE
HEARD OTHER TAXES. INCOME TAX,
WHAT ARE OUR REVENUE ESTIMATES
FOR INCOME TAX REVENUES GOING TO
BE? ARE THEY ON THE UP TREND OR
DOWN TREND? BECAUSE I KNOW WE
HAVE THE HIGHEST UNEMPLOYMENT IN
THE NATION RIGHT NOW. SO I THAT
THAT FRIGHTENS ME A LITTLE BIT.
YES, SIR. OF COURSE, I DID
MENTION THE STATE'S SALES AND
USE TAX AND CORPORATION TAX
SLIDING, THE FLIP SIDE OF THAT
COIN IS THAT THERE HAS BEEN SOME
MODEST GROWTH IN THE STATE'S
PERSONAL INCOME TAX RECEIPTS,
AFTER THE SUBSTANTIAL DECLINE
THAT WE SAW IN THE LAST FISCAL
YEAR, WE AS AN OFFICE THINK THE
MOST LIKELY REASON WE'RE SEEING
STRENGTH IN THE PERSONAL INCOME
TAX, BUT NOT IN THE OTHER
REVENUE SOURCES, IS DUE TO ONE
OF THE KEY REMAINING BRIGHT
SPOTS IN THE STATE'S ECONOMY.
AND THAT'S BEEN THE STOCK MARKET
OVER THE LAST SIX MONTHS, THE
S&P IS UP 20% SINCE LAST
OCTOBER, AND THAT HAS DIRECT AND
INDIRECT CONSEQUENCES.
IMPROVEMENTS FOR THE STATE'S
PERSONAL INCOME TAX, WE THINK
WE'RE IT NOT FOR STRONG EQUITY
MARKETS. THE PERSONAL INCOME TAX
WOULD BE MOVING SIDEWAYS AND
THAT WOULD BE A DETERIORATION
RELATIVE TO MAY REVISION
POSITION THAT WE'RE IN. I WILL
SAY THAT BOTH OUR OFFICE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION NOW HAVE PERSONAL
INCOME TAX FORECASTS THAT ARE
RELATIVELY CLOSE TO ONE ANOTHER,
BUT EMPHASIZING THAT THAT MODEST
GROWTH THAT WE HAVE SEEN IN THE
LAST YEAR, REALLY, IN OUR VIEW,
HINGES ON ON ASSET MARKETS,
WHICH, AS YOU ALL KNOW, ARE
SUBJECT TO CONSIDERABLE
VOLATILITY. ALL RIGHT, FOLLOW UP
QUESTION TO THAT, OR IS IT
EITHER OF YOUR OPINIONS THAT WE
ARE IN A RECESSION OR ARE WE NOT
IN A RECESSION? I'M NOT THE
EXPERT ON THE REVENUES, BUT THE
MAY REVISION DOES NOT FORECAST A
RECESSION. OKAY. SO WE'RE
DEALING WITH ALL THIS IN THE
SCOPE OF NOT BEING IN A
RECESSION. I SHUDDER TO THINK
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF WE WERE IN
A RECESSION. SO HOPEFULLY WE
WON'T GO THERE. QUESTION ABOUT,
THE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
INTEREST. SO WE HAVE A REVISED
ESTIMATE FOR THAT. CORRECT. IT'S
$153 MILLION MORE THAN WE
THOUGHT. SO WE UPDATE THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INTEREST PAYMENT
TWICE A YEAR. SO IN OCTOBER AND
IN MAY, IN OCTOBER, WE WERE
WORKING WITH THE CURRENT
INTEREST RATES AT THE TIME, AND,
AND PROJECTED IT FOR, THE 2024
CALENDAR YEAR IN MAY. WE'VE
UPDATED THAT WITH REVISED
INTEREST RATES FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND SUBSEQUENTLY THE
INTEREST PAYMENT HAS GONE UP BY
153 MILLION TO 484.3 MILLION. SO
IT'S ALMOST A HALF $1 BILLION
RIGHT NOW. AND WE OWE $21
BILLION CURRENTLY, AS OF LAST,
AS OF AS OF APRIL, WE OWE 18.3
BILLION. BUT IT DOES FLUCTUATE
DEPENDING ON THE RECEIPTS AND
THE BENEFITS. AND THAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE OF THE FLUCTUATION.
THÀNH. OKAY. THAT'S CORRECT. BUT
WE ARE PROJECTING, AROUND A $20
BILLION, UI LOAN BALANCE AT THE
END OF 2024. YEAH. SO IN
RETROSPECT, THE $43.4 BILLION
THAT WE GOT FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, IF WE HAD PAID THAT
OFF, WE WOULDN'T HAVE THAT
PAYMENT RIGHT? POTENTIALLY, IF
THE STATE HAD MADE DIFFERENT
CHOICES, SEVERAL YEARS AGO TO,
TO PAY THE, THE BALANCE, THEN
YES, THERE WOULD BE, THERE WOULD
BE, YEAH. TWO YEARS AGO.
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD, WE
HAVE SOME CUTS THERE THAT
CONCERN ME A GREAT DEAL, FIRST
OF ALL, WE ARE WE ARE CONTINUING
WITH, THOUGH NOT AS MUCH, BUT
$20 MILLION TO GO TO THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH LEADERSHIP
CORPS. CORRECT. WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE THAT FUNDING. NÓ. SO
THAT FUNDING WAS ORIGINALLY
PROPOSED IN IN 24, 25. WE'RE
PROPOSING NOW TO REDUCE THAT
FUNDING TO ZERO. OKAY. I BECAUSE
I DIDN'T KNOW WHETHER WE WERE
DOING 40 MILLION AND WE REDUCED
IT BY 20. SO ZERO. THE ORIGINAL
COMMITMENT WAS $60 MILLION, 20
MILLION EACH YEAR FOR THREE
YEARS. AND WE'RE WITHDRAWING THE
LAST YEAR OF THAT FUNDING. SO 40
MILLION HAS BEEN. SO IT'S
ALREADY GONE. AND NOW WE'RE
WE'RE GOING DOWN TO THIS ONE.
YES. CORRECT. OKAY. SO THAT
ALLEVIATES THAT CONCERN.
HOWEVER, MORE CONCERN COMES IN
THE IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS, YOU KNOW,
AS OUR UI DEBT GOES UP, AND WE
SHIFT THOSE COSTS, THOSE COSTS
GET SHIFTED TO, I THINK WE'RE
DOING 100, 150 MILLION FROM
WORKFORCE TRAINING BASICALLY ON
OUR EMPLOYMENT TRAINING, SO WITH
REGARDS TO THE EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PANEL, THE EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING FUND, SO EARLY ACTION
ADOPTED UTILIZING $100 MILLION
FROM THAT FUND, WHICH WAS IN THE
FUND BALANCE. SO IT WASN'T IT'S
NOT THERE ARE NO PROGRAMMATIC
IMPACTS TO USING THAT THAT FUND,
AND THEN THE MAY REVISION ALSO
PROPOSES IN 2526 TO UTILIZE AN
ADDITIONAL $50 MILLION. THAT IS
AGAIN IN THE FUND BALANCE. SO NO
PROGRAMMATIC IMPACTS. SO IS THE
WOMEN IN CONSTRUCTION UNIT BEING
ELIMINATED, NOT A PROGRAMMATIC
BALANCE ISSUE, THAT IS SO AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER, THERE WERE
MANY DIFFICULT DECISIONS AND
DECISIONS THAT WE WOULD PREFER
NOT TO MAKE THAT ARE IN THE IN
THE MAY REVISION. BUT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO DISCUSSING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND PRIORITIZING
COMING TO A BALANCED BUDGET. BUT
DUE TO THE CONSTRAINTS OF THE
BUDGET, WE HAD TO MAKE SOME
DIFFICULT DECISIONS, AND THAT
WAS ONE OF THEM. AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU WILL BE
DOING SOME NEGOTIATING WITH MY
OTHER COLLEAGUES, THIS IS OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT OUR
CONCERNS SO THAT WHEN YOU'RE
NEGOTIATING AT LEAST SOME OF OUR
VOICES CAN BE HEARD IN THE BACK
OF THE BACK OF PEOPLE'S MINDS
WHILE WE'RE GOING THROUGH THIS,
WOMEN IN CONSTRUCTION UNIT
ABSOLUTELY DOES NOT NEED TO BE
ELIMINATED. THERE ARE PLENTY OF
PLACES TO GET MONEY THAT WE'RE
SPENDING OTHER MONEY ELSEWHERE,
TO BE ABLE TO MAINTAIN A PROGRAM
THAT HELPS US GET WOMEN INTO A
NONTRADITIONAL FIELD. YOU KNOW,
I'VE RIDDEN ON PLANES WITH SOME
OF THESE LADIES, OKAY. AND THERE
IS THERE IS NO REASON FOR US TO
BE ELIMINATING THAT PROGRAM,
WHILE WE SHIFT MONEY THAT COULD
BE USED FOR THAT PROGRAM TO PAY
UI DEBT, WHERE WE'RE ACTUALLY
SPENDING MONEY IN UNEMPLOYMENT
INSTEAD OF IN EMPLOYING PEOPLE,
WHICH WILL HELP ELIMINATE OUR
UNEMPLOYMENT, YOU KNOW,
PROBLEMS. SO THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT, AS WE GO FORWARD, I WOULD
LIKE EVERYBODY TO BE AWARE OF
THAT. WOMEN IN CONSTRUCTION
APPRENTICESHIP STUFF, THOSE TYPE
OF THINGS SHOULD NOT BE
ELIMINATED WITH THEIR 10 MILLION
OR $15 MILLION PRICE TAGS. AND I
SEE YOUR HAND ON THE BUTTON. ARE
YOU WANTING TO ME TO MOVE ON?
BECAUSE I'M NOT DONE, I AM DONE.
ACTUALLY, THOSE WERE THE THINGS.
SO THOSE ARE MY CONCERNS ABOUT
WHERE THOSE CUTS ARE. THERE ARE
OTHER FUNDS THAT WE CAN WE CAN
STILL MAKE THOSE CUTS AND THOSE
OTHER FUNDS AND REDUCE THOSE
FUNDS, NOT ELIMINATE OTHER
PROGRAMS, BUT THOSE ELIMINATING
THOSE PROGRAMS IS NOT AN
ACCEPTABLE SOLUTION FOR OUR SELF
GENERATED BUDGET WOES. THANK YOU
, SENATOR DURAZZO. I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FOR RAISING
THAT THAT LAST ISSUE. I WANT TO
ADD TO THE QUESTION, IN ADDITION
TO ELIMINATING THE WOMEN IN
CONSTRUCTION THÀNH, WE'VE CUT
THE YOUTH APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM
, AS WELL, THERE'S VIRTUALLY NO
MONEY LEFT FOR HIGH ROAD
TRAINING, PARTNERSHIPS. AND SO,
WITH THESE KINDS OF WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS, CUTS ALL ACROSS THE
BUDGET, WHAT'S THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN TO FUND
TRAINING? FOR THE JOBS THAT WE
KNOW ARE GROWING, THERE WILL BE,
GROWING DEMAND FOR JOBS THAT ARE
NEEDED, FOR EXAMPLE, TO
MANUFACTURE, BUILD, OPERATE AND
SERVICE GREEN FUTURE. JOBS. AND
THEY'RE ALREADY OUT THERE,
BROADBAND, YOU NAME IT. THERE'S
SO MUCH, NEED OF A TRAINED
WORKFORCE THAT WE DON'T HAVE
RIGHT NOW. SO HOW WAS THIS TAKEN
INTO CONSIDERATION? AND WHAT IS
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN TO
FUND THE TRAINING THAT WE
ALREADY ARE FEELING IS NEEDED?
AND WE KNOW IT'S ONLY GOING TO
GROW AND DEMAND. YES. SO THE
REDUCTIONS THAT ARE INCLUDED IN
THE MAY REVISION ARE GENERALLY
FOR THE LAST YEAR OF FUNDING. SO
THERE STILL WAS SIGNIFICANT
FUNDING THAT WAS PREVIOUSLY
COMMITTED TO AS PART OF THE 2022
BUDGET PACKAGE. SO THERE'S YOU
KNOW, THERE'S STILL A GENERAL
FUND THERE. AND THAT FUNDING IS
STILL GOING OUT. SO FOR EXAMPLE,
FOR HIGH ROAD TRAINING
PARTNERSHIPS, THAT FUNDING IS
STILL EVEN THOUGH IT WAS ALREADY
ALLOCATED, IT IS STILL FLOWING
THROUGH TO THE GRANTEES, IN
ADDITION TO THE PRIOR GENERAL
FUND COMMITMENTS, THERE REMAINS,
FUNDING FEDERAL FUNDING THROUGH
THE WORKFORCE INNOVATION
OPPORTUNITY ACT, AND THEN IN
ADDITION TO FUNDING THAT'S BEEN
DESIGNATED FROM THE IIJA THROUGH
SB 150, ADDITIONALLY, FOR
TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS, AND THE
STATE CONTINUES TO LOOK AT
OPPORTUNITIES TO LEVERAGE
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDING TO,
TO, TO EXPAND WORKFORCE
TRAINING. SO THAT WOULD HAVE TO
BE A CONSCIOUS DECISION BY THE
ADMINISTRATION, BY US, BY
CALIFORNIA, TO USE FEDERAL
DOLLARS FOR TRAINING. IT DOESN'T
COME PRE, PREDETERMINED. SO IS
THE IDEA TO USE FEDERAL DOLLARS
FOR TRAINING? WE DON'T HAVE A
PROPOSAL ON THE TABLE RIGHT NOW.
BUT AS I MENTIONED, SB 150
DIRECTS THE STATE TO USE, 50
MILLION OF FUNDING FOR WORKFORCE
TRAINING. SO THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT THE STATE IS, IS PURSUING.
YEAH, THAT'S FOR CONSTRUCTION.
IT'S NOT FOR NON CONSTRUCTION.
SO I GUESS THAT WAS THAT WAS MY
QUESTION. AND IF YOU'RE USING,
THE BY THE AND BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, FEDERAL DOLLARS,
HOW IS IT THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
INCLUDE EQUITY AND JOB QUALITY
AGAIN, WE DON'T HAVE A PROPOSAL
IN FRONT OF US, BUT HAPPY TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON HOW TO ACCESS
THOSE THAT FUNDING AND WHAT
UTILIZING THAT FUNDING LOOKS
LIKE. OKAY, THAT'S A REALLY
ESSENTIAL PART OF WHAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS SAID. THEY
WANT THE DOLLARS TO BE USED IN A
WAY THAT'S GOING TO PROMOTE JOB
QUALITY AND, ACCESS AND EQUITY
TO THOSE TRAINING PROGRAMS AND
TO THE JOBS THEMSELVES, ON, ON,
ON THE JOB CALLED
.
OH, OKAY. THE CALIFORNIA JOBS
FIRST. COULD YOU, EXPLAIN THAT
WHERE WHERE WE'RE ENDING UP ON
THE CALIFORNIA JOBS FIRST?
PROGRAM, AND IF THERE MAY
REVISION IS ADOPTED, HOW DOES
LABOR AGENCY PREPARE TO ADAPT
THE PROGRAM TO A LOWER AMOUNT OF
SUPPORT? I MEAN, THAT THAT'S
GONE THROUGH AND I'M NOT I WANT
TO BE CLEAR AS TO WHERE WE'RE
ENDING UP AFTER THE JANUARY
PROPOSAL, THE MAY REVISION.
THERE'S A LOT OF MOVING PARTS IN
THAT. YES, SO, SO AT THE MAY
REVISION, THE MAYOR REVISION
PROPOSAL, SO ORIGINALLY THERE
WERE $600 MILLION ALLOCATED TO
CALIFORNIA JOBS. FIRST, THAT
WOULD THE PRIOR FUNDING WOULD BE
MAINTAINED AT $300 MILLION, AND
THEN IT WOULD BE $50 MILLION
EACH YEAR OVER THE NEXT THREE
YEARS. SO $50 MILLION IN 24, 25,
50,000,000 IN 2526, AND
50,000,000 IN 26, 27. AND, THE
PREVIOUS $300 MILLION IS FULLY
COMMITTED, AND THE CALIFORNIA
JOBS FIRST COUNCIL HAS HAS
ALLOCATED THAT RESPECTIVELY.
OVERALL, THE $150 MILLION
REDUCTION WOULD BE A GENERAL
REDUCTION TO, TO A NUMBER OF
AREAS WITHIN CALIFORNIA. JOBS.
FIRST, WE'RE HAPPY TO PROVIDE
YOU SPECIFICS ON SORT OF WHERE
THAT THE VARIOUS POTS OF FUNDING
END UP. OKAY, OKAY. YEAH AND ON
THE, CALIFORNIA YOUTH LEADERSHIP
CORPS, REDUCTION IN, THERE WERE
A LOT OF, PARTNERSHIPS THAT WERE
REQUIRED, YOU KNOW, TO MAKE THAT
PROGRAM WORK. SO WHAT IS YOUR
SENSE OR ANYONE WHAT IS THE
SENSE OF THE IMPACT ON THESE
PARTNERSHIPS, THAT IT TOOK TWO
YEARS TO PULL TOGETHER AND
REALLY WORK TOGETHER. I MEAN, SO
THERE WOULD BE IT WAS WITH
WITHDRAWING $20 MILLION OF THE
$60 MILLION COMMITMENT. SO THERE
WOULD STILL BE MAINTAIN THAT $40
MILLION, OF WHICH $20 MILLION
IS, YOU KNOW, STILL GOING OUT IN
THE CURRENT YEAR, BUT WE DON'T
WE'RE NOT NAIVE THAT THERE WOULD
BE IMPACTS ACROSS THE BOARD WITH
THESE REDUCTIONS, OKAY. I THINK
THAT'S IT FOR THANK YOU. SO I
HAVE A COUPLE STARTER QUESTIONS
AND THEN I HAVE, YOU KNOW, MORE
DETAILED QUESTIONS. ONE, DO YOU
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
ABOUT HOW THE ONGOING REDUCTIONS
TO STATE OPERATIONS IS GOING TO
BE IMPLEMENTED? AND IS THERE
ACCOMPANYING BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE EXPECTED WITH THIS
PROPOSAL? AS FAR AS DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE, AS MY COLLEAGUE ELIO
ALLUDED TO, THERE'S TIME NEEDED
TO IMPLEMENT SOME OF THESE. AND
SO FINAL, I'M SORRY, I CAN'T
HEAR YOU, FINAL DECISIONS ARE
STILL BEING MADE ON TERMS OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION, WHY? WHILE THE
EXPECTATION IS THAT MOST
DEPARTMENTS WILL BE EXPECTED TO
REDUCE THEIR SUPPORT BUDGETS BY
THE 7.95, FINANCE WILL WORK WITH
THEM IN ORDER TO DETERMINE THE
IMPACTS AND THE FEASIBILITY OF
THOSE REDUCTIONS. WITHOUT
NEGATIVELY IMPACTING THEIR
OPERATIONS, IN TERMS OF A
VEHICLE TO CARRY IT FORWARD,
CONTROL SECTION 4.05 WAS
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES A MINOR UPDATES TO THAT
LANGUAGE. ALL RIGHT. AND THEN
ARE THERE DEPARTMENTS THAT WILL
NOT BE STRICTLY SUBJECT TO THESE
REDUCTIONS? IF SO, WHICH
DEPARTMENTS AND HOW WERE THESE
DEPARTMENTS DETERMINED AS EXEMPT
AT THIS TIME? MOST DEPARTMENTS
ARE EXPECTED TO PARTICIPATE, IN
THE REDUCTIONS. THE LANGUAGE
PROPOSED FOR 4.05 IN THE 24TH
MAY REVISION EXPLICITLY EXEMPTS
THE LEGISLATURE FROM THESE CUTS,
GIVEN ITS INDEPENDENT STATUS AND
APPROPRIATION PROCESS, WE DO
ESTIMATE THAT AT THE TIME OF
REVISION, WE WERE GOING TO,
EXCLUDE THE VARIOUS PUBLIC
SAFETY IN 24 HOUR OPERATIONAL
NEEDS, BUT GENERALLY, MOST
DEPARTMENTS WILL BE
PARTICIPATING. OKAY. SO YOU SEE
CSU, CAL FIRE AND CDC ARE EXEMPT
, THAT SOUNDS LIKE IT OVERLAPS
WITH THE LIST, BUT I DON'T HAVE
THE SPECIFIC LIST IN FRONT OF ME
. OKAY. AND WITH CDC ARE I WANT
TO BE VERY FRANK, SO ORIGINALLY,
THE PROPOSAL IN JANUARY WAS A
POINT ZERO 1, ROUGHLY $15
MILLION. CORRECT I WOULD NEED TO
TURN TO A COLLEAGUE FOR THAT
ANSWER FOR ANY COLLEAGUES IN THE
AUDIENCE.
ALLISON HEWITT, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. SO I THINK WHAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO IS THERE WAS ONE
PROPOSAL INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET OF A COUPLE OF
PROPOSALS. IN ADDITION TO THIS
WAS ONE SOLUTION THAT RELATED TO
A BASELINE ADMINISTRATIVE
REDUCTION FOR CDCR. THAT WAS 15
MILLION IN TOTAL FOR SOLUTIONS.
I THINK WITHIN EARLY ACTION,
THERE WAS 107.9 MILLION, WHICH
INCLUDED THE 15 MILLION, WHICH
IS A LITTLE BIT MORE SIGNIFICANT
. AND THEN THE MAY REVISION
BUILDS ON WHAT WE INCLUDED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. OKAY. AND
OBVIOUSLY THERE HAVE BEEN CALLS
FOR INCREASED, DECREASES. I
SHOULD SAY, SPECIFICALLY, YOU
KNOW, WE HAVE SEEN ROUGHLY IT'S
RIGHT NOW AT 3, IN TERMS OF THE
OVERALL LIKE REDUCTION IN THE
BUDGET PROPOSED FROM, FROM, FROM
MAY TO, I MEAN, FROM JANUARY TO
MAY, CURRENTLY, WHAT IS THE
PROPOSAL? YEAH. SO FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET, THE TOTAL CHANGE IS 146
MIL, APPROXIMATELY $146 MILLION
IN CDCR'S BUDGET. THAT'S A NET
OF GENERAL FUND SOLUTIONS, AS
WELL AS A NUMBER OF A HANDFUL OF
OTHER WORKLOAD PROPOSALS THAT
WILL BE PRESENTING TO YOU LATER
IN THE HEARING. OKAY AND THEN OF
THAT, WHAT IS THE PERCENTAGE OF
THE OVERALL BUDGET, IT'S I, I'M
SORRY, I'M NOT NOT ABLE TO DO
THE QUICK MATH, IN MY HEAD, BUT,
THE, JUST TO, KIND OF, TO MY
COLLEAGUE'S POINT, WE'RE STILL
EXPECTING THAT THERE ARE SOME
PORTIONS OF CDCR THAT WOULD BE,
HELD TO THE STATEWIDE. SO THE
NUMBER YOU STATED WAS 100. AND
WHAT, FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET, THE NET REDUCTION IS
146.4 MILLION, BUT THAT'S A NET
NUMBER, I THINK THERE'S MORE,
THERE'S A HIGHER NUMBER OF
REDUCTIONS. I THINK SOMETHING
LIKE 300 MILLION. IT'S JUST THAT
THERE ARE SOME WORKLOAD
PROPOSALS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAD TO BRING
FORWARD. SO 146 MILLION OF
ROUGHLY A $15 BILLION BUDGET,
CORRECT? 14.4 BILLION. BUT YES,
ROUNDING UP ROUGHLY AND I THINK
YOU HAVE TO TAKE WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT IT OVER A COUPLE OF YEARS.
THAT'S JUST THE CHANGE IN MAY.
REVISION. WE HAVE TO THERE'S
SOME THAT NUMBER ISN'T REALLY
CAPTURING LIKE OVERALL SOLUTIONS
, I THINK IF YOU LOOK AT THE
SOLUTIONS THE ADMINISTRATION
BROUGHT FORWARD, IT'S 169
MILLION ACROSS THE BUDGET
WINDOW. AND THEN THERE'S ONGOING
FUNDING, ASSOCIATED WITH THE
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT PROPOSALS.
OKAY. AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE I KNOW, WE DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE NORA, BUT, WE
WENT THROUGH A BUNCH OF LAOS.
ARE YOU GUYS REVIEWING A NUMBER
OF LAOS HISTORIC, PROPOSALS FOR
REDUCTIONS OVER THE COURSE OF
SEVERAL YEARS? THEY HAVE PUT
SEVERAL THINGS ON THE TABLE. IT
HAS NOT NECESSARILY, OUR MAIN
CONSULTANT ON THIS ISSUE IS
HERE, BUT, I JUST WANT TO
UNDERSTAND, HAVE YOU GUYS BEEN
REVIEWING ALL THE HISTORIC
PROPOSALS ON THE TABLE AS WELL?
I THINK THE ADMINISTRATION
LOOKED AT A NUMBER OF, OF
DIFFERENT WAYS TO ADDRESS THE
OVERALL BUDGET DEFICIT, AND THAT
INCLUDED WHAT WAS ACHIEVABLE
WITHIN CDCR'S BUDGET. AND THOSE
ARE THE PROPOSALS THAT ARE
BEFORE YOU TODAY. WHAT IS THE
DEFINITION OF ACHIEVABLE,
NUMBER, A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
FACTORS. SO I'D SAY AND WE
HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO PRESENT
THESE PROPOSALS YET. BUT THERE'S
A NUMBER THERE'S A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT WAYS THAT WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT CDCR'S BUDGET. IT IS A
24 OVER SEVEN OPERATION, AND SO
THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS
TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION THAT
THEY, THEY DO PROVIDE LIKE
CRITICAL 24 HOUR SERVICES. SO
THERE'S, THERE'S SOME THINGS
THAT ABSOLUTELY JUST CAN'T BE
CUT, THAT SAID, THERE IS A AND
AS MY COLLEAGUES FROM THE, THE
DEPARTMENT AND FROM FINANCE CAN
SHARE, THERE'S A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT THINGS. HOUSING UNIT
DEACTIVATIONS. REVERSIONS OF
PRIOR APPROPRIATIONS, THERE'S A
NUMBER OF ONGOING SOLUTIONS THAT
ARE PROPOSED AS WELL. SO, YOU
KNOW, REVIEWING BUDGETS IN
PARTICULAR. THE ULTIMATE GOAL IS
USUALLY LOOKING AT FOR THE MOST
BANG FOR YOUR BUCK, IF YOU WILL,
IN A VERY CLEAR, CONCISE WAY,
THIS DEPARTMENT IS ONE OF THE
MOST, WELL FUNDED DEPARTMENTS
WITH A POPULATION THAT IS
DECREASING, FIRST AND FOREMOST.
SO I JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT SOME
OF THE EFFORT AROUND THERE THAT
WE WOULD GET THE MOST BANG FOR
OUR BUCK IN SAVINGS HERE. AGAIN,
WE SPEND A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
MONEY ON SAFETY NETS AND
MEDI-CAL AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
AND CDCR COMES IN RIGHT AFTER,
RIGHT? SO I WANT PEOPLE TO TAKE
A LOOK AT THAT. I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE AS WELL. IS THAT AS
MUCH AS WE'RE TAKING A LOOK, YOU
KNOW, WHETHER WE WANT TO DEFINE
WHAT WE'VE BEEN IN OR WHAT WE'RE
MOVING TOWARDS, WHETHER IT'S A
RECESSION OR NOT, AND IT'S VERY
DEBATABLE. YOU HAVE EXPERTS
SAYING WE ARE OR WE WERE OR
WE'RE GOING TO BE, AND SO WE
NEVER REALLY KNOW UNTIL WE'RE
OUT OF IT, BUT ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT I HAVE IS, AS YOU
KNOW, MY COLLEAGUE MENTIONED IS
WE SHOULD BE INVESTING IN
PROGRAMS AND PROJECTS THAT PUT
PEOPLE TO WORK, WHETHER THAT'S
INFRASTRUCTURE, WHETHER THOSE
ARE GETTING WOMEN IN
CONSTRUCTION, WHETHER THAT IS
ANYTHING THAT ALLOWS THEM TO
HAVE A FUTURE RIGHT. AND SO FAR
WE'VE BEEN SEEING, YOU KNOW, FOR
ME, MY BIGGEST FRUSTRATION AND I
THINK I'VE SHARED THIS IN A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT ARENAS, IS,
SERVICES AND DEPARTMENTS AND
ORGANIZATIONS AND EFFORTS AND
PROGRAMS THAT, TO ME ARE
DUPLICATIVE IN NATURE OR COULD
BE EXPANDED WITH SIGNIFICANT
COST SAVINGS. SO, FOR EXAMPLE,
YOU HAVE A CALIFORNIA YOUTH
LEADERSHIP CORPS, RIGHT, AND AT
THE SAME TIME, WE ALSO HAVE A
CALIFORNIA SERVICE CORPS, RIGHT,
AS WELL AS MANY OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT ARE KIND OF COMING INTO
PLACE THAT POTENTIALLY COULD DO
THE SAME THING OR BE
CONSOLIDATED INTO ONE. OR ARE WE
TAKING A LOOK AT JUST
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS AT, YOU
KNOW, THE OVERHEAD
CONSOLIDATION, SEAMLESS AND
EFFICIENT PROGRAMS? AS I, I
CAN'T SPEAK SPECIFICALLY TO THE
TWO PROGRAMS THAT YOU MENTIONED
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THERE MAY BE
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT, ALTHOUGH I
AGREE THAT THEY DO HAVE SIMILAR
NAMES. THAT MAY BE CONFUSING,
BUT GENERALLY THERE ARE SOME
PROPOSALS ACROSS THE GOVERNMENT
OR ACROSS THE STATE TO
CONSOLIDATE VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS
AND REALIGN PROGRAMS WITH, THAT
ARE MORE APPROPRIATE, I THINK
THOSE MIGHT BE HEARD IN A
DIFFERENT SUBCOMMITTEE, FOR
THOSE SPECIFIC PROPOSALS. BUT
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT THE STATE
CONTINUES TO LOOK AT IS SORT OF
IS HOW TO STREAMLINE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS. AND THAT'S
PART OF, THE, THE, THE IMPETUS
OF THE 7.95, OPERATIONAL
REDUCTION IS THAT WE DO BELIEVE
THAT WE CAN DO THINGS MORE
EFFICIENTLY IN STATE GOVERNMENT.
SO WE SEE ROUGHLY A $20 MILLION
CUT TO THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
LEADERSHIP CORPS. BUT WE DON'T
NECESSARILY SEE ANYTHING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SERVICE CORPS. AGAIN,
I, WHICH WAS LAUNCHED THIS YEAR,
WHICH IS A PET PROJECT. SO I
JUST WANT TO UNDERSTAND, YOU
KNOW, AGAIN, IF WE'RE TRYING TO
PROMOTE YOUTH, DOING WORK AND,
AND SUPPORTING THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND SOCIETY, YOU KNOW, WHY CAN'T
WE CONSOLIDATE SOME OF THIS AND
NOT NECESSARILY HAVE THE
DUPLICATIVE NATURE OF THESE
PROGRAMS? I CAN'T SPEAK TO THE
CALIFORNIA SERVICE CORPS, THE
YOUTH LEADERSHIP CORPS IS UNDER
THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD.
AGAIN, ALTHOUGH I THINK THEY DO
HAVE SIMILAR NAMES. I THINK
THERE ARE DIFFERENT IN NATURE,
THE YOUTH LEADERSHIP CORPS IS A
PARTNERSHIP WITH COMMUNITY
COLLEGES, IN ORDER TO HELP YOUNG
PEOPLE BECOME MORE ENGAGED IN
THEIR COMMUNITY. AND, DO YOU
THINK THAT YOUTH LEADERSHIP
CORPS CAN, CAN ALSO BE ENGAGED
WITH THE LOCAL COLLEGES AND SO
FORTH? AND AGAIN, TO AN
EXTENSION? AGAIN, I'M NOT THE
EXPERT ON THE CALIFORNIA SERVICE
CORPS, I THINK IS A IS A IS THE,
TITLE. BUT WE CAN GET BACK TO
YOU ON SORT OF MAYBE ANY OVERLAP
BETWEEN THOSE TWO PROGRAMS. SO I
CONSISTENTLY SEE AND THE REASON
WHY I'M BRINGING THIS UP IS I
SEE, AGAIN, DUPLICATIVE OF TYPES
OF PROGRAMS, WHETHER IT'S IN MY
SUBCOMMITTEE, HOWEVER, YOU GUYS
WANT TO DIVIDE IT OUT. WE'RE
LOOKING AT AN OVERALL BUDGET
RIGHT. SO AT THE END OF THE DAY,
ALL OF US SIT AS SITTING MEMBERS
OF THE OVERALL BUDGET IN THE
SENATE. YOU KNOW, THESE TOUCH
DIFFERENT THINGS. AND, YOU KNOW,
THE FOCUS MAY BE SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT. BUT OVERALL FOR US,
WE HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE
BUDGET. HOWEVER WE WANT TO
DISSECT THIS. RIGHT. SO MY OTHER
CONCERN IS I DO BELIEVE IN
INVESTING IN ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT, INVESTING IN, YOU
KNOW, BETTER WORKER PROGRAMS,
WHETHER IT'S THROUGH A FORMAL
EDUCATION SYSTEM OR THROUGH
APPRENTICESHIPS OR SOMETHING
ELSE. RIGHT. WE HAVE OUR LABOR
EXPERTS HERE IN THE BACK AS WELL
THAT ARE DEEPLY INTERESTED AND
CONCERNED ABOUT THESE PROGRAMS.
AND FOR ME, WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT LABOR, ONE OF OUR LARGEST
POPULATIONS ENTERING THE
WORKFORCE TODAY ARE SENIORS, IS
SENIORS. AND SO AS WE'RE CUTTING
THESE PROGRAMS AND SPECIFICALLY,
YOU KNOW, I WANT TO ASK A LITTLE
BIT MORE WHEN WE'RE CUTTING
PROGRAMS THAT ARE SAFETY NETS TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE POTENTIALLY NOT
ABLE TO WORK ANYMORE, WHO HAVE
DONE 30, 40 YEARS IN THE
WORKFORCE. WHY? AS THE AS WE
HEAR THE TALKING POINT ALL THE
TIME, THE FOURTH LARGEST ECONOMY
IN THE WORLD, WHY DO WE HAVE
SENIORS STILL WORKING,
STRUGGLING AND WHY ARE THE CUTS
SPECIFICALLY TO SAFETY NETS AND
PROGRAMS THAT WOULD PUT PEOPLE
TO WORK AND SO FORTH TO
SPECIFIC, I GUESS, COULD YOU
MAYBE PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT MORE
DETAIL ON THE SAFETY NET
PROGRAMS THAT ARE MENTIONED? ARE
THEY THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS BEING MENTIONED HERE,
OR THERE'S A NUMBER OF PROGRAMS?
RIGHT. THE BUDGET CUTS THAT WE
ARE SEEING LARGELY ARE AFFECTING
OUR EVERYDAY MEMBERS OF SOCIETY.
RIGHT. WE ARE SEEING SIGNIFICANT
CUTS IN SOME OF THESE SAFETY
NET. WE COULD TALK ABOUT THEM
RIGHT IN FULL DEPTH. AND I
SPECIFICALLY WANTED TO ASK, YOU
KNOW, SINCE SINCE WE'RE GOING TO
GET INTO DEPTH IS WHAT AT CDCR
QUALIFIES FOR THE 8% REDUCTION,
I THINK AS MY COLLEAGUE SHARED,
AND I'M HAPPY TO DEFER. BUT WE
WERE NOT ABLE TO SHARE THAT
LEVEL OF DETAIL AT THIS POINT.
IT'S GOING TO BE A WE NOT HAVE
IT. DO WE? I KNOW WE HAVE A
FRAMEWORK THAT WE'RE WORKING
FROM, BUT IT'S GOING TO REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSIONS WITH CDCR
AND THE OTHER DEPARTMENTS AND
OFFICES AND AGENCIES THAT WOULD
BE SUBJECT TO THE REDUCTION.
OKAY. SINCE THIS IS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING, CAN YOU
BRIEF US A LITTLE BIT AS TO WHAT
IS THAT FRAMEWORK POTENTIALLY WE
, IN TERMS OF THE OVERALL
FRAMEWORK FOR THE REDUCTION, I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT
THE POTENTIAL OVERLAPS WITH
DEPARTMENTS BETWEEN DEPARTMENTS
AND TRY TO ARRIVE AT THE VALUE
THAT WE'VE PUT FORWARD. OKAY. SO
WE DON'T HAVE ANYTHING, BUT
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO DELIVER A
BALANCED BUDGET BY JUNE 15TH. I
THINK THERE WOULD BE MORE LIKE
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS BEING
BEING BROUGHT FORWARD. IT'S
GOING TO BE SUBJECT FOR
DISCUSSIONS. THERE'S GOING TO BE
MORE BROUGHT FORWARD IN FUTURE
IN FUTURE BUDGETS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER. BUT
THIS IS THERE IS MORE TIME
NEEDED TO FIGURE OUT EXACTLY HOW
TO OPERATIONALIZE THESE
REDUCTIONS. OKAY. AND I DO
BELIEVE THAT WE ALSO NEED MORE
TIME TO SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING.
WHAT ARE THE PROPOSALS? WHERE
ARE THE DISCUSSIONS GOING? AND
NOT ONE SINGLE DEPARTMENT IS
FREE FROM MORE SIGNIFICANT
IN-DEPTH ANALYSIS OF WHAT'S
GOING ON. I DO BELIEVE IN EVERY
SINGLE DEPARTMENT WE HAVE,
INCLUDING SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT, WHETHER
IT'S UNDER THE SUB FIVE
COMMITTEE'S JURISDICTION OR
ANOTHER, THERE'S MANY, MANY
PROGRAMS THAT ARE DUPLICATIVE IN
NATURE AND THAT, WITH A LITTLE
TWEAKING, CAN BE CONSOLIDATED,
COULD POTENTIALLY SAVE MONEY,
SAVE THESE PROGRAMS, AND ALLOW
PEOPLE TO ACTUALLY PARTAKE IN
THEM. RIGHT. SO AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE, MY PRIORITY IS THE
LOWEST INCOME INDIVIDUALS,
VULNERABLE COMMUNITY SAFETY
NETS, PRESERVING ALL OF THAT FOR
THEM AS WE REALIZE WHETHER OR
NOT WE'RE IN A RECESSION OR NOT.
NUMBER ONE. AND THEN NUMBER TWO
IS DEFINITELY MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE INVESTING IN ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. THAT MEANS
INVESTING IN OUR WORKERS AS WELL
AS INVESTING IN OUR ECONOMY AS A
WHOLE. RIGHT SO MY DISTRICT IN
PARTICULAR, AS MUCH AS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THESE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS, MY
DISTRICT IN ONE CITY ALONE IS
HOME TO THE LARGEST, YOU KNOW,
NUMBER OF MANUFACTURERS IN THE
STATE. 900. RIGHT? IT COVERS
BIOMEDICAL. IT COVERS, YOU KNOW,
BATTERY RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT
, DEVELOPMENT AND MUCH MORE. AND
I DON'T WANT TO SEE MY DISTRICT
HURT BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
SKILLED WORKFORCE, BECAUSE WE'RE
NOT INVESTING IN THEM. RIGHT.
AND WE HAVE IN MY CITY THAT I
REPRESENTED IN HAYWARD, WE HAVE
THREE COLLEGES. THESE ARE
NATURAL ALLIANCES THAT WE CAN
DEVELOP THROUGH DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS WHERE WE CAN HELP,
WHETHER YOU'RE A COLLEGE KID OR
JUST SOMEBODY IN THE REGULAR
STREET WANTING TO SKILL UP SO
THAT IS WHERE OUR INVESTMENT AND
FOCUS SHOULD BE PROTECTING THE
MOST VULNERABLE AND ALSO
DEVELOPING THE WORKFORCE. RIGHT.
BECAUSE WE ARE NOT ONLY
COMPETING WITH EACH OTHER IN, IN
BUSINESS TO BUSINESS, BUT
INTERNATIONAL ONLY. AND SO WHEN
WE SAY WE'RE THE FOURTH LARGEST
ECONOMY, WE HAVE TO START
THINKING LIKE IT AND INVEST LIKE
IT. SO I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
WE'LL MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
TWO. YES SENATOR DURAZO, THANK
YOU, AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
, YOUR REMARKS. I JUST WANT TO
END BY GIVING YOU A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES OF, I THINK, WHAT WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT, THE NEED,
THE ESSENTIAL NEED FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT DOLLARS, THERE WERE
77 APPLICATIONS FOR HIGH ROAD
TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS, AND WE
COULD ONLY FUND 33. SO THE
DEMAND, THE NEED IS THERE FOR
WOMEN IN CONSTRUCTION. THERE WAS
A DEMAND FOR $50 MILLION IN
APPLICATION. THEY COULD ONLY
FUND $25 MILLION. THERE IS ABOUT
$12 MILLION LEFT IN OIL. WELL,
CAP BEING AND THE MONEY YOU
KNOW, THE HIGH ROAD TRAINING
PARTNERSHIP FUNDING ALLOWED AND,
FOR CREATING A PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN OPERATING ENGINEERS,
LABORERS AND A CALIFORNIA
CONTRACTOR. THE MONEY WENT TO
THAT WENT TO FUND THE ACTUAL
WORK CAME FROM CAL GEM. THE BID
WAS WON BY A TEXAS COMPANY
BECAUSE THERE WERE NO LABOR
STANDARDS IN THAT CONTRACT. SO
WE'RE USING OUR MONEY, TO DO THE
WORK OF CAPPING THE ABANDONED
WELLS, WENT TO TEXAS INSTEAD OF
A CALIFORNIA COMPANY WITH
CALIFORNIA WORKERS WITH HIGH
ROAD, STANDARDS. THESE ARE THE
THINGS THAT WILL ONLY WORSEN
WITHOUT THE FUNDING, WITHOUT THE
, THE, FOCUS THAT IT NEEDS TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVEN THOUGH WE'RE
IN A VERY DIFFICULT TIME IN OUR
BUDGET, DOES NOT MEAN THAT WE
SHOULDN'T BE INVESTING IN OUR
WORKFORCE TODAY. SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
TWO, EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION,
PENSIONS AND RETIREMENT
PROPOSALS. WE'RE GOING TO START
OFF WITH ASTON FOSS DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. AND THEN NICK
SCHROEDER FROM LÀ Ó FOR CALPERS
PROPOSALS. AND THEN ANGELA SHORT
FROM THE LEÓN CALSTRS PROPOSALS.
ISSUE NUMBER TWO COVERS THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION PROPOSAL
FOR EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION,
PENSIONS AND RETIREMENT. FIRST,
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AUSTIN FOSS, DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE, MY COLLEAGUES WILL
PROVIDE THE OVERVIEW FOR
RETIREMENT, EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION AND, PROPOSITION
TWO. NOEL, FOR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, FIRST, THE 2024 25TH
MAY REVISION INCLUDES 6.9
BILLION OF WHICH IS 3.5 BILLION.
GENERAL FUND TO SATISFY THE
STATE'S REQUIRED CALPERS
EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTION. AND THIS
NUMBER IS INCLUSIVE OF CSU. VÌ
AND NGUYEN. BOTH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE, THE 2024 25TH MAY
REVISION INCLUDES 4.26 BILLION
IN EXPECTED GENERAL FUND
CONTRIBUTIONS TO CALSTRS IN 20
2425. THIS AMOUNT, WHICH IS
SLIGHTLY INCREASED BY 20 MILLION
FROM THE PROPOSED THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AND IS INCREASED BY 318
MILLION FROM WHAT WAS INCLUDED
IN LAST YEAR'S STATE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO CAL STATE'S HAS
GROWN BASED ON UPDATED, CREDIBLE
COMPENSATION DATA REPORTED BY
CALSTRS SINCE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET, AND IS GROWING OVERALL
SINCE LAST YEAR, BASED ON
INCREASED SALARIES FOR
CALIFORNIA STATE WORKERS. WE
NOTE THE CALSTRS BOARD IS NOT
ELECTED TO INCREASE THE STATE'S
CONTRIBUTION RATE FOR 20 2425,
AND WE'D ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT THE REVISION INCLUDES
519,000 TO REFLECT THE STATE'S
SHARE OF OVERPAYMENTS IDENTIFIED
BY THE SYSTEM, TO BE PAID BY THE
STATE ON JULY 1ST, 2024, AS
REQUIRED BY EDUCATION CODE
SECTION 24616.2. NEXT, THE MAY
REVISION INCLUDES 1.6 BILLION
FOR THE PROPOSITION TWO DEBT
REPAYMENTS. THIS IS
APPROXIMATELY 400 MILLION LESS
THAN A GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THE
PROPOSITION $2 ARE PROPOSED TO
BE APPLIED AS FOLLOWS 360
MILLION TO PRE-FUND RETIREE
HEALTH BENEFITS 836 MILLION TO
REPAY THE LOAN AUTHORIZED BY
CHAPTER 50 STATUTES OF 2017 AND
420 MILLION AS A ONE TIME
SUPPLEMENTAL PENSION PAYMENT
TOWARDS CALPERS TO PAY DOWN
UNFUNDED LIABILITIES. THE MAY
REVISION ALSO INCLUDES 1.2
BILLION, OF WHICH 639.5 MILLION
IS GENERAL FUND FOR INCREASED
EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION AND HEALTH
CARE COSTS IN 20 2425. INCLUDED
IN THESE COSTS COLLECTIVELY
BARGAINED SALARY AND BENEFIT
INCREASES RESULTING FROM
CONTRACT AND SIDE LETTER
NEGOTIATIONS, AS WELL AS
CALENDAR YEAR 2025. PROJECTED
INCREASES IN HEALTH CARE AND
DENTAL PREMIUM COSTS. THIS
AMOUNT SLIGHTLY DECREASED FROM
WHAT WAS PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BY 92.7
MILLION, DUE TO UPDATED PAYROLL
ASSUMPTIONS. AND FINALLY, THE
REVISION INCLUDES PROPOSAL TO
AMEND CONTROL SECTION 3.61 TO
AUTHORIZE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO TRANSFER PROPOSITION
TWO DEBT REPAYMENT FUNDING TO
THE CALIFORNIA EMPLOYERS.
RETIREE BENEFIT TRUST FUND IN
THE CURRENT FISCAL YEAR TO
SATISFY THE SATISFY THE STATE'S
PROPOSITION TWO DEBT REPAYMENT
ALLOCATION FOR THE RELEVANT
FISCAL YEAR. AND WITH THAT,
WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE ON AN
EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION ITEMS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE'RE
GOING TO GO ON TO LÀ Þ, NICK
SCHROEDER WITH THE LAO. WE HAVE
NO PREPARED STATEMENTS, BUT ARE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT THE COMMITTEE MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU. COLLEAGUES, DO YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS? QUESTIONS
SENATOR SEYARTO OKAY, SO WE'RE
WE'RE SUPPLANTING, NOT
SUPPLEMENTING MONEY IN THE
STATE, CALPERS, FROM OUR DEBT,
OUR PROP TWO DEBT IS THAT WE'RE
DOING IS THAT EVEN LIKE
CONSTITUTION, THE 420 MILLION IS
PROPOSED AS A SUPPLEMENTAL
PENSION PAYMENT, I BELIEVE YOU
MAY BE REFERRING TO THE 1.3
BILLION OR 1.7 BILLION, FROM THE
PRIOR YEAR, WHICH, WE ARE
PROPOSING ARE UNDER, THE EARLY
ACTION AGREEMENT, AB 106,
CHAPTER NINE, STATUTES OF 2024,
WE ARE PROPOSING TO APPLY TO THE
, UNFUNDED LIABILITY IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. LEO, IS THERE AN
ISSUE WITH THAT, SO EARLIER IN
THIS PROCESS, IN MARCH, WE
RELEASED AN ANALYSIS OF THIS
ISSUE, AND AT THAT TIME WE DID
INDICATE THAT OR RAISED SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY OF USING THE
2324, PROPOSITION TWO DEBT
REPAYMENT TO REDUCE THE STATE'S
CALPERS CONTRIBUTIONS IN 24, 25
AND AS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
INDICATED. AND THE PROPOSAL WAS
ADOPTED AS PART OF THE EARLY
ACTION. THAT BEING SAID, THE
2425 BUDGET ITSELF HAS NOT BEEN
ADOPTED YET, AND SO BECAUSE OF
THAT, WELL, BECAUSE OF THAT, THE
LEGISLATURE CAN STILL CHOOSE NOT
TO DO THAT. HOWEVER, IT WOULD
REQUIRE REVISITING THE EARLY
ACTION AGREEMENT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THAT'S ALL. ALL RIGHT
, WE'LL BE HOLDING THIS ITEM
OPEN AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
THREE. THANK YOU. ISSUE NUMBER
THREE IS THE OVERVIEW OF
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
PROPOSALS. HENRY. I DON'T KNOW
HOW TO PRONOUNCE THE LAST NAME
NHîNG. HOW DO YOU PRONOUNCE NG?
NO MÁS NINE NINE HENRY NOGHAI,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. ANITA
LEE, PRINCIPAL FISCAL AND POLICY
ANALYST, LAO DREW SODERBERG,
DEPUTY LEGISLATIVE ANALYST FROM
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE, ISSUE NUMBER THREE.
AGAIN, ALL REPRESENTATIVES FROM
THE DEPARTMENTS ARE AVAILABLE
FOR ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AND
DETAILS. BUT ISSUE NUMBER THREE
COVERS THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION PROPOSALS FOR JUDICIAL
BRANCH. FIRST, WE'RE GOING TO
HEAR FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING, HENRY NG, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. I WILL BE HIGHLIGHTING
A FEW OF THE NOTABLE ADJUSTMENTS
PROPOSED IN THE MAY REVISION FOR
THE JUDICIAL BRANCHES BUDGET.
THE MAY REVISION INCLUDES EARLY
REVISIONS OF SAVINGS IDENTIFIED
BY THE JUDICIAL BRANCH FOR THE
FOLLOWING. THIS INCLUDES 60
MILLION FROM THE FUNDING
PROVIDED TO THE COURTS TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF COURT
REPORTERS AND FAMILY LAW AND
CIVIL CASES, 20 MILLION FROM ONE
TIME FUNDING THAT WAS PROVIDED
FOR COURT INTERPRETER GRANTS AND
17.6 MILLION FROM TRIBAL COURTS
FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION OF CARE
COURT, THIS IS LOWERED IN ANTICIPATED,
THIS ORDER OF 5 MILLION
OPERATIONAL SAVINGS AND THE MAY
REVISION ALSO INCLUDES THE
FOLLOWING GENERAL FUND SOLUTIONS
STARTING IN 20 2425, A ONE TIME,
25 MILLION UNRESTRICTED FUND
BALANCE TRANSFER. TO THE GENERAL
FUND IN 20 2425. THIS BRINGS THE
TOTAL AMOUNT UP TO 105 MILLION.
BECAUSE WE HAVE PROPOSED A
TRANSFER OF 80 MILLION BUDGET
AND PROPOSING ANOTHER TRANSFER
OF 25 MILLION IN THE BAY
REVISION, THERE, WE'RE ALSO
PROPOSING A ONGOING REDUCTION OF
10 MILLION FOR COURT REPORTERS,
AND THIS IS TO ALIGN WITH THE
ACTUAL EXPENDITURES WITH TRIAL
COURTS. BUT THIS STILL LEAVES 20
MILLION, AVAILABLE FOR THE
PROGRAM. AND WE'RE ALSO
PROPOSING A ONGOING REDUCTION OF
97 MILLION TO TRIAL COURT
OPERATIONS, THIS IS CONSISTENT
WITH THE STATEWIDE APPROACH TO
REDUCE STATE OPERATIONS BY THE
7.95, HOWEVER, THE MAY REVISION
DOES PROVIDE, RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT THE JUDICIAL BRANCH, AND
THEY INCLUDE 21 MILLION ONGOING
GENERAL FUND FOR TRIAL COURT
EMPLOYEE AND RETIREMENT
BENEFITS, AND ONGOING RESOURCES
TO IMPLEMENT SB 331, INCLUDING
FOUR POSITIONS AND 1.1 MILLION
GENERAL FUND AND 150,000 FAMILY
LAW TRUST FUND. IN 20 2425, 1.1
MILLION GENERAL FUND AND 210,000
FAMILY LAW TRUST FUND IN 2025,
26 AND 1.1 MILLION GENERAL FUND
IN 2026 AND 2027. ONGOING, THESE
RESOURCES WILL ALLOW THE COURTS
TO EXPAND ON THE YEAR ON THEIR
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS AND
MATERIALS RELATED TO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND POST-CONVICTION
PROBATION SUPERVISION, I ALSO
WANT TO NOTE THAT THE MAY
REVISION INCLUDES ONGOING
REDUCTIONS TO RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO IMPLEMENT THE CARE
ACT. AGAIN THIS IS BASED ON THE
UPDATED CASELOAD ESTIMATES, AND
THE SPECIAL FUND BACKFILLS,
BASED ON UPDATED REVENUES, AND
LASTLY, I JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT
THE JUDICIAL BRANCH IS ALSO
REQUESTING 11.5 MILLION IN
SUPPLEMENTAL LEASE REVENUE BOND
AUTHORITY, THIS IS TO COMPLETE
THE CONSTRUCTION OF TWO NEW,
COURTHOUSES IN SANTA ROSA. THIS
CONCLUDES MY OVERVIEW. I AM
JOINED BY MY COLLEAGUES OF THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH AND FINANCE, AND
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU, WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO LÀ. Þ ANITA LEE
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE, JUST AS OVERARCHING
COMMENTS, THE PUBLIC SAFETY
PROPOSALS WHICH ARE COVERED ON
ISSUES THREE THROUGH EIGHT OF
YOUR AGENDA, OUR OFFICE ARE
STILL IN THE PROCESS OF
REVIEWING AND WILL BE PROVIDING
RECOMMENDATIONS AND COMMENTS TO
THE, TO THE COMMITTEE IN THE
COMING DAYS. WITH THAT IN MIND,
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH, I THINK THAT
THERE ARE SOME HIGH LEVEL
COMMENTS WE WANTED TO PROVIDE
RELATED TO TWO OF THE PROPOSALS,
THE FIRST PROPOSAL RELATES TO
THE REDUCTION TO TRIAL COURT
OPERATIONS, ABSENT ANY SPECIFIC
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTION, JUDICIAL
COUNCIL WOULD HAVE THE
DISCRETION ON HOW TO DISTRIBUTE
THOSE REDUCTIONS TO THE
INDIVIDUAL TRIAL COURTS. ONE
POSSIBLE WAY THIS COULD HAPPEN
IS THROUGH THE JUDICIAL BRANCHES
WORKLOAD FORMULA, WHICH COULD BE
REASONABLE BECAUSE THAT'S
GENERALLY BASED ON WORKLOAD, BUT
IT COULD BE DISTRIBUTED IN OTHER
WAYS AS WELL. SO TO THE EXTENT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS CLEAR
PRIORITIES FOR HOW THEY WANT THE
REDUCTIONS TO BE IMPLEMENTED, WE
WOULD RECOMMEND ADOPTING BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE TO SPECIFY THAT
BECAUSE IN THE ABSENCE OF THAT
LANGUAGE, TRIAL COURTS WOULD
HAVE DISCRETION IN HOW THEY
IMPLEMENT THE REDUCTIONS. AND
THIS COULD MEAN THAT YOU HAVE
DIFFERENT WORKLOAD OR SERVICE
DELAYS, REDUCTIONS OR BACKLOGS
THAT ARE REFLECTED AT THE
INDIVIDUAL TRIAL COURTS. OUR
SECOND SET OF COMMENTS IS
RELATED TO THE PROPOSED
REDUCTIONS, RELATED TO THE COURT
REPORTERS IN 20 2122. THE BUDGET
INCLUDED 30 MILLION IN
DEDICATED, ONGOING GENERAL FUND
SUPPORT TO INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF COURT REPORTERS IN CIVIL AND
FAMILY LAW PROCEEDINGS, THE
COURTS HAVE USED THIS MONEY IN A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT WAYS,
INCLUDING TO INCREASE EXISTING
COURT REPORTER SALARIES, AS WELL
AS OFFERING RETENTION AND
SIGNING BONUSES, AS OUR
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE ARE
TRIAL COURTS THAT EFFECTIVELY
ENTERED INTO LABOR AGREEMENTS
THAT WOULD DICTATE SORT OF HOW
THIS MONEY MAY NEED TO BE USED.
SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
WANTED TO FLAG FOR THE
COMMITTEE, JUST TO KEEP IN MIND,
BECAUSE THAT COULD MEAN THAT THE
EXTENT TO WHICH THE DESIRED
SAVINGS ARE ACHIEVABLE IS, IS
UNCLEAR. SO AS AN EXAMPLE OF
THAT, THE PROPOSAL WOULD REDUCE
IN 2024 THE AMOUNT PROVIDED BY
$10 MILLION IN A SURVEY THAT WAS
DONE BY JUDICIAL COUNSEL, THE
TRIAL COURTS WERE ESTIMATING
THAT THE AT THE END OF 2324,
THEY THOUGHT ONLY 6.4 MILLION
WOULD BE UNSPENT. AND SO YOU CAN
SEE THERE'S ALREADY SLIGHTLY A
MISMATCH THERE. SO IF WE WERE
GOING TO ACHIEVE THAT HIGHER
LEVEL OF SAVINGS WHICH IS
CURRENTLY INCLUDED IN THE
BUDGET, IT COULD BE POTENTIALLY
CHALLENGING UNTIL WE RENEGOTIATE
SOME OF THESE LABOR AGREEMENTS,
BECAUSE UNTIL THEY'RE
RENEGOTIATED, THEY WOULD REMAIN
IN EFFECT. SO I THINK THOSE ARE
KIND OF THE TWO COMMENTS, HIGH
LEVEL COMMENTS THAT WE WANTED TO
PROVIDE FOR THE COMMITTEE. AS
YOU CONSIDER THESE PROPOSALS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
ANY COMMENTS FROM PANELISTS?
SENATOR DURAZZO, THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR, THANK YOU. TO THE
LAO, JUST WITH REGARDS TO THE
COURT REPORTER AND THE
INTERPRETER, REDUCTION ÓRDENES.
THE WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING THIS
FOR SEVERAL YEARS NOW, THE NEED,
THE URGENT NEED FOR BOTH COURT
REPORTERS AND FOR INTERPRETERS
IS. SO I GUESS MY QUESTION,
CONSIDERING THERE'S AN ENORMOUS
NEED, PEOPLE'S LIVELIHOOD IN THE
SENSE ARE ON THE LINE BECAUSE SO
MUCH CAN HAPPEN IN A, IN A
COURTROOM THAT IMPACTS THEIR
FUTURE LIVES, CURRENT AND FUTURE
LIVES. SO I GUESS MY, MY
QUESTION AND I AND I, I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S SOME, EITHER
PROPOSAL OR THOUGHTS ABOUT,
PILOT PROGRAMS THAT HELP RECRUIT
TALKING SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE
COURT REPORTER THAT HELP
RECRUIT, APPLICANTS, IT'S A VERY
HIGH PAYING, VERY, VERY HIGH
PAYING JOB. AND IT'S SUCH A
SHAME THAT WE HAVEN'T, YOU KNOW,
WITH A HIGH DEMAND, HIGH PAYING
JOBS, YOU KNOW, OVER 100,000,
PROBABLY PLUS A YEAR THAT WE
COULDN'T DO MORE TO HELP FILL
THAT NEED, AND IT'S A NEED IN
ALL LEVELS. SO WITH THAT,
SIMILAR TO THE, COURT
INTERPRETER USED KING FUNDING
THAT, FOR EXAMPLE, WOULD HELP
PAY APPLICANTS EDUCATION COSTS
OR, MAKE SURE THAT THAT COURT
REPORTER IS GOING TO HAVE THE
JOB, SO WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THESE
IDEAS, BUT HERE'S A TIME WHEN WE
SHOULDN'T LET GO OF THAT. WE'RE
REALLY MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AS FAR AS
CONVERSATIONS TO MAKE IT REAL,
AND THIS REVERTING FUNDING THAT
WAS ALREADY OURS. AND NOW TO
GIVE IT BACK AND GIVE IT AWAY, I
THINK IS A BIG, BIG SHAME. SO
AGAIN, WITH THE COURT
INTERPRETERS USING, A PORTION OF
ONE TIME FOR RECRUITMENT
BONUSES, THOSE HELP US GET THERE
WITH, WITH THOSE IDEAS. AND SO
THAT NEXT YEAR WE'RE NOT AGAIN
N IN THIS CRISIS OR A WORSE
CRISIS SITUATION. YES. YES. YOU
AGREE? YEAH. ALL RIGHT, JUDGE
MARIA HERNANDEZ, I WOULD
CERTAINLY AGREE. I'M THE
PRESIDING JUDGE FROM ORANGE
COUNTY AND THE CHAIR OF OUR TCP
JACKET, AND WE WANT TO BE GOOD
PARTNERS. WE'RE COMING TO THE
TABLE WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
BRANCH AS WELL AS THE GOVERNOR'S
ADMINISTRATION. BUT WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED OVER THE OVERALL
IMPACT ON THE REDUCTION AND WHAT
THAT MEANS TO ACCESS TO JUSTICE
FOR AS SENATOR WAHAB STATED, THE
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATION THAT
WE SERVE. AND TO YOUR POINT,
SENATOR DURAZO, WE DON'T HAVE
VERBATIM RECORDS WHEN WE DON'T
HAVE COURT REPORTERS SITTING IN
THOSE CHAIRS AND TALKING ABOUT
THEIR LIVELIHOODS. BUT THE
PEOPLE THAT WE ARE SERVING
DESERVE THEIR RECORDS AND
PRESERVE THAT ACCESS TO JUSTICE.
SO WE HAVE GREAT CONCERNS ABOUT
THE REDUCTIONS AND WHAT THAT
MEANS CUTTING HOURS, SHUTTERING
DOORS, NOT BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE
THE SERVICES AND THE RESOURCES
THAT WE ALL KNOW ARE NEEDED TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE TO OUR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. THANK YOU,
SENATOR COR. THANK YOU. I HAVE A
QUESTION, CONCERNING OR
CONCERNING THE, TRIAL COURT
TRUST FUND. BACKFILLS CURRENTLY,
THE STATE HAS BEEN BACKFILLING
BECAUSE WE RUN SHORT ON
REVENUES. WE NEED TO RUN THE
COURTS AND ALL OF ALL OF THE
THINGS NECESSARY TO MAINTAIN
THOSE COURTS. AND THIS IS
LOOKING LIKE A 45, I DON'T KNOW,
$45 MILLION THAT THEY'RE
REDUCING IT BY, DID THEY DID
DOES THE STATE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FOLKS, DID THEY
ANTICIPATE THAT THIS NEED IS
GOING AWAY OR BECAUSE GENERAL
FUND REVENUES ARE GOING DOWN? SO
THAT'S ONLY GOING TO GET WIDER,
BECAUSE IT'S ALMOST SEEMS LIKE
JUST A MANEUVER TO MAKE IT LOOK
LIKE WE DON'T WE'RE NOT GOING TO
BE SPENDING AS MUCH WHEN WE
ACTUALLY ARE BECAUSE WE CAN'T
JUST SHUTTER FACILITIES. YEAH.
EMMA JUNGWIRTH, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THIS IS JUST AN ANNUAL
ADJUSTMENT THAT WE DO EVERY
YEAR, FOR THE TRIAL COURT, TRUST
FUND, BACKFILL, WHERE WE ASSESS
THE REVENUES THAT ARE COMING
INTO THE TÊ CGRTS AND PROVIDING
A BACKFILL TO KEEP THEM WHOLE.
SO WHILE IT LOOKS LIKE, WELL,
WHILE IT IS A $45 MILLION
REDUCTION, IT IS TRULY TO ALIGN
WITH THE REVENUES THAT ARE
COMING INTO INTO THE TCTC TCTF
ITSELF, AND SO THERE IS A TOTAL
AMOUNT Dð SAU C  DO YOU HAVE
THAT BY CHANCE? I DON'T HAVE OFF
THE TOP OF MY HEAD, BUT THERE IS
A TOTAL AMOUNT THAT WE HAVE
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET. THE
REVENUES ARE GOING UP IN THE IN
THE TRIAL COURT TRUST FUND, THE
TRIAL COURT TRUST FUND WITHOUT
THE STATE INPUT. YES. SO WE'RE
JUST KIND OF KEEPING THAT
BALANCE. IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING? OKAY. THANK YOU. YEAH.
CIVIL FILINGS HAVE IMPROVED OVER
THE LAST YEAR. AND SO THAT
GENERATES ADDITIONAL REVENUES
FOR THE BRANCH. ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR. ALL RIGHT, SO I'M JUST
GOING TO MAKE MY COMMENTS ABOUT
THE JUDICIAL BRANCH. I THINK
IT'S OFTEN OVERLOOKED AS, AS,
VERY MUCH AN IMPORTANT PART OF
OUR SOCIETY AND NOT NECESSARILY
PRIORITIZED IN A LOT OF THE
BILLS THAT WE INTRODUCED, LET
ALONE A BUDGET REQUEST. SO I
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND THAT, I
ALSO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT AND ECHO
SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT WERE
MADE. I DEEPLY CARE ABOUT THE
INTERPRETERS, SPECIFICALLY, YOU
KNOW, CALIFORNIA BEING AS
DIVERSE AS IT IS, AND I OFTEN,
KIND OF STATE, YOU KNOW, EVEN IN
MY OWN POSITION, I'M A MINORITY
AMONGST MINORITIES. AND OFTEN I
SEE THE ELDERS IN MY COMMUNITY
NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED. RIGHT. IT'S NOT ONE OF THE
DOMINANT LANGUAGES. IT'S NOT ONE
OF THE DOMINANT CULTURES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, BUT JUST AS
EVERYBODY, THEY ALSO NEED
INTERPRETERS. THEY NEED
TRANSLATORS, THEY NEED
INDIVIDUALS THAT CAN KIND OF
WALK THEM THROUGH WHAT'S GOING
ON, ESPECIALLY AS DAUNTING AND
SCARY AS GOING TO COURT CAN BE
FOR SO MANY OF THEM. RIGHT SO I
PERSONALLY AND AGAIN, I JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT I DO
THINK THAT WE NEED TO MAINTAIN
WHAT WE'RE DOING FOR THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH. FIRST AND
FOREMOST, I KNOW I'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE CHIEF
JUSTICE AS WELL, WHO'S BEEN
ADVOCATING FOR KIND OF
MAINSTREAMING AND STREAMLINING A
LOT OF THE EFFORTS IN THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH, SPECIFICALLY,
AND I'VE STATED THAT STATED THIS
MULTIPLE TIMES, EVEN IN THE LAST
TIME YOU GUYS WERE HERE IS IF WE
CAN HAVE EXTENDED HOURS, RIGHT.
IF PEOPLE ARE WORKING 9 TO 5,
THEY CANNOT GO TO COURT, RIGHT?
AND SOMETIMES THEY JUST SIGN
SOMETHING. PEOPLE OFTEN TALK
ABOUT PLEA PLEA BARGAINS AND
PLEA DEALS, JUST BECAUSE IT'S SO
DAUNTING. BUT I WILL GO EVEN A
STEP FURTHER THAT EVEN ON SOME
VERY SMALL INFRACTIONS, THESE,
PEOPLE TAKE A DEEPER HIT,
WHETHER IT'S THEIR INSURANCE OR
WHETHER IT'S JUST PAYING THE FEE
AND SO FORTH, JUST BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T ATTEND A COURT
APPOINTMENT. SO FOR ARRAIGNMENTS
AND THINGS LIKE THAT, I
GENUINELY BELIEVE THAT IT SHOULD
BE SUPER QUICK AND SUPER FAST
AND POTENTIALLY JUST ONLINE FOR
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO DO IT, I
KNOW I TOLD THE CHIEF JUSTICE, I
THINK YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO GET
AN EMAIL, CLICK A BUTTON, MOVE
ON, SHE SAID, I THINK YOU'RE
AHEAD OF LIKE WHERE THE REST OF
SOCIETY WANTS TO GO WITH THAT,
AND THEN ALSO JUST EVEN THE
COURT CASES, RIGHT, YOU KNOW,
THEY GET DOCUMENT, THEY SPEND
LITERALLY POTENTIALLY THE WHOLE
DAY, EIGHT HOURS, AND THERE'S NO
CLEAR COMMITMENT OF WHEN THEIR
TIME IS FOR THEIR ACTUAL CASE.
RIGHT THAT IS A PROBLEM FOR
REGULAR PEOPLE. RIGHT. AND I
OFTEN STATE THIS IN REGARDS TO
OUR FISCAL DEFICITS, IS THAT WE
SHOULD ALSO TAKE A LOOK AT IT AS
AN OPPORTUNITY K¾T TO FIX
SYSTEMS THAT ARE NOT AS
EFFICIENT, AND I THINK THAT THIS
IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH TO REALLY THINK
ABOUT HOW THEY CAN POTENTIALLY
EITHER PROVIDE WEEKEND OR A
LITTLE BIT LATE NIGHT SERVICES.
AND I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
WALK IN COURTS. YOU KNOW, THAT
HAPPENED ONCE OR TWICE A MONTH
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT. I'M
TALKING ABOUT MORE ROBUST, LATER
TIMING. RIGHT, BECAUSE THE 9 TO
5 DOESN'T ALWAYS WORK. AND, AND
I KNOW IT'S NOT MOST COURTS, AT
LEAST IN MY COUNTY, IT'S NOT
EVEN 9 TO 5. IT'S LIKE 9 TO 4 OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT. SO IT'S NOT
FAIR TO THE AVERAGE SOCIETY,
WHETHER THEY THEY ARE ACCUSED OF
SOMETHING OR NOT. THOSE TIME
FRAMES DO NOT WORK FOR WORKING
PEOPLE. RIGHT. SO, AGAIN, I DO
CARE ABOUT THE INTERPRETERS AND
THE REPORTERS, AND I THINK IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO, BE ABLE
TO MAINTAIN THE, THE INTEGRITY
TÊ OF THE COURT RECORDS AS WELL
AS MUCH MORE. SO I'M HOPING THAT
WE CAN KIND OF FIGURE OUT WHAT
WE'RE DOING HERE. SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. WE'LL MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SO
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR, I ALWAYS MESS
UP ANTHONY FRANZONI. YEAH FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. ANITA
LI FROM LAO DREW SODERBERG. LAO
ISSUE NUMBER THREE COVERS THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION PROPOSAL
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
WE'RE FIRST GOING TO HEAR FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO
WHEN YOU'RE READY, PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE. AND
PERFECT PRONUNCIATION ON THE
LAST NAME. THANK YOU, ANTHONY
FRANZOY FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, I WILL BE HIGHLIGHTING
A HANDFUL OF ADJUSTMENTS
INCLUDED IN THE MAY REVISION FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE'S
BUDGET, FIRST AND FOREMOST, IT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. WE PROPOSED
$100 MILLION LOAN FROM THE
LITIGATION DEPOSITS FUND GOING
TO THE GENERAL FUND IN 2425, BUT
GIVEN SOME STATUTORY CHANGES, WE
ARE NOW PROPOSING TO SWITCH THE
FUND SOURCE TO THE UNFAIR
COMPETITION LAW FUND AND THEN
ADDITIONALLY, THE MAYOR DIVISION
IS PROPOSING ANOTHER $30 MILLION
LOAN FROM THE UNFAIR COMPETITION
LAW FUND FOR A TOTAL OF $130
MILLION IN 2425, MOVING ON TO
WORKLOAD, BC IS AT A HIGH LEVEL.
THERE ARE ONGOING RESOURCES FOR
SIX WORKLOAD BC AND 2425. THESE
AMOUNT TO $30.7 MILLION AND 93
POSITIONS. THE GENERAL FUND
PORTION OF THAT IS $12.8 MILLION
AND EIGHT POSITIONS. THE SPECIAL
FUND COMPONENT IS $17.9 MILLION
AND 85 POSITIONS IS, QUICKLY ON
CHAPTER LEGISLATION, BC THERE
ARE ONGOING RESOURCES FOR 13
CHAPTER LEDGE BC IS IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. THESE TOTAL 17.4
5,000,047 POSITIONS. THE GENERAL
FUND COMPONENT ABOUT $15.9
MILLION AND 41 POSITIONS. THE
SPECIAL FUND COMPONENT A LITTLE
BIT SMALLER AT 1.4 7,000,006
POSITIONS, IN TERMS OF GENERAL
FUND SOLUTIONS, THERE ARE TWO
INCLUDED FOR DOJ IN THE MAY
REVISION, THE FIRST IS A $15
MILLION ONGOING REDUCTION FOR
THE DIVISION OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND THE DIVISION OF LEGAL
SERVICES. THAT WILL BE A $10
MILLION REDUCTION FOR THE
DIVISION OF LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
A $5 MILLION REDUCTION FOR LEGAL
SERVICES, DOJ HAS THE
FLEXIBILITY TO DETERMINE EXACTLY
HOW IT IMPLEMENTS THIS
REDUCTION. WE'RE NOT BEING
PRESCRIPTIVE IN TERMS OF WHAT
DOJ NEEDS TO CUT TO MEET THE
TARGET, GIVEN THE FACT THAT THE
DIVISION HAS ONLY JUST BEEN
RELEASED, I DON'T THINK DOJ HAS
A LOT OF SPECIFICS ON WHAT WILL
GO INTO THAT $15 MILLION, BUT
BOTH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND DOJ ARE WORKING TOGETHER ON
THAT, AND WE'RE COMMITTED TO
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE OVER THE COMING
WEEKS, THE SECOND SMALLER
SOLUTION IS A $3 MILLION ONGOING
REDUCTION FOR THE DIVISION OF
MEDI-CAL FRAUD AND ELDER ABUSE
AND FOR THE DEPARTMENT'S
DEFENDING CALIFORNIA RESOURCES,
WHICH I'LL REFER TO AS DECAL,
FOR THE DIVISION OF MEDI-CAL
FRAUD AND ELDER ABUSE. THERE'S A
$2 MILLION FUND SWAP BETWEEN THE
GENERAL FUND AND FALSE CLAIMS
ACT FUND. BASICALLY WE WOULD
REDUCE, DOJ'S GENERAL FUND ITEMS
SUPPORTING DMV BY $2 MILLION AND
THEN INCREASE THE FALSE CLAIMS
ACT FUND ITEM BY $2 MILLION. SO
OFFSETTING SOME GENERAL FUND
EXPENSES. AND THEN FOR DECAL, IT
WOULD JUST BE A $1 MILLION
ONGOING REDUCTION TO THOSE
RESOURCES. AND THAT CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. LEO ANITA LEE WITH
THE LAO SO SIMILAR TO THE PRIOR
ISSUE, WE HAVE A COUPLE OF
INITIAL HIGH LEVEL COMMENTS FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. THE FIRST IS
RELATED TO THE PROPOSED $10
MILLION REDUCTION TO THE
DIVISION OF LAW ENFORCEMENT.
ALSO KNOWN AS DLI. DLI GENERALLY
SUPPORTS DOJ TASK FORCES AND
INVESTIGATION TEAMS, AS WELL AS
THE BUREAU OF FIREARMS, THE
BUREAU OF FORENSIC SERVICES, AND
THE BUREAU OF GAMBLING CONTROL.
ALL OF THESE, WITH THE EXCEPTION
OF THE BUREAU OF GAMBLING
CONTROL, DO RECEIVE GENERAL FUND
SUPPORT, AND SO THE LEGISLATURE
MIGHT WANT TO CONSIDER WHETHER
IT WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE DOJ
WITH DIRECTION ON HOW TO
IMPLEMENT THE REDUCTION, IF THE
LEGISLATURE HAS CLEAR
PRIORITIES. SO, FOR EXAMPLE, THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT HAVE A
PRIORITY THAT CERTAIN TASK
FORCES OR TEAMS MAINTAIN
OPERATIONS AS A PRIORITY TÊ OVER
OTHERS. SO THAT'S JUST AN
EXAMPLE SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO
THE BUREAU OF FORENSIC SERVICES.
WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE STATE HAS
PROVIDED GENERAL FUND SUPPORT
SINCE 20 1617 TO BACKFILL A
DECLINE OF CRIMINAL FINE AND FEE
REVENUE THAT SUPPORTS ITS
OPERATIONS. AND SO MOST RECENTLY
, THE 20 2324 BUDGET. SO LAST
YEAR'S BUDGET, PROVIDED 46.1
MILLION OF A GENERAL FUND
BACKFILL FOR THREE YEARS, AND
THAT BACKFILL CAN ALSO BE
INCREASED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IF MORE MONEY IS NEEDED
THROUGH A SECTION LETTER PROCESS
, AND WE DID WANT TO NOTE AND
REMIND THE COMMITTEE THAT OUR
OFFICE HAS MADE PRIOR
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY REDUCE THAT AMOUNT
OF GENERAL FUND THAT'S NEEDED TO
SUPPORT BFS. SPECIFICALLY, WE
HAVE RECOMMENDED REQUIRING THAT
USERS OF DFS SERVICES BE
DIRECTED TO PARTIALLY SUPPORT A
COST OF ITS OPERATIONS, AND THIS
WOULD MINIMIZE, AGAIN, THE
IMPACT ON THE GENERAL FUND, AS
WELL AS PROVIDE USERS WITH
GREATER INCENTIVE TO THINK ABOUT
THE WORKLOAD THAT THEY ARE
SUBMITTING TO THE BUREAU, WE
RAISE THIS AGAIN BECAUSE GIVEN
THE STATE'S BUDGET SITUATION,
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THE
COMMITTEE MAY WANT TO CONSIDER
IN ADDITION OR IN LIEU TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL, THE SECOND
SET OF OUR COMMENTS RELATE TO
SIX FIREARM RELATED BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSALS THAT WERE
INCLUDED AS PART OF THE MAY
REVISION. THESE SIX PROPOSALS
TOTAL 15.5 MILLION FROM THE
GENERAL FUND IN 2024, 25
DECLINED TO 8.1 MILLION ANNUALLY
BEGINNING IN 2728. WE GENERALLY
DON'T HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
DOLLAR AMOUNT, BUT WE DO
QUESTION WHETHER THE GENERAL
FUND IS THE APPROPRIATE SOURCE
TO BE PAYING FOR THIS,
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE STATE'S
BUDGET SITUATION, SPECIFICALLY,
WE WOULD NOTE THAT THESE COSTS
COULD POTENTIALLY BE SUPPORTED
BY THE STATE'S FIREARM RELATED
SPECIAL FUNDS, WHICH WOULD
INCLUDE THE DEALER'S RECORD OF
SALE, SPECIAL ACCOUNT OR DRAWS,
WHICH THE COMMITTEE HAS
DISCUSSED IN THE PAST. THE DRAWS
FUND IS AUTHORIZED BY STATE LAW
TO SUPPORT A WIDE RANGE OF
FIREARM RELATED PROGRAMS AND
ACTIVITIES. SO A KEY EXAMPLE OF
THAT IS ONE OF THE PROPOSALS ON
THIS LIST IS THE FIREARM IT
SYSTEM MODERNIZATION PROJECT, OR
THE FITSUM PROJECT THAT WOULD
REPLACE A NUMBER OF EXISTING
SYSTEMS, ABOUT 17 OF THEM. AND
SO THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
PROPOSES FUNDING FOR THE NEXT
STEP. BUT FROM THE GENERAL FUND
AND PRIOR ITERATIONS OF
REQUESTED FUNDING HAVE ACTUALLY
COME FROM DRO. SO THAT'S KIND OF
AN EXAMPLE, OF THAT FUNDING
THESE TYPES OF PROPOSALS FROM
FEE REVENUE THAT GO INTO THE
FIREARM RELATED SPECIAL FUNDS
WOULD MERIT CONSIDERATION GIVEN
THE STATE'S BUDGET SITUATION. WE
DO NOTE THAT THERE COULD BE
CONCERNS RELATED TO THE SOLVENCY
OF DRAWS. AND SO THE LEGISLATURE
COULD EITHER CONSIDER INCREASING
THE DRAWS FEE AND OR PROVIDING A
GENERAL FUND LOAN THAT WOULD BE
REPAID FROM DRAWS. OUR FINAL
COMMENTS IS SPECIFICALLY RELATED
TO FITSUM, THE FITSUM PROJECT IS
GETTING CLOSE TO THE STAGE WHERE
IT MIGHT THEN BE BUILT. YOU
DON'T HAVE A PROPOSAL FOR THAT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING, BUT WE
THOUGHT WE WOULD FLAG FOR THE
COMMITTEE THAT IT COULD COST A
COUPLE HUNDRED, MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO BUILD. SO GIVEN THIS
UPCOMING COST, THE LEGISLATURE
MAY ALSO WANT TO CONSIDER
DIRECTING DOJ TO PROVIDE AN
ASSESSMENT OF HOW MUCH FEE
REVENUES MAY NEED TO BE
INCREASED TO COVER THAT COST,
AND THE LEGISLATURE COULD THEN
USE THAT INFORMATION TO
DETERMINE HOW MUCH TO INCREASE
THE FEE WHILE BALANCING ITS
PRIORITIES, AND BY BALANCING ITS
PRIORITIES. IT CAN INCLUDE
ENSURING THAT THERE'S SUFFICIENT
MONIES FOR ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES, WHILE ALSO BALANCING
HOW MUCH FIREARM PURCHASERS ARE
BEING ASKED TO PAY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SENATOR SATO. ALL
RIGHT. RIGHT NOW WE HAVE, WHAT,
$4.7 MILLION IN 24, 25, ANOTHER
4.7 IN 25, 26. AND DOES THAT
SECOND FOR THE I'M SORRY FOR THE
CLIMATE LITIGATION NUISANCE,
LOOSE CLIMATE NUISANCE
LITIGATION AGAINST THE OIL
COMPANIES. SO THAT'S $5 BILLION
OR SO. IS IT $10 MILLION TOTAL
OR IS IT 15. IN OTHER WORDS IS
THAT SECOND 4.7. IS THAT FOR THE
NEXT TWO YEARS? ANTHONY FRANZOY
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IT'S
CORRECT. IT'S $4.7 MILLION IN
24, 25, 25, 26 AND 2627. SO
THREE ADDITIONAL YEARS OF
FUNDING. SO $15 MILLION TO CHASE
AFTER A CLIMATE NUISANCE
LAWSUIT, CORRECT? I WILL NOTE
THAT THE 2023 BUDGET ACT ALREADY
APPROPRIATED AND I THINK $3.8
MILLION ONE TIME, THAT WAS
GENERAL FUND. YEAH. AND THESE
ARE SPECIAL FUND RESOURCES. OKAY
BECAUSE THAT'S ABSURD. THAT'S
THAT'S RIDICULOUS. THAT'S A
RIDICULOUS EXPENDITURE OF MONEY,
AND THEN THE OTHER ONE IS AGAIN,
THE FIREARMS INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SYSTEMS. WE HAVEN'T
HAD A VERY GOOD TRACK RECORD
WITH THIS STUFF, WITH OUR IT
SYSTEMS SHIFTS AND STUFF AND
THOSE ARE THE KIND OF PROJECTS
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT A BUDGET
THAT NEEDS TO BE CUT
DRASTICALLY. YOU KNOW, THERE ARE
SOME PROGRAMS THAT DON'T DON'T
NEED TO BE DONE RIGHT NOW,
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
HAVE AN IMMEDIATE IMPACT ON THE
LIVES OF ANYBODY. AND SO, YOU
KNOW, I WOULD LIKE TO SEE US
BEING A LITTLE BIT MORE, I DON'T
KNOW, CAREFUL ABOUT WHAT KIND OF
PROGRAMS WE'RE CUTTING VERSUS
WHAT KIND OF PROGRAMS CAN SIT
AND WAIT FOR A LITTLE BIT. AND,
AND I'M GOING TO TAKE ONE THAT'S
A LITTLE OUT OF OUR CONTEXT, BUT
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT $500
MILLION FOR ELECTRIC BUSSES, AND
WE'RE CUTTING $10 MILLION FROM,
FROM SOME OF OUR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT STUFF, THAT DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE. SOME OF THAT STUFF
CAN WAIT A COUPLE OF YEARS WHILE
WE'RE IN THIS CRISIS, WHILE WE
DIG OURSELVES OUT OF THIS
SELF-IMPOSED CRISIS, OUR
SELF-GENERATED CRISIS, THAT'S
NOT IN A RECESSION, THAT'S THE
KIND OF TOUGH KIND OF CUTS THAT
WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT. AND YET
I DON'T SEE THOSE. I SEE US
FUNDING A RIDICULOUS LAWSUIT FOR
$15 MILLION FOR THE NEXT TWO
YEARS THAT I DOUBT VERY MUCH
THAT WE'RE GOING TO PREVAIL IN,
SO, I THINK THERE'S A LOT MORE
WORK TO BE DONE. AND ROOTING
OUT, SOME OF THE NONSENSICAL,
EXPENDITURES THAT WE'RE USING MY
TAXPAYER MONEY AND OTHER
TAXPAYERS MONIES FOR, BECAUSE
THAT'S STUFF LIKE THAT IS NOT
NOT THE STUFF THAT WE THINK IS
VERY HELPFUL IN OUR LIVES. AND
SO, THOSE ARE THE ONLY COMMENTS
I HAVE, ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR
SECTION, BUT THERE'S A LOT OF
WORK THAT NEEDS DONE IN THE DOJ
TO FERRET OUT, STUFF THAT IS
ACTUALLY USEFUL, VERSUS STUFF
THAT IS MORE OF A MESSAGING TOOL
BECAUSE THOSE MESSAGES ARE
REALLY, REALLY EXPENSIVE TO US,
THE TAXPAYERS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR DURAZO. THANK YOU,
HOPEFULLY THIS IS NOT OUT OF
ORDER, BUT THERE THERE WAS IN
THE, ORIGINAL PROPOSAL FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION, A $30 MILLION
CUT TO PUBLIC DEFENDERS. AND I'M
CONCERNED BECAUSE IT MAY REVISE
DOESN'T SPEAK TO IT, BUT ALSO
DOESN'T RESTORE IT, AS FAR AS I
UNDERSTAND. BUT I JUST I WANT TO
RAISE THAT ISSUE IF THERE'S A
WAY OF RESPONDING BECAUSE, AS I
HEAR AS I UNDERSTAND IT, THE
SPENDING ON INDIGENT DEFENSE
ACROSS THE STATE, IS ABOUT HALF
A LITTLE OVER HALF OF THE AMOUNT
SPENT ON DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICES. SO HERE WE HAVE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE LITTLE TO NO RESOURCES
TO SPEND ON THEIR OWN DEFENSE.
AND YET IN TOTAL, THE SYSTEM IS
REALLY CUTTING OUT HALF THE HALF
THE PEOPLE WHO VERY DESPERATELY
NEED THAT DEFENSE. SO IF ANYBODY
COULD SPEAK TO THAT. HIÂU
CYNTHIA MENDOZA, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. YES, THAT PROPOSAL THAT
WAS PROPOSED GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
UNDER THE BOARD OF, STATE AND
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS BUDGET IS
STILL, UP FOR NEGOTIATION. IT
WAS PROPOSED AND NO ACTION WAS
TAKEN ON IT DURING THE EARLY
ACTION. SO IT IS STILL, IT IS
STILL THERE. OKAY. AND IT'S $40
MILLION REDUCTION FOR THE 40
MILLION. YES. OKAY SO I WAS
WRONG. MORE THAN 30. OKAY. THANK
YOU. I APPRECIATE THAT. SO LET'S
NEGOTIATE. YOU AND ME ON THIS
AND WE CAN FIGURE IT OUT. BUT
LET'S PUT MORE INTO DEFENSE FOR
INDIGENOUS PEOPLE. THANK YOU.
THANK THANK YOU. SENATOR NEWMAN.
LET ME JUST ADD MY VOICE, YOU
KNOW VERY STRONGLY TO SENATOR
DEROSA SINCE I GIVE HER MY PROXY
TO NEGOTIATE WITH YOU TO RESTORE
THOSE FUNDS THAT, NOWHERE ARE
THOSE FUNDS MORE NEEDED, I DON'T
THINK YOU'D FIND AN INSTANCE
WHERE THESE CUTS ARE GOING TO BE
MORE, NEGATIVELY IMPACTFUL. SO,
YOU KNOW, I'M GLAD TO WORK ON ON
RESTORING THAT THOSE FUNDS AS
WELL. THANK YOU, ONE, I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. I'M GOING
TO MOVE ON TO THE NEXT ISSUE
AREA.
SO ISSUE NUMBER FIVE, AGAIN, THE
OVERVIEW, WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
ERIC SWANSON, DEPUTY DIRECTOR
WITH OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES. VÌ NGUYEN, PRINCIPAL
PROGRAM BUDGET ANALYST,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, TEST.
SCHRECKENBACH SORRY. I'M SO
SORRY, WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. JARED SIPPEL PRINCIPAL,
FISCAL AND POLICY ANALYST. LEO
AND DREW SODERBERG, DEPUTY
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST. LEO AGAIN,
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
DEPARTMENTS ARE AVAILABLE FOR
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS AND
DETAILS, GOVERNORS MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL AGAIN. THE FLEXIBLE. SO
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
EXCELLENT. THANK YOU. TESS
SCHRECKENBACH WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I'M JUST
GOING TO PROVIDE A QUICK BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE FIVE GENERAL
FUND SOLUTIONS FOR CALOES BUDGET
AND THEN TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE ERIC SWANSON WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TO TALK ABOUT,
PROPOSALS, THE MAY REVISION.
THANK YOU. THE GENERAL FUND
SOLUTIONS THAT ARE PROPOSED IN
THE MAY REVISION RESULT IN A
TOTAL OF 142.8 MILLION. IN
GENERAL FUND SAVINGS FROM THE 20
2324 THROUGH 20 2728 YEARS, 7.3
MILLION IS IN 2023, 24,
22,000,000 IN 2024, 25, 69.5
MILLION IN 20 2526, 22,000,000
IN 20 2627 AND 22,000,000 IN 20
2728. SO I'LL BREAK THESE OUT
NOW FOR THE STATE DISASTER
WAREHOUSING OPERATIONS 20 2223
UNENCUMBERED BALANCE. THE MAYOR
REVISION PROPOSES REVERTING
640,000. IN GENERAL FUND, AND
THIS MAINTAINS 99.5% OF THE
TOTAL ORIGINAL APPROPRIATION FOR
THIS PROGRAM. THEN WE HAVE THE
FIRE FLEET VEHICLE REPLACEMENTS,
AND THE MAYOR REVISION PROPOSES
REVERTING THE REMAINDER OF THE
CURRENT YEAR FUNDING FOR THE
FLEET VEHICLE REPLACEMENT, WHICH
WILL RESULT IN 6.62 MILLION. IN
GENERAL FUND SAVINGS. NEXT, WE
HAVE THE LEAST DOSE CALIFORNIA
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS CAMPAIGN,
AND THE MAYOR REVISION PROPOSES
A REDUCTION OF 12.5 MILLION
GENERAL FUND ONGOING. THIS
MAINTAINS 50% OF THE TOTAL
ORIGINAL APPROPRIATION FOR THIS
PROGRAM. NEXT WE HAVE FOR
WAREHOUSING OPERATIONS A
PROPOSAL TO REDUCE 9.5 MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN 20 2425, 2025,
26, 20 2627 AND 20 2728,
MAINTAINING 82% OF TOTAL
ORIGINAL APPROPRIATION FOR THIS
PROGRAM. LASTLY WE HAVE THE
FLEXIBLE, FLEXIBLE CASH
ASSISTANCE FOR SURVIVORS OF
CRIME PROGRAM, AND THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSED
REVERTING THE REMAINING 47.5
MILLION FOR THIS PROGRAM IN 20
2324 AND THEN DELAYING THIS
FUNDING TO 20 2526. BUT GIVEN
THE MAGNITUDE OF THE BUDGET
PROBLEM HAS INCREASED, THE MAY
REVISION DOES REMOVE THE
PROPOSED DELAY, RESULTING IN A
STRAIGHT REVERSION OF THIS
REMAINING FUNDING. THAT'S IT.
I'LL TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE, ERIC SWANSON, DEPUTY
DIRECTOR, OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES, WE HAVE TWO CONSISTENT
WITH OTHER DEPARTMENTS. WE HAVE
TWO, PCP'S RELATED TO CHAPTER
LEGISLATION TOTALING ABOUT
900,003 POSITIONS. ONE IS FOR
THE NEWLY CREATED CANCER
FIREFIGHTER CANCER PREVENTION
AND RESEARCH PROGRAM, AND ONE IS
RELATED TO CHANGES TO OUR
CALIFORNIA STATE NONPROFIT
SECURITY GRANT PROGRAM, A COUPLE
OTHER PROPOSALS OF NOTE, WE
HAVE, PROPOSED, 15.8 MILLION IN
THE BUDGET, FEDERAL FUNDS FOR A
SECOND ROUND OF OUR STATE AND
LOCAL CYBERSECURITY GRANT
PROGRAM. AND WE'VE ALSO,
PROPOSED AN INCREASE FOR
EQUIPMENT RELATED TO A JANUARY
PROPOSAL ASSOCIATED WITH, A,
FOR, PURCHASE EQUIPMENT RELATED
TO A STAR, STATE, EMERGENCY
TELEPHONE NUMBER ACCOUNT,
PROGRAM, OR FOR A PUBLIC, RADIO,
PROPOSAL. I WANTED TO MENTION
THERE WAS ONE PROPOSAL THAT GOT
LEFT OUT OF THE AGENDA BECAUSE
IT WAS PART OF A CAPITAL OUTLAY,
LATE BREAKING BCP, WE'VE
PROPOSED A NET INCREASE OF 3.2
MILLION. GENERAL FUND, RELATED
TO A THE CONSTRUCTION PHASE OF A
COMMUNICATION FACILITY.
REPLACEMENT AT RED MOUNTAIN,
WHICH IS NEAR DEL NORTE AND
HUMBOLDT COUNTY AND PROVIDES
PUBLIC SERVICE RADIO
COMMUNICATION TO THOSE COUNTIES.
DREW SODERBERG, LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE DON'T HAVE
ANY SPECIFIC REMARKS. WE'RE
STILL REVIEWING THE PROPOSALS,
BUT HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AS
THEY COME UP. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS. SENATOR DURAZZO, THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. I HAVE A
QUESTION ABOUT THE FLEXIBLE
ASSISTANCE FOR SURVIVORS, THAT
IS BEING COMPLETELY VÆ. IS IT IS
IT NOW DEFUNDED? AND SO IT WON'T
. I GUESS ON PAPER IT WILL
CONTINUE TO EXIST. BUT OR I
DON'T KNOW IF AT ALL, BUT IF YOU
COULD TELL ME SOME MORE ABOUT
IT. HOW HOW IS IT THAT THAT
FUNDING HELPED ORGANIZATIONS
MEET THE NEEDS OF CRIME VICTIMS?
I'LL JUST PROVIDE A QUICK
COMMENT AND CLARITY. YES, YOU
ARE CORRECT. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET HAD PROPOSED THAT AS A
DELAY IN FUNDING, BUT GIVEN THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE BUDGET PROBLEM
HAS GROWN SINCE THEN, THE MAY
REVISION DOES PROPOSE A STRAIGHT
REVERSION OF THAT FUNDING, SO NO
LONGER DELAYING IT IS A
REDUCTION. SENATOR GRASSO, I
THINK YOU'RE CORRECT IN THAT THE
CHAPTERED LEGISLATION THAT
CREATED THAT PROGRAM WILL STILL
EXIST. IT JUST WOULD NEED TO BE
FUNDED IN A FUTURE BUDGET,
APPROACH CREATION. AND COULD YOU
TELL ME SOME MORE OR SOMEONE
TELL ME SOME MORE ABOUT THE
PROGRAM AND THE IMPACT ON THE
CRIME VICTIMS WHEN IT WILL BE
FUNDED? I THINK IN GENERAL, IN A
PRIOR HEARING, WE NOTED THAT WE
FELT LIKE THIS WAS A GREAT IDEA.
IT FITS A NICHE IN VICTIMS
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN HIT BY
OTHER PROGRAMS, IT WAS SELECTED,
I THINK, BECAUSE OF THE NATURE
OF IT BEING A PILOT PROGRAM. AND
IT HAVEN'T BEING IMPLEMENTED
YET. THIS WAS SOMETHING WE FELT
COULD I JUST WOULD
NOTE A QUICK COMMENT PACT, SO
GIVEN THAT THIS PROGRAM IS STILL
UNDER DEVELOPMENT AND NO GRANT
GUIDELINES HAD BEEN RELEASED,
THERE IS NO LOSS OF ADDITIONAL
BENEFITS THAT SURVIVORS WILL
IMMEDIATELY EXPERIENCE BECAUSE
THOSE BENEFITS HAVE NOT BEEN
PROVIDED YET. THE PROGRAM IS
STILL UNDER DEVELOPMENT, SO THE
SITUATION WILL REMAIN STATUS QUO
UNTIL FUNDING IS PROVIDED. I
APPRECIATE THAT, BUT BUT CAN
ANYONE GIVE ME A AN EXPLANATION
AS TO WHAT KIND OF SERVICES
WOULD HAVE BEEN AND WILL BE WHEN
WE GET THE FUNDING? SURE, THE
LEGISLATION ITSELF SET UP AN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE WHICH HAD
MEMBERS, APPOINTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
THAT ADVISORY COMMITTEE HAS
ALREADY MET AND SORT OF COME UP
WITH A FRAMEWORK FOR THE PROGRAM
, WHAT'S DIFFERENT BY FROM THIS
PROGRAM, FROM OTHER PROGRAMS IS
THAT IT'S, MEANT TO BE MORE
FLEXIBLE CASH ASSISTANCE RATHER
THAN SOME OF OUR OTHER VICTIMS
PROGRAMS PROVIDE SUPPORT
SERVICES SUCH AS HOUSING OR
OTHER KINDS OF THINGS. BUT
AGAIN, BECAUSE WE FELT LIKE IT
WAS A PILOT PROGRAM HADN'T BEEN
TESTED YET, WE DIDN'T HAVE ANY
EVIDENCE THAT OF HOW IT WORKED,
WE WANTED TO PUT IT ON HOLD
UNTIL FUTURE, FISCAL ROSE-INNES,
IF YOU WILL. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. ANY OTHER MEMBERS, ANY
OTHER MEMBERS? SO I SPECIFICALLY
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT, OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES ALSO HANDLES,
THE ISSUES THAT HAPPEN IN OUR
SCHOOL CAMPUSES. CORRECT ISSUES
IN TERMS OF, èC CSU'S, YOU
KNOW, THINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING
IN THE NEWS, WE DO HAVE WE HAVE
A COORDINATION. WE'RE NOT THE
PRIMARY PERSON GROUP INVOLVED,
BUT WE DO HAVE A COORDINATION
EFFORT IN THAT. YES. OKAY. AND
SPECIFICALLY WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT, SECURITY AND MUCH MORE, I
GENUINELY AM CONCERNED WITH THE
SURVIVORS REDUCTION, THIS THIS
IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AS WE'RE
TRYING TO PRIORITIZE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. AND OBVIOUSLY THIS
IS IMPORTANT, AS WELL AS, YOU
KNOW, JUST, AGAIN, TRYING TO
MAINTAIN THE INTEGRITY OF
EQUIPMENT AND RESPONSE TIME AND
MUCH MORE. AND I JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT IS, DO YOU BELIEVE
THAT THERE'S ANYTHING ELSE? DO
YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS FOR THE
PROPOSED REDUCTIONS ON THEIR
IMPACTS, INCLUDING THE STATE
OPERATIONS AND VACANCY
REDUCTIONS? I THINK IN GENERAL,
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT PRIOR
DEPARTMENTS HAVE SAID, WE'RE
GOING TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NOW, I
WOULD NOTE SPECIFICALLY FOR CAL
OS IN THIS AREA THAT, YOU KNOW,
WE'RE GOING TO OBVIOUSLY MAKE
SURE THAT WE MEET OUR MISSION AS
FAR AS DISASTER PREPAREDNESS
RESPONSE AND RECOVERY AND MAKE
SURE THAT THAT IS, THAT THOSE
REDUCTIONS TAKE PLACE IN THAT
LIGHT. BUT THEN WE ALSO THINK
THAT THERE WE CAN LOOK AND SEE
IF THERE'S INEFFICIENCIES THAT
CAN BE REALIZED THROUGH THESE
PROPOSED REDUCTIONS. OKAY. AND
THEN SPECIFICALLY WITH THE
FLEXIBLE ASSISTANCE PROGRAM, WHY
IS OAS MAINTAINING THAT
ADMINISTRATIVE PORTION, SOME OF
THAT, A LOT OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PART OF IT HAS
BEEN DONE ALREADY, A LOT OF THE
WORK AHEAD OF TIME OF THE
PROGRAM, WE WORKED WITH THE
ADVISORY COUNCIL TO COME UP WITH
, THE REQUEST FOR PROPOSAL. SO
MOST OF THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
BEEN HAS BEEN TAKEN CARE OF
AHEAD OF TIME. THERE WOULD BE
SOME ADMINISTRATION
ADMINISTRATIVE SAVINGS THAT WE
CAN WORK WITH YOU A LITTLE BIT
IN TERMS OF, MAINTAINING IF THE
GRANTS AREN'T, YOU KNOW,
CONSTANT COMMUNICATION AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WITH THE
GRANTEES AS THEY, GO THROUGH THE
PROGRAM. OKAY I THINK THAT WE
HAVE A LITTLE BIT MORE WORK TO
DO, BUT THEN I'M JUST GOING TO
MOVE ON TO THE WAREHOUSING
REDUCTIONS. DOES THAT HAVE AN
OPERATIONAL IMPACT OR THOSE
PROJECTS, PROJECTED SAVINGS
BASED ON THE CURRENT LEASES OR
SAVINGS FROM OTHER SOURCES? THIS
REDUCTION IS JUST A REDUCTION IN
THE AMOUNT OF PPE LEVELS THAT WE
ARE PURCHASING, THIS PROPOSAL
ORIGINALLY CAME ABOUT BECAUSE OF
WHAT WE WERE GOING THROUGH IN
COVID. AS TIME HAS GONE ON,
WE'VE COME TO REALIZE THAT WE
THINK WE DON'T NEED THE LEVELS
WE THOUGHT WE NEEDED AT THAT
POINT. OKAY. AND THEN WHAT IS
THE IMPACT OF THE REDUCTION TO
THE LOWEST DOSE PROGRAM? WHAT
WILL BE, THE REMAINING 12.5
MILLION BE USED FOR, WE HAVEN'T
COME UP WITH AN EXACT PLAN OF
HOW TO ALLOCATE HALF THE
FUNDING. IT'S BASICALLY HALF THE
FUNDING IS LEFT ON AN ONGOING
BASIS. I WILL SAY THAT BECAUSE
IN PRIOR YEARS, THIS WAS FULLY
FUNDED, WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
DEVELOP, EDUCATION MATERIALS AND
STATEWIDE COMMUNICATION THAT WE
CAN DRAW UPON TO, WORK WITH TO
PRIORITIZE MAKING SURE THAT
FUNDING GETS TO, LOCAL NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS WHERE, YOU KNOW,
THE SORT OF THE INTENT OF THE
ORIGINAL PROGRAM ITSELF. OKAY.
AND THEN I SPECIFICALLY WANT TO
ASK ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
FIREFIGHTER CANCER CANCER
PREVENTION AND RESEARCH PROGRAM.
CAN YOU GIVE A LITTLE MORE
DETAIL INTO THAT? SURE. THIS IS
A PIECE OF CHAPTER LEGISLATION.
I THINK THE BULK OF THE FUNDING
ASSOCIATED WITH THE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION IS ACTUALLY IN THE
èC BUDGET TO PROVIDE THE
RESEARCH GRANTS THEMSELVES, BUT
THE LEGISLATION GIVES CAL OES A
ROLE IN DETERMINING TO GO GOING
THROUGH AND KIND OF RATING AND
RATING THOSE PROPOSALS AND
WORKING OUT WITH RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR UCS OF HOW TO FUND THAT,
THOSE GRANTS. OKAY. SO, YOU
KNOW, THERE'S A COUPLE OF
PROGRAMS THAT YOU GUYS OVERSEE
THAT I THINK IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO ME. THE STATE AND
LOCAL CYBERSECURITY GRANT
PROGRAM FUNDING AUTHORITY, I
HAVE SAID THIS IN MULTIPLE
HEARINGS SO FAR THAT
CYBERSECURITY AND PRIVACY IS,
PRIORITY K¾T, AND THERE IS A LOT
OF MONEY ON THE TABLE FROM THE
FEDERAL SIDE. AND, YOU KNOW, WE
JUST HAD A QUICK TRIP TO
WASHINGTON, D.C, AND MET WITH A
LOT OF FOLKS THERE, AND THERE'S
A LOT OF, AGAIN, FUNDING ON THE
TABLE THAT'S NOT BEING UTILIZED
OR ABSORBED. SO EVEN, FOR
EXAMPLE, WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TRANSPORTATION, RIGHT,
THERE IS ROUGHLY $40,000 ON THE
TABLE IF THE VEHICLE IS
CONSIDERED A GREEN VEHICLE,
RIGHT? IF THE PURCHASE OF THAT
VEHICLE IS A GREEN VEHICLE, AND
I DON'T SEE ENOUGH OF THE
DEPARTMENTS, CITIES, LOCALITIES
UTILIZING THOSE FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES, I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THAT JUST BECAUSE IT IS
LITERALLY MONEY ON THE TABLE FOR
NEW EQUIPMENT, NEW IDEAS,
INITIATIVES AND SO FORTH, AND
ALSO HOPEFULLY MEETING OUR
CLIMATE GOALS AND OTHER, MORE
INNOVATIVE EFFORTS, BUT
SPECIFICALLY THE CYBERSECURITY
GRANT PROGRAM, IT IS OF
PRIORITY. I'VE SPOKEN TO YOUR
LEADERSHIP ABOUT THIS, A LOT OF
THE LOCALITIES, INCLUDING IN THE
BAY AREA WITH THE FOURTH LARGEST
ECONOMY AND OBVIOUSLY THE, YOU
KNOW, INNOVATION THAT WE'RE
SEEING AND MUCH MORE. AND
EVERYTHING BEING DONE ONLINE, WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE SOME
OF THESE LOCALITIES WITH MORE
RESOURCES WHEN IT COMES TO
CYBERSECURITY AND BUILD OUT THE
CYBERSECURITY DEPARTMENT WITHIN
THE OES OPERATIONS, RIGHT. AND I
JUST WANT TO UNDERSTAND WHAT IS
THE PROJECTED VISION FOR THIS.
SO THIS GRANT PROGRAM, AND I
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
ABOUT TRYING TO WORK WITH
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO GET AS
MUCH AS WE CAN IN CALIFORNIA TO
IN THIS PARTICULAR PROGRAM. I
THINK OUR STATE SHARE IS PRETTY,
IS PRETTY GENEROUS COMPARED TO
OTHER STATES. THE PROGRAM
ITSELF, 80% OF THE FUNDING WILL
GO TO LOCALS, AND THERE'S A
PERCENTAGE. I'M NOT RECALLING IT
RIGHT NOW, BUT THERE'S A
PERCENTAGE THAT'S SUPPOSED TO GO
TO RURAL AREAS AS WELL, BUT AND
20% WOULD BE USED FOR BOTH FOR A
STATE WE'VE HAD OUR OWN STATE
ISSUE, STATE DEPARTMENT ISSUES
WITH CYBERSECURITY AS WELL AS,
YOU KNOW. SO THAT IS HOW THE
GRANT IS SET UP. WE DO PLAN TO
DO A TRADITIONAL RFP OR A
REQUEST FOR PROPOSAL FROM CITIES
AND COUNTIES TO GO AND TRY TO
ALLOCATE THE FUNDS TO THE WHERE
THE GREATEST NEED IS POSSIBLE.
ALL RIGHT, I APPRECIATE IT. I
DEFINITELY WANT TO PRIORITIZE
CYBERSECURITY AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE. WE'RE SEEING A LOT OF
THE LOCALITIES BEING KIND OF,
HUNG UP ON, BEING ABLE TO DEFEND
ITSELF WITH THESE ATTACKS, SO
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER SIX, AGAIN, OVERVIEW OF
THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL, ISSUE NUMBER SIX, TO
BE CLEAR, IS GOING TO BE ALYSSA
CERVANTES, STAFF FINANCE BUDGET
ANALYST FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. ORLANDO SANCHEZ ZAVALA,
FISCAL AND POLICY ANALYST OF LAO
DREW SODERBERG, DEPUTY
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST FROM THE LAO
ISSUE SIX COVERS AGAIN THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION PROPOSAL
FOR THE OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL. WE'RE GOING TO FIRST
HEAR FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. GOOD AFTERNOON, ALYSSA
CERVANTES, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. SO THE SOLUTION IS A
REDUCTION OF 1.9 MILLION IN
2425, GROWING TO 3.9 MILLION IN
2526 AND ONGOING. THE PROPOSAL
WOULD RETURN STAFFING LEVELS FOR
THE OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S MEDICAL INSPECTION
UNIT TO THE LEVELS THAT EXISTED
PRIOR TO THE RECENT AUGMENTATION
INCLUDED IN THE 2022 BUDGET ACT.
THE INTENT OF THIS REDUCTION IS
TO DECREASE FREQUENCY OF MEDICAL
INSPECTIONS ONLY FOR DELEGATED
INSTITUTIONS, WHILE MAINTAINING
THE SHORTENED PERIOD FOR NON
DELEGATED INSTITUTIONS. THE
SOLUTION ALLOWS THE
ADMINISTRATION TO REALIZE
SAVINGS WHILE STILL PROTECTING
THE CORE MISSION, INCLUDING
EMPLOYEE DISCIPLINE MONITORING,
CLINICAL INCIDENT MONITORING AND
STAFF COMPLAINT AND INMATE
GRIEVANCE MONITORING. HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE HAS. THANK YOU. ELIO
DREW SODERBERG, LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE BEFORE
CONSIDERING APPROVING THE THIS
REDUCTION, WE'D ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO ASK THE
DEPARTMENT WHETHER OR NOT THIS
REDUCTION WOULD IMPACT THE
TIMETABLE ON WHICH THE STATE IS
ABLE TO TAKE BACK CONTROL OF ITS
PRISON MEDICAL CARE PROGRAM. SO
THE OIG INSPECTIONS ARE A KEY
METRIC THAT THE FEDERAL RECEIVER
USES TO ASSESS WHETHER OR NOT AN
INDIVIDUAL PRISON IS PROVIDING
AN ADEQUATE LEVEL OF CARE. AND,
AND MAKING A DETERMINATION ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THAT PRISON, CAN
BE DELEGATED BACK TO STATE
CONTROL TO THE EXTENT THAT THIS
PROPOSAL BEALL DELAYED THE
ABILITY OF INDIVIDUAL PRISONS TO
BE DELEGATED BACK TO STATE
CONTROL, IT COULD EVENTUALLY
RESULT IN THE STATE NOT BEING
ABLE TO TAKE OVER CONTROL OF
PRISON MEDICAL CARE, AS SOON AS
IT OTHERWISE WOULD, WE WOULD
NOTE THAT TO THE EXTENT THIS IS
A CONCERN OF THE LEGISLATURE,
THERE ARE OTHER REDUCTIONS THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER IN
LIEU OF THIS ONE. SO IN THE 2020
2324 BUDGET, 3.2 MILLION GENERAL
FUND, INCREASING TO 6.1 MILLION
ANNUALLY, WAS PROVIDED TO ALLOW
THE DEPARTMENT TO SEEK
ACCREDITATION FROM THE JOINT
COMMISSION, THIS WAS INTENDED TO
PROVIDE AN EXTERNAL SOURCE OF
OVERSIGHT OVER THE LEVEL OF
HEALTH CARE PROVIDED BY THE
DEPARTMENT AT THE TIME, BECAUSE
THIS IS SO SIMILAR TO THE
FUNCTION PROVIDED BY OIG, WE
FELT THAT THIS FUNDING WAS
DUPLICATIVE AND UNNECESSARY. SO
THIS IS A PLACE WHERE THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CUT IN LIEU OF
REDUCING THE OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL. WE DO NOTE
THAT IT WOULD RESULT IN GREATER
ONGOING GENERAL FUND SAVINGS.
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT,
SO DOES THE OFFICE OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL HAVE ANY
COMMENTS ON THE PROPOSED
REDUCTIONS IN HOW IT WILL IMPACT
THEIR PROGRAMS, GOOD MORNING,
THIS IS NEIL ROBERTSON. I'M
CHIEF DEPUTY INSPECTOR GENERAL.
I DO NOT HAVE ANY PREPARED
STATEMENTS. I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. ASIDE FROM
STATING THE OBVIOUS, THE
REDUCTION IN THE POSITIONS WOULD
HAVE, IN OUR OPINION, A VERY
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON HOW WE ARE
ABLE TO TIMELY, PERFORM OUR
REPORTS AND OVERSIGHT OF THE
MEDICAL PROGRAMS AT CDCR, ONE OF
THE MAIN GOALS AND MAIN MISSION
STATEMENTS THAT OUR NEW
INSPECTOR GENERAL CAME ON TWO
YEARS AGO WAS TO WAS TO PICK UP
THE PACE ON PROVIDING THESE
REPORTS. IN THE PAST, WE WERE
AROUND A THREE AND A HALF YEAR
RANGE TO PROVIDE A CYCLE OF
REPORTS FOR THE INSTITUTIONS, SO
IN 2022, WE DID GET THE BUDGET
INCREASE, WE GOT 18 ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS TO, TO, TO ENHANCE,
THE SPEED WITH WHICH WE'RE
PROVIDING THOSE REPORTS. AND, WE
HAVE FILLED ALL OF THOSE
POSITIONS, IN THIS UPCOMING
CYCLE, THE CYCLE THAT WE'RE
CURRENTLY IN. AND WE ARE SEEING
AN INCREASE IN TIME IN OUR
PROJECTION IS THAT WE WILL BE
ABLE TO GET THIS DOWN TO A TWO
YEAR CYCLE. WHAT IS YOUR
RESPONSE TO THE LEO'S PREVIOUS
COMMENTS, REGARDING ON THE
QUESTIONS THAT THE BEGINNING OF
THE WOULD YOU LIKE TO REPEAT
YOURSELF? REPEAT THOSE? YEAH,
SURE, WE BASICALLY RAISED
CONCERNS THAT THIS REDUCTION
COULD, COULD END UP DELAYING THE
TIMETABLE FOR THE STATE TO TAKE
BACK CONTROL OF PRISON MEDICAL
CARE, FROM THE FEDERAL RECEIVER.
YEAH, WE WOULD AGREE WITH THAT
ANALYSIS. I THINK THAT IT WOULD
SLOW DOWN THE PROCESS, IT'S
STATING THE OBVIOUS. THE, YOU
KNOW, THE POSITIONS WE NEED TO
GET OUT TO THE INSTITUTIONS AND
DO THESE TYPES OF REVIEWS, AND I
KNOW THAT THE RECEIVER DOES RELY
UPON, OUR REPORTS TO MAKE
ANALYSIS ON WHETHER TO DELEGATE
INSTITUTIONS BACK TO THE
INSTITUTIONS, AND SO WE ARE FEEL
WE'RE A CRITICAL MISSION TOWARDS
THAT AND PROVIDING THAT REPORT.
SO THANK YOU, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, JUST A QUICK
CLARIFICATION, SO THE INTENT OF
THE REDUCTION IS TO ONLY REDUCE
THE TIME FOR INSPECTION FOR
ALREADY DESIGNATED INSTITUTIONS.
WE'RE NOT SUGGESTING TO REDUCE
TIME, FOR THE ONES THAT ARE NOT.
AND ONLY TEN OF THE REMAINING
INSTITUTIONS ARE NO LONGER ARE
NOT YET DELEGATED BACK TO THE
STATE PERFECT. SENATOR DURAZZO,
ARE THERE LEGAL IMPLICATIONS FOR
THIS? I MEAN, THERE'S ONE THING
IS THE TIME FRAME NOT BEING ABLE
TO DO IT IN THE TIME FRAME, BUT
DOES THAT HURT US ON THE LEGAL
FRONT AS FAR AS WHAT WE'RE
EXPECTED? AND, TO CARRY OUT
EXACTLY ON THE LEGAL. SO IN THE
FEDERAL RECEIVER'S OFFICE,
THEY'RE DELEGATING THE PRISONS
BACK TO THE INSTITUTIONS FOR,
MANAGEMENT BY THE INSTITUTIONS
AND NOT OVERSIGHT BY THE FEDERAL
RECEIVER, YOU KNOW, OUR ROLE HAS
BEEN TRADITIONALLY WHEN WE CAME
ON BOARD, WHICH WAS TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT AND QUALITY
OF CARE AND IN POLICY,
COMPLIANCE WITH THEIR POLICIES.
THOSE ARE THE REPORTS THAT WE
PUT OUT. SO IF IT'S ASSISTING IN
GETTING PRISONS DELEGATED BACK,
IT WOULD SLOW THAT DOWN. I'M NOT
SURE HOW THAT WOULD PLAY OUT
LEGALLY, BUT IT GOES TOWARDS HOW
LONG THE FEDERAL RECEIVER WOULD
NEED TO CONTINUE TO ITS WORK IN
MONITORING AND, WORKING WITH
THOSE INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE,
DELEGATED AT THIS POINT. OKAY. I
GUESS BECAUSE THERE IS A
RECEIVERSHIP, THAT IS A LEGAL
THAT'S ALREADY HAPPENED. RIGHT?
RIGHT. BUT I'M SAYING IS WOULD
THIS HURT ANYTHING THAT THE
RECEIVER EXPECTS OF US? I CAN'T
REALLY ANSWER THAT. ON BEHALF OF
THE RECEIVER'S OFFICE. I KNOW
THAT WE ARE JUST PROVIDING THOSE
REPORTS, AND HE UTILIZES THOSE
REPORTS IN HIS ANALYSIS. I'M NOT
SURE THAT, I WOULD DEFER TO
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
RECEIVER'S OFFICE. I DON'T KNOW
IF THERE IS ANY HERE THAT COULD
TALK, BUT, IT'S NOT MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS WOULD
NECESSARILY PUT US IN BREACH OF
ANY REQUIREMENT THAT PLACED ON
US BY THE FEDERAL RECEIVER. OUR
CONCERN IS MOSTLY, THOUGH, THAT
IT WOULD JUST DELAY THE OVERALL
PROCESS, MEANING THAT IT TAKES
LONGER FOR THE STATE TO GET IT
BACK. BUT AT THIS POINT, WE
HAVEN'T IDENTIFIED A CONCERN
THAT THIS WOULD MEAN THAT WE'RE,
VIOLATING ANY REQUIREMENTS PUT
ON US BY THE COURT, IF THAT
MAKES SENSE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
NEWMAN, I GUESS I'D ASK MR.
SODERBERGH. CAN WE TRANSLATE
THIS INTO DOLLARS OR PROSPECTIVE
COSTS, WHICH IS TO SAY, YOU
KNOW, IS THE SAVINGS OF $1.9
MILLION THIS YEAR AND THE
ONGOING SAVINGS OF JUST UNDER
FOUR. YOU KNOW, IS THERE A
CHANCE THAT WE COULD WIND UP
SPENDING MORE OVER TIME IN THE
EVENT THAT WE DO EITHER BREACH
OUR OBLIGATIONS OR EXTEND THE
RECEIVERSHIP? IT'S DIFFICULT TO
SAY FOR SURE, BASICALLY, SO LONG
AS THE FEDERAL RECEIVER REMAINS
IN PLACE, THE FEDERAL RECEIVER
IS GOING TO BE CONTROLLING STATE
PRISON MEDICAL POLICY TO THE
EXTENT THE STATE IS ABLE TO,
TAKE CONTROL OF PRISON MEDICAL
POLICY BACK, IT WOULD HAVE MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO DO THINGS THAT IT
MIGHT OTHERWISE NOT BE ABLE TO
DO, AND BUT THE QUESTION OF HOW
HOW MUCH DIFFERENCE THE
DIFFERENT TYPE OF DECISIONS THE
STATE WOULD MAKE IN THE ABSENCE
OF THE FEDERAL RECEIVER IS HARD
TO KNOW. BUT IT'S POSSIBLE. BUT
IT WOULD BE. IT WOULDN'T BE
POSSIBLE TO IDENTIFY A SPECIFIC
DOLLAR AMOUNT, AND IT'S POSSIBLE
THAT THE STATE MAY MAKE SIMILAR
DECISIONS TO THE FEDERAL
RECEIVER, BUT THERE IS SOME
CHANCE THAT WE WOULD YOU KNOW,
SEE SOME EXPOSURE MONETARILY,
EITHER THROUGH LEGAL EXPENSES
OR, YOU KNOW, SOME OTHER COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH EXTENDING THIS
TIMELINE, POSSIBLY. SO IF THE
STATE, IF THE ABSENCE OF THE
FEDERAL RECEIVER ALLOWED THE
STATE TO TAKE AN ACTION TO
REDUCE COSTS THAT IT WOULDN'T
OTHERWISE TAKE, THEN THAT THAT
WOULD BE WHERE THE STATE WOULD,
BE NEGATIVELY AFFECTED BY THIS
CHAIR. IF I IF I MAY, I FEEL
LIKE IT'S IMPORTANT TO CLARIFY.
SO WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION, THE
ADMINISTRATION LOOKED AT RECENT
ONE TIME AND ONGOING PROPOSALS.
THIS WAS AN AUGMENTATION THAT
WAS INCLUDED IN A RECENT BUDGET
TO SPEED UP THE CYCLES OF THEIR
MEDICAL INSPECTIONS. THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL IS NOT
SUGGESTING THAT WE'RE,
ELIMINATING MEDICAL INSPECTIONS,
AND WE'RE NOT EVEN SUGGESTING
THAT THEY BE DELAYED FOR
INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
DELEGATED. SO THERE ARE
DELEGATED INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE
BACK UNDER THE, THE, THE, THE
CONTROL OF THE STATE AND THERE'S
INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE UNDER THE
RECEIVER. THIS REDUCTION SHOULD
STILL DOESN'T IMPACT AND SHOULD
STILL ALLOW THE OIG TO PERFORM
MEDICAL INSPECTIONS AT A FASTER
RATE FOR INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE
NOT DELEGATED. IT'S THE
DELEGATED. I THINK THE DELEGATED
INSTITUTIONS. WHAT WE'RE SAYING
IS THAT THAT IT'S OKAY IF THOSE
TIMELINES TAKE A LITTLE BIT
LONGER. AND I WOULD JUST SAY IT
IS VERY TÊ HYPOTHETICAL THAT
THIS PROPOSAL IN FRONT OF YOU
WOULD DELAY THE END OF THE
RECEIVERSHIP. THE OIG MEDICAL
INSPECTIONS ARE ONE THING THAT
THE RECEIVER AND I I'M NOT THE
RECEIVER CANNOT SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF THE RECEIVER. HE'S NOT HERE
TODAY, BUT WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
IT'S LIKE VERY HYPOTHETICAL THAT
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD HAVE AN
IMPACT ON THAT. IT'S NOT, IT'S
NOT COMPLETELY OUT OF THE REALM,
BUT IT'S ONE THING THAT THE
RECEIVER IS LOOKING AT. AND
AGAIN, THE MAJORITY OF
INSTITUTIONS HAVE BEEN DELEGATED
BACK TO THE STATE. AND IF THE
OIG PRIORITIZES THESE RESOURCES,
TO PERFORM MORE TIMELY
INSPECTIONS ON NON DELEGATED
INSTITUTIONS THAT WOULD
ESSENTIALLY NOT HAVE AN IMPACT
KIND OF TOWARDS THE END OF THE
RECEIVERSHIP. SO LET ME SEE IF I
CAN PARAPHRASE. YOU CAN TELL ME
IF I'M PARAPHRASING, YOU CAN
TELL ME IF I'M RIGHT. THE
ARGUMENT HERE IS THAT'S A
NATURAL REDUCTION FOR THE
EXPENSES. THAT WOULD BE
ASSOCIATED WITH ALREADY
DELEGATED INSTITUTIONS THAT IT'S
SENSIBLE BECAUSE IT'S NO LONGER
NECESSARY AT THE LEVELS AT THE,
AT THE PREVIOUS LEVELS. IS THAT
CORRECT? I THINK THAT'S WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL IS
BASED ON. THAT SAID, IF THE OIG
WHO WILL BE WORKING WITH KIND OF
ON AN IMPLEMENTATION PLAN OR THE
LEGISLATURE FELT DIFFERENTLY, I
MEAN, WE'RE CERTAINLY OPEN TO
THAT, BUT YES, I THINK THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE WHAT THE KIND OF THE
BASIS FOR THE PROPOSAL WAS NOT
ONLY LOOKING ACROSS DEPARTMENTS
AT RECENT AUGMENTATIONS AND
TRYING TO KIND OF LOOK AT THOSE
THOUGHTFULLY WHILE PROTECTING
MANY OIG CORE PROGRAMS AND CORE
PROGRAMS FOR OTHER DEPARTMENTS.
SO IT'S JUST THAT WE'RE WE'RE
SAYING THAT PERHAPS THE
DELEGATED INSTITUTIONS, WHICH
ARE UNDER THE CONTROL OF THE
STATE, DO NOT NEED QUITE AS
FREQUENT MEDICAL INSPECTIONS AS
COMPARED TO THE NON DELEGATED.
BUT AGAIN, THIS IS KIND OF FOR A
LITTLE BIT FOR DISCUSSION AS
WELL. MR. SODERBERGH, YOU GET
THE LAST WORDS. SURE. I, I GUESS
THERE WAS THERE'S A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT THINGS I WOULD NOTE.
FIRST, IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
INSTITUTIONS CAN THE RECEIVER
COULD TAKE CONTROL BACK OVER OF
INSTITUTIONS, WHICH THEN WOULD
LEAVE THE OIG SHORT IN TERMS OF
RESOURCES TO INSPECT THEM, AND
SECOND OF ALL, FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE, EVEN IF THE RISK OF
DELAYING THE END OF THE
RECEIVERSHIP WITH THIS PROPOSAL
WAS SLIGHT, WE SEE REALLY NO
RISK, OF USING THE ALTERNATIVE
OPTION THAT WE IDENTIFIED OF
HAVING ANY IMPACT ON THE
TIMELINE OF THE RECEIVERSHIP,
AND THAT OPTION WOULD CREATE
GREATER ONGOING GENERAL FUND
SAVINGS. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN,
PLEASE, ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN
AGAIN, COVERS THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION PROPOSALS FOR CDC ARE
WE'RE GOING TO FIRST HEAR FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WE'LL
HAVE PATRICK PLANT, WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, ALYSSA
CERVANTEZ WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, AMANDA GARCIA WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, ORLANDO
SANCHEZ ZAVALA WITH LÀ Þ,
CAITLIN O'NEIL WITH LEO AND DREW
SODERBERG WITH LEO. FINANCE GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY COLLEAGUE AND I
ARE GOING TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW
OF THE MAY REVISION PROPOSALS
FOR THE DEPARTMENT AND OUR CDC,
OUR COLLEAGUES ARE ALSO HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MIGHT HAVE. SO TO ADDRESS THE
PROJECTED BUDGET SHORTFALL, THE
MAY REVISION PROPOSES GENERAL
FUND SOLUTIONS FOR CDCR, WHICH
RESULT IN A NET REDUCTION OF
169.2 MILLION IN THE BUDGET
WINDOW AND 117.1 MILLION ONGOING
STARTING IN 20 2526. AS NOTED IN
THE AGENDA, THESE ONGOING
SOLUTIONS INCLUDE A REDUCTION OF
80.6 MILLION FOR DEACTIVATING
VARIOUS HOUSING UNITS ACROSS 13
PRISONS, A REDUCTION OF 8.5
MILLION IN 2324, 13.8 MILLION IN
20 2425, AND 22.6 MILLION
ONGOING TO REFLECT A REDUCTION
IN ANNUAL TRAINING FOR
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS AND A
DISCONTINUING OF THE USE OF THE
CALIFORNIA REALITY BASED
TRAINING CENTER, A REDUCTION OF
4.1 MILLION TO REDUCE THE NUMBER
OF COVID 19 TESTS CONDUCTED AT
THE RECEPTION CENTERS, A
REDUCTION OF 4.1 MILLION TO
REDUCE VISITING FROM THREE DAYS
TO TWO DAYS FOR INDIVIDUALS IN
LEVEL FOUR, HOUSING, AND A
REDUCTION OF 4.8 MILLION FOR THE
PROPOSED CANCELLATION OF THE
FIRE SUPPRESSION SERVICES
CONTRACT WITH THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. ADDITIONALLY, THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES A REVERSION OF
54.8 MILLION FROM PRIOR BUDGET
ACTS FOR EXPANDING THE MANAGED
ACCESS SYSTEM, THE PAROLEE DATA
OUTCOME PROJECT, AND ESTIMATED
CURRENT YEAR SAVINGS FOR BOTH
COVID 19 MITIGATION AND THE
TRANS METRO BUS CONTRACT.
PATRICK PLANTE, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE MAY REVISION ALSO
INCLUDES VARIOUS WORKLOAD
PROPOSALS FOR CDCR, AND WE
HIGHLIGHT THE FOLLOWING 26
MILLION ONGOING TO ADDRESS THE
INCREASED COSTS OF RENEGOTIATED
SEX OFFENDER MANAGEMENT
TREATMENT CONTRACTS 7.5 MILLION
IN 24, 25 AND 14.4 MILLION
ONGOING TO SUPPORT CONTINUED
IMPLEMENTATION OF CDCR'S REVISED
STAFF MISCONDUCT PROCESSES, 1.5
MILLION GROWING TO 3.3 MILLION
TO SUPPORT PEACE OFFICER DEATH
BENEFITS CONSISTENT WITH AB 621
OF 2023, 4,000,024 25 AND 2526,
SHIFTED FROM CAPITAL OUTLAY TO
CONTINUE THE HOPE AND REDEMPTION
TEAM, THROUGH WHICH FORMERLY
INCARCERATED STAFF LÀ, LEAD
WEEKLY REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMING
AND SERVE AS MENTORS TO THOSE
CURRENTLY INCARCERATED. SAVINGS
OF 44.2 MILLION ONE TIME IN 2425
RELATED TO THE ACCELERATED
CLOSURE OF CHUCKAWALLA VALLEY
STATE PRISON, SAVINGS OF 8.5
MILLION 2526 AND ONGOING TO
REDUCE CDCR'S DOWNTOWN
SACRAMENTO HEADQUARTERS LEASE, A
REDUCTION OF 6.3 MILLION ONGOING
TO BETTER REFLECT ANTICIPATED
ONGOING NEEDS ASSOCIATED WITH
COVID 19 MITIGATION. ALSO, THE
MAY REVISION REFLECTS A NET
DECREASE OF 21.2 MILLION AND
2425 AND 13.5 MILLION ONGOING
ASSOCIATED WITH UPDATED
POPULATION PROJECTIONS FOR THE
ADULT INCARCERATED AND PAROLEE
POPULATION, WITH THAT, WE WILL
PASS IT OFF TO OUR COLLEAGUE
AMANDA GARCIA TO COVER CAPITAL
OUTLAY. THANK YOU. PATRICK.
AMANDA GARCIA, DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. ON THE CAPITAL OUTLAY
SIDE, WE HAVE TWO PROPOSED
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE $20 MILLION
THAT WAS INCLUDED IN THE 2023
BUDGET ACT FOR THE SAN QUENTIN
REHABILITATION CENTER
IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS. WE PROPOSE
REVERTING 8 MILLION ON THE
CAPITAL OUTLAY SIDE AND SHIFTING
THAT FOR USE ON THE SUPPORT
SIDE, AS DISCUSSED BY PATRICK IN
ADDITION, WE PROPOSE
REAPPROPRIATING THE REMAINING 12
MILLION TO BE USED FOR
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE UPPER YARD.
CONSISTENT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MODEL AND THE RECOMMENDATIONS
MADE BY THE ADVISORY COUNCIL.
ADDITIONAL DETAILS WILL BE
PRESENTED FOR THIS PROJECT AS
PART OF THE ESTABLISHMENT
PACKAGE AT THE JUNE 14TH STATE
PUBLIC WORKS BOARD MEETING.
THANK YOU. LEO DREW SODERBERG,
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WE
HAVE COMMENTS ON TWO OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS, THE FIRST
BEING THE PROPOSED HOUSING UNIT,
DEACTIVATIONS. WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL TO TRY TO ACHIEVE SOME
SAVINGS RELATED TO PRISON
CAPACITY REDUCTION, WE DO NOT
RECOMMEND APPROVING THIS
PROPOSAL AND CONTINUE TO
RECOMMEND THAT THE STATE INSTEAD
ADOPT A STRATEGY OF DEACTIVATING
ENTIRE PRISONS, AS OPPOSED TO
PORTIONS OF PRISONS, RECENT
DEACTIVATIONS OF ENTIRE PRISONS
HAVE GENERATED SAVINGS OF AROUND
50 TO $60,000 PER BED
DEACTIVATED. EACH PRISON IS
COMPOSED OF AROUND 4 TO 6 YARDS,
IN RECENT YEARS, THE STATE HAS
DEACTIVATED EIGHT YARDS AND
THOSE DEACTIVATIONS CREATE ABOUT
SAVINGS OF ABOUT $29,000 PER
BED. ON AVERAGE UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL, RATHER THAN
DEACTIVATING PRISONS OR YARDS,
THEY'RE PROPOSING TO DEACTIVATE
HOUSING UNITS, WHICH MAKE UP
PRISON YARDS, SPECIFICALLY, THE
GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING TO
DEACTIVATE 46 HOUSING UNITS
REPRESENTING ABOUT 4600 BEDS
ACROSS 13 PRISONS. THAT WOULD
SAVE AN ESTIMATED $18,000 PER
BED RIDDEN USING A SIMILAR
AMOUNT OF CAPACITY BY EITHER
CLOSING, DEACTIVATE BY
DEACTIVATING PRISONS, AS WELL AS
ADDITIONAL YARDS, WOULD CREATE
AN ADDITIONAL ABOUT $100 MILLION
IN SAVINGS ANNUALLY, IN ADDITION
TO WHAT WOULD BE CREATED UNDER
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
ADDITIONALLY, AFTER ACCOUNTING
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
DEACTIVATIONS, THERE WOULD
REMAIN ABOUT 10,000 EMPTY BEDS
IN THE BUDGET YEAR, A NUMBER
THAT WOULD GROW IN FUTURE YEARS.
AND IF THE LEGISLATURE WERE TO
REDUCE THIS CAPACITY THROUGH
PRISON DEACTIVATION, IT COULD
CREATE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL SAVINGS,
THIS FORGONE SAVINGS UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS NOTABLE
GIVEN THE CONDITION OF THE STATE
BUDGET AND, IF ADOPTED, COULD
RESULT IN THE LEGISLATURE
NEEDING TO MAKE DEEPER
REDUCTIONS TO OTHER CUTS IN
ORDER TO AFFORD THIS LEVEL OF
PRISON CAPACITY, WELL, THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS NOTED THAT
PRISON DEACTIVATION CAN CREATE
DIFFICULTIES SUCH AS ACCESS TO
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS. WE
THINK THERE'S EASY WAYS TO
MITIGATE THOSE CONCERNS, SUCH AS
BY USING A PORTION OF THE
SAVINGS TO BUILD ADDITIONAL
CLASSROOMS AT EXISTING PRISONS,
ACCORDINGLY, WE RECOMMEND, AS I
SAID, REJECTING THE PROPOSAL AND
DIRECTING THE DEPARTMENT TO
IDENTIFY PRISONS FOR CLOSURE AND
TO ALSO REPORT WHICH PRISONS IT
WOULD DEACTIVATE THE ANY
CONCERNS IT HAS ABOUT SUCH
DEACTIVATION AND POTENTIAL
STRATEGIES FOR MITIGATING THOSE
CONCERNS BY JANUARY 10TH, 2025.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SENATOR SATO, THANK YOU. WE'LL
START WITH THAT PRISON HOUSING
UNIT DEACTIVATION. SO FAR WE'VE
ALREADY TAKEN SEVERAL PRISONS
OFFLINE AND WE HAVE ANOTHER ONE
THAT I'LL TALK ABOUT IN A LITTLE
BIT THAT IS SCHEDULED TO BE
OFFLINE. ISN'T IT EASIER TO,
REACTIVATE A HOUSING UNIT THAN
IT IS AN ENTIRE PRISON? BECAUSE
THERE IS A POINT AT WHICH THE
POPULATION OF INMATES WILL WILL
LEVEL OUT AND THERE'S A
POTENTIAL FOR IT TO INCREASE
BACK UP. AND, AND SO I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO MAINTAIN THAT,
THAT FLEXIBILITY. AND SO MY
QUESTION TO YOU, LEÓN, SINCE
YOU, FAVOR CLOSING PRISONS, IS,
IS AT WHAT POINT DO WE STOP
CLOSING PRISONS SO THAT WE HAVE
THAT FLEXIBILITY TO BE ABLE TO
ACCOMMODATE WHAT WE NEED TO KEEP
OUR PUBLIC SAFE? SO,
HISTORICALLY SPEAKING, THE STATE
HAS MAINTAINED WHAT WE REFER TO
AS A BUFFER OF ABOUT 2500 BEDS.
SO WHAT THIS BUFFER IS, IS THE
NUMBER OF BEDS THAT WE KEEP OPEN
BELOW THE FEDERAL LIMIT ON
PRISON OVERCROWDING. AND SO IN
2019 AND YEARS BEFORE THAT, THAT
BUFFER WAS AROUND 2500 WHEN WE
HAD A MUCH LARGER, PRISON
POPULATION. HOWEVER, SINCE THEN,
BECAUSE OUR DEACTIVATIONS HAVE
NOT KEPT UP WITH THE DECLINE IN
THE POPULATION THAT SIZE OF THAT
BUFFER HAS GROWN SIGNIFICANTLY.
SO UNDER OUR, PROPOSAL, WE WOULD
SUGGEST THAT IT WOULD BE
REASONABLE FOR THE STATE TO TRY
TO AIM FOR A 2500 BUFFER. IN
ADDITION, SPEAKING TO YOUR
CONCERN ABOUT THE NEED TO BE
FLEXIBLE AND POTENTIALLY BRING
ADDITIONAL CAPACITY ONLINE, YOU
ARE CORRECT THAT ACTIVATING
HOUSING UNITS AND YARDS
REACTIVATING THEM WOULD BE
EASIER AND FASTER THAN
REACTIVATING ENTIRE PRISONS. BUT
IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
PRISONS WE'VE CLOSED TO DATE
HAVE BEEN PUT ON WHAT'S REFERRED
TO AS WARM SHUTDOWN, MEANING
THAT THERE'S STAFF AT THE
PRISONS WHO ARE TRYING TO
MAINTAIN THEM AND PREVENT THEM
FROM GOING INTO A STATE OF
DISREPAIR, WHICH WOULD
FACILITATE THEM BEING
REACTIVATED IN THE FUTURE. OKAY
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE L.A. COUNTY
FIRE CAMP CONTRACT. WHAT'S THAT
CONTRACT COVER RIGHT NOW? SO
RIGHT NOW THAT CONTRACT IS
APPROXIMATELY $4.5 MILLION, WE
KIND OF HAVE A RELATIONSHIP WITH
LOS ANGELES COUNTY TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO CAMPS IN THOSE AREAS
OPERATED BY LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
AND THE PROPOSAL HERE WOULD
ELIMINATE THAT CONTRACT FULLY
BEGINNING IN 2526. WHAT DID THEY
DO FOR US? THEY PROVIDE FIRE
SUPPRESSION SERVICES FOR LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY CAMPS. WE HAVE OTHER CAL
FIRE CONSERVATION CAMPS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE, THOUGH,
RIGHT. WHO'S GOING TO DO THE
WORK THAT THEY DO CURRENTLY?
PRESUMABLY LOS ANGELES COUNTY
WOULD HAVE TO SUPPORT THOSE
SERVICES. SO YOU'RE SUGGESTING
THAT THE COUNTY ABSORBED THOSE
SERVICES? THEY WOULD HAVE TO
TAKE ON THE ADDITIONAL FIRE
SUPPRESSION SERVICES. THAT WOULD
BE SO THE STATE IS PAYING THE
COUNTY 2.4 MILLION. IT'S A
CONTRACT. SO IT'S 4.5 OR 4.5,
$4.8 MILLION. CORRECT. SO THE
STATE IS PAYING THE COUNTY FOR
SOMETHING. THE COUNTY HAS TO BE
DOING SOMETHING FOR THE STATE.
THEY PROVIDE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR THOSE CAMPS THAT WE SUPPORT
WITH INCARCERATED AND THE FOR
THE INCARCERATED CAMPS. CORRECT.
IT'S IN INCARCERATED CDCR,
INCARCERATED POPULATION THAT
OPERATE IN THOSE CAMPS. RIGHT.
OKAY AND SO YOU'RE SUGGESTING
THAT THE COUNTY SHOULD ABSORB
THAT THE CDCR POPULATION FOR THE
PRISON CAMPS NØ THEY WOULD HAVE
TO TAKE ON THE FIRE SUPPRESSION
SERVICES THROUGH MUNICIPAL FIRE
SERVICES OR OTHER MEANS, NOT
CDCR INCARCERATED POPULATIONS.
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE CAMPS THAT
WOULD BE UP TO LOS ANGELES
COUNTY TO DETERMINE HOW TO
OPERATE THOSE? SO THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THERE'S A POTENTIAL THAT
THOSE CAMP CREWS WOULD GO AWAY.
IT'S POTENTIAL. YES. AND SO
YOU'RE CUTTING THE CAMP CREWS
THAT ARE IN THOSE CAMPS.
CORRECT. THAT IS A REDUCTION IN
THE CAMP CREWS AND ACKNOWLEDGING
THE STATE FIXED FISCAL PICTURE.
WE ARE MAINTAINING THOSE CAMPS
THROUGH THE 2425 FIRE
SUPPRESSION SEASON, WHICH IS WHY
THEY'RE HALF YEAR SAVINGS. ARE
WE ANTICIPATING THAT THERE'S NOT
GOING TO BE A FIRE SEASON IN THE
NEXT 2 OR 3 YEARS? BECAUSE THIS
IS THIS IS ALL ABOUT VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT, CORRECT? AND RIGHT
NOW WITH OUR INSURANCE RATES,
PART OF THE PROBLEM IS WE NEED
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT. AND
ESPECIALLY NOW WE'VE HAD TWO
REALLY WET YEARS. SO THINGS ARE
GROWING FAST. SO WHO'S GOING TO
DO THAT WORK IF WE'RE TAKING
THOSE THAT TOOL AWAY FROM
WHOEVER IT IS THAT WE WANT TO DO
THAT JOB. DO YOU THINK CAL FIRE
IS GOING TO GO DO THAT JOB? I
CAN'T SPEAK TO OTHER DEPARTMENTS
OR THE LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES THAT
WOULD BE REQUIRED. I'M GOING TO
TAKE A WILD GUESS ON THEIR
BEHALF. NO BECAUSE THEY HAVE
PLENTY TO DO WITH WHAT THEY HAVE
, REDUCING FIRE CAMPS AND ALSO
REDUCING THE ONE OF THE, ONE OF
THE BETTER PROGRAMS THAT WE CAN
GET SOME OF OUR CDCR PEOPLE IN
THE NOT THE I'M TALKING ABOUT
OUR THE POPULATION OF
INCARCERATED PEOPLE, THAT'S ONE
OF THE BETTER CAMPS. BOTH WOMEN
AND MEN. AND THEY DO GREAT WORK.
AND WE'RE TAKING THAT AWAY AND
REDUCING OUR ABILITY TO DO THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT THAT WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO SHOW
INSURANCE COMPANIES THAT IT'S
OKAY TO INSURE OUR HOMES IN
THOSE AREAS. AGAIN IT'S JUST THE
ELIMINATION OF THE CONTRACT. WE
WOULD STILL RETAIN THE EXISTING
CDCR AND THAT THAT CONTRACT IS
ABOUT $5 MILLION, AND WE'RE
GOING TO WIND UP SPENDING
HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN CONSEQUENCES FROM NOT HAVING
THE WORK THAT THEY DO GET DONE.
THAT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE. SO
I THINK THAT NEEDS TO BE LOOKED
AT REALLY CAREFULLY IN REGARDS
TO NOT JUST HOW MUCH MONEY WE
CAN CUT, BUT THE GOOD TO THE
PERSONS INVOLVED IN THE PROGRAM,
THE WORK THAT THEY DO, AND WHO'S
GOING TO DO IT IF THEY'RE NOT
DOING IT? BECAUSE CERTAINLY I
DOUBT VERY MUCH THAT CAL FIRE IS
GOING TO BE ABLE TO INSTALL CAMP
CREWS INTO THOSE AREAS BECAUSE
THOSE CAMP CREWS, BY THE WAY,
AUGMENT EVERYBODY IN CALIFORNIA
WHEN WE HAVE CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES UP HERE, A BUNCH OF
OUR CAMP CREWS FROM L.A. COUNTY
COME ALL THE WAY UP HERE. SO
WE'RE WE'RE ACTUALLY CREATING
PROBLEMS WITHIN THAT SYSTEM
ITSELF TO OUR RESPONSE SYSTEM BY
SAVING $5 MILLION ON THIS. SO
THAT'S THAT'S SOMETHING THAT IS
OF GREAT CONCERN TO ME IS
REDUCING OUR ABILITY. WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO INCREASE OUR ABILITY
TO NOT HAVE CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES. AND THIS IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THAT. AND YET,
YOU KNOW, WE'RE GOING TO SAVE $5
OR $5 MILLION SO THAT WE CAN
SPEND HUNDREDS OF BILLION
DOLLARS, HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS LATER IN CATASTROPHIC
FIRES. SO, SO I THINK YOU
UNDERSTAND MY CONCERNS ABOUT
THAT. THE VISITATION, WE'RE
GOING TO SKIP THAT. OKAY. LET'S
TALK ABOUT CHUCKAWALLA. SO HAVE
THEY TAKEN INTO HOW ARE THEY
GOING TO DO THIS THERE? I MEAN,
IT'S A YEAR AWAY THAT THEY WERE
THINKING ABOUT DOING OR THEY'RE
TRYING TO DO IT. HOW ARE THEY
GOING TO ACCELERATE IT TO SIX
MONTHS? THEY'RE JUST GOING TO
MOVE EVERYBODY OUT. WHAT'S THE
IMPACT ON THE COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE THERE AND THE IMPACT ON THE
WORKFORCE? SO APOLOGIES FOR NOT
INTRODUCING MYSELF PREVIOUSLY,
JUSTIN, I'M AN ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR WITH THE BUDGET
MANAGEMENT BRANCH. I DO HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES HERE FROM THE
DIVISION OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS.
THEY MIGHT BE ABLE TO SPEAK
ADDITIONALLY WITH KIND OF THE
PROCESS OF, YOU KNOW, NOTIFYING
LABOR AND WORKING WITH THE
COMMUNITY ON REDUCING THE OR
ACCELERATING THE CLOSURE OF THE
PRISON. THAT'D BE GREAT. THANK
YOU. ARE THEY COMING UP? YES.
ONE MOMENT. SORRY THANK YOU. AS
PART OF THE WHILE THEY'RE COMING
UP, I WOULD SAY PART OF THE,
NOTIFICATION PROCESS AND PART OF
THE WHOLE PROCESS IS ENABLING
PEOPLE THAT ARE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED FISCALLY AND, BY THE
CLOSURE OF A PRISON. IT'S NOT
JUST THE PRISON. IT'S THE
COMMUNITY SURROUNDING IT. IT'S,
YOU KNOW, IT'S THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE WORKING. THERE ARE THEY
GETTING REASSIGNED SOMEWHERE
ELSE? YES. HI, RAQUEL BUCKLE,
ASSISTANT DEPUTY DIRECTOR. YEAH,
MOVE THE MIC UP. YEAH. THERE YOU
GO. HI RAQUEL BUCKLE, ASSISTANT
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR FACILITIES
SUPPORT, WHEN IT COMES TO
CHUCKAWALLA, YOU ARE CORRECT
THAT THERE IS NOTICES THAT NEED
TO GO OUT. AND, ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT, WE ARE LOOKING AT
IS OBVIOUSLY, THE PLACEMENT OF
STAFF TO MAKE SURE WE MINIMIZE
THE IMPACT OF THOSE EMPLOYEES
THERE. AND THE POPULATION TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE ALSO,
TRANSFERRING THEM TO AREAS WHERE
THEY WILL CONTINUE WITH THEIR
PROGRAMING, BOTH REHABILITATION
AND EDUCATION, AND ALSO ANY,
HEALTH CARE THAT'S NEEDED, SO,
YES, AGAIN, WE WERE ABLE TO
MOVE, SOME OF THE POPULATION
WITH THE PREVIOUS, TRANSITIONS
OF NON, DESIGNATED, PROGRAMING
FACILITIES. AND WE WERE ABLE TO
ABSORB SOME OF THAT POPULATION.
THERE IS STILL POPULATION AT
CHUCKAWALLA AND WE ARE WORKING
ON, ON AGAIN TRANSFERRING THOSE
AS WELL. SO THEY HAVE A LOT OF
EDUCATION PROGRAMS AT
CHUCKAWALLA. YES OKAY. SO THE
OTHER ALL THE PRISONS I'VE
VISITED, WHICH IS FOUR SO FAR,
THEY DO HAVE EDUCATION PROGRAMS
THAT ARE FAIRLY FAR MÀ. THEY'RE
OVER IMPACTED BY A LONG WAYS. SO
HOW ARE WE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
HELP PEOPLE TO, TO STRAIGHTEN
THEIR LIVES OUT IF WE'RE GOING
TO SHUT DOWN YET ANOTHER
FACILITY AND TRY TO STUFF THEM
INTO THE SAME, CLOSET LIKE
ATMOSPHERES THAT SOME OF THESE
OTHER PRISONS ARE BEING FORCED
TO LIVE WITH BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE THE FACILITIES RIGHT NOW.
AND I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO SOMETHING AT SAN
QUENTIN AND CRC HAS A GOOD
FACILITY, BUT THEY DON'T HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO BE ABLE TO
ABSORB MORE OF THESE FOLKS. SO
HOW ARE WE GOING TO HELP THEM IF
THEY CAN'T EVEN HAVE ACCESS TO A
PROGRAM, GOING TO A DIFFERENT
PRISON AND TO SPEAK TO THAT?
SORRY, TO SPEAK TO THAT? I THINK
THAT'S ONE OF OUR KIND OF
DISAGREEMENTS WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE WHO
REFER TO KIND OF THAT BUFFER OF
2500, YOU KNOW, SEVERAL YEARS
AGO. AND, AND THAT IS A BED
SPACE, KIND OF THE OPERATIONAL
USE OF THOSE BEDS. BUT WE WANT
TO MAINTAIN ADDITIONAL SPACE
BECAUSE OF THE PROGRAMING,
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR INDIVIDUALS TO HAVE, YOU
KNOW, ADEQUATE SPACE FOR
EDUCATION OR OTHER VOCATIONAL
PROGRAMS. OKAY. THANK YOU. LABOR
FORCE, WHAT'S WHAT ARE WE DOING
WITH THEM? SO THE LABOR FORCE
WERE ACTUALLY, GOING THROUGH,
DIFFERENT PROCESSES TO ENSURE
THAT WE MITIGATE THE IMPACT
THAT, SOME OF THE, THINGS THAT
WE ARE DOING IS ACTUALLY
AFFORDING THEM AN OPPORTUNITY TO
, TO, MOVE TO WITHIN THE COUNTY
AND OUTSIDE THE COUNTY TO
VACANCIES TO MINIMIZE THE IMPACT
WITH THE LABOR FORCE. WE ARE
WORKING WITH THEM. WE CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THEM. THE GOAL IS
TO MINIMIZE THE IMPACT ON THE
EMPLOYEES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
ARE THEY IS EVERYBODY GOING TO
BE EMPLOYED WHEN WE'RE DONE IN
SIX MONTHS? I DON'T HAVE ARE
THEY GOING TO ADD TO THE 5.9? I
DON'T HAVE A I DON'T KNOW, I
THINK I THINK IT IS NOT PRUDENT
TO MOVE DO MOVE SOMETHING LIKE
THIS, THIS MASSIVE OF A PROJECT
UP SIX MONTHS MORE THAN IT
ALREADY IS. IT'S ALREADY A
STRAIN TO GET IT DONE IN A YEAR,
BUT SIX MONTHS, IS A LITTLE MUCH
FOR THE WORKFORCE, FOR THE
COMMUNITIES THAT DEPEND ON SOME
OF THAT ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT,
THAT ARE THE ECONOMIC IMPACT
THAT THESE THESE PRISONS HAVE IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES, FOR ALL THAT
CHANGE TO GET PUSHED INTO SIX
MONTHS TO SAVE WHATEVER THEY
THINK THEY'RE GOING TO SAVE, I
DON'T THINK IS WORTH IT. THANK
YOU. I DO, YOU KNOW, LESS
PROBABLY CONSEQUENTIAL, BUT I
THINK IMPORTANT NONETHELESS. I
HAVE A QUESTION. I THINK IT'S
FOR CDCR, BUT THAT THE ITEM ON
DATA COLLECTION ANALYSIS NOW
COMES FUNDING THE REVOCATION OF
THE $6 MILLION TO YOU. IF I CAN.
YEAH. SO THAT WAS A ONE TIME
ALLOCATION. FUNDED SEVERAL YEARS
AGO TO KIND OF INCREASE AND TO
CONTRACT OUT FOR DATA COLLECTION
ON PAROLE OUTCOMES, SO LET ME
GIVE YOU SOME CONTEXT. SO, SO
THIS WAS AN ITEM I THINK, THAT
WAS ADOPTED A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO, AND IT WAS, YOU KNOW, A
RESULT OF SENATOR BECKER AND A
BUNCH OF US, YOU KNOW, WANTED TO
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
SYSTEM, A DASHBOARD FOR BETTER
INSIGHT IN REAL TIME OUTCOMES ON
PAROLE. AND MY UNDERSTANDING, IS
IT TOOK A COUPLE OF YEARS TO
MOVE THIS FORWARD. AND WE HAD
THE RFP IS MY UNDERSTANDING HAS
BEEN DONE. THERE WERE,
SUBMISSIONS RECEIVED PRIOR TO
MAY 3RD WHEN IT WAS PAUSED AND
SO I GUESS FIRST QUESTION, WHY
WOULD IT HAVE TAKEN TWO YEARS,
TO SIMPLY GET AN RFP DONE? AND
RESPONSES RECEIVED ON SOMETHING
THAT WAS, I UNDERSTAND, WAS
PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD. SURE SO
ONE OF THE ISSUES WAS THAT CDCR
HAS DELEGATED AUTHORITY FOR IT
CONTRACTS AND ISSUES LIKE THIS
UP TO $1 MILLION. AND BECAUSE
THIS CONTRACT WAS VALUED AT $6
MILLION, WE HAD TO WORK WITH CDC
ON KIND OF GETTING THE RFP READY
AND KIND OF WORKING THROUGH THAT
PROCESS. AND THAT PROCESS HAD
SOME SIGNIFICANT DELAYS IN IT.
THERE WERE ALSO SEVERAL KIND OF
INTERESTED PARTIES, YOU KNOW,
WHO KIND OF HAD A COMPLICATED
BID PROPOSAL IN THE INITIAL RFP.
AND SO THAT WHOLE PROCESS WITH
CDC KIND OF IS WHY IT TOOK SO
LONG TO EFFECTUATE. SO, I GUESS
TWO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS. ONE IS
TO THE EXTENT THAT THE RFP HAS
BEEN DONE AND, YOU KNOW, IS
THERE SOME CONSIDERATION TO AT
LEAST FOLLOW THAT PROCESS
THROUGH AND MAYBE REVOKING SOME
OF THE MONIES LATER AND THEN
PICKING THAT PROGRAM UP AT SUCH
TIME WHEN FUNDS ARE AVAILABLE?
AND I GUESS THE POINT I WOULD
MAKE IS, IS THE PROBLEM
PERSISTS. THE LACK OF REAL TIME
DATA, IS A REAL PROBLEM. AND A
SOLUTION TO THAT IS THAT A
DASHBOARD MIGHT PROVIDE ACTUALLY
MIGHT YIELD SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS
OVER TIME. THAT WOULD FAR OFFSET
THE COST OF THAT PROGRAM. SO IT
IS THIS, YOU KNOW, DOES THIS
MAKE SENSE, ALL THINGS
CONSIDERED, BECAUSE AT SOME
POINT WE'LL PROBABLY START FROM
SCRATCH IF THIS IS, IN FACT, A
GOOD IDEA AND I YOU KNOW, LOVE
TO HEAR A RESPONSE THERE SO I
CAN SPEAK TO SOME OF THAT. AND I
ALSO HAVE JANET SANFORD MILLER,
THE ACTING DIRECTOR OF THE
OFFICE OF RESEARCH HERE, AS FAR
AS YOU KNOW, WHAT WE CAN AND
CAN'T AFFORD, I CAN'T SPEAK TO
THAT. I KNOW THAT AGAIN, IT'S
STILL IN PROGRESS THAT BID. SO I
DON'T KNOW IF THERE ARE ANY
FUNDS THAT HAVE GONE OUT OR
THAT, YOU KNOW, ARE ISSUES WITH
THAT. I THINK WITH REGARD TO
KIND OF THE ONGOING DATA
RESEARCH, WE DO HAVE A ROBUST
OFFICE OF RESEARCH, AND THEY ARE
WORKING WITH OUR DIVISION OF
ADULT PAROLE OPERATIONS TO KIND
OF DO SOME, YOU KNOW, NEW
DASHBOARDS INTERNALLY AND
IN-HOUSE AND HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL DATA REPORTING. AND
AGAIN, AGAIN, THE ORIGINAL
PROBLEM WE'RE TRYING TO SOLVE
WAS THERE WAS A SUBSTANTIAL LAG
IN DATA REPORTING AND ANALYSIS,
AND AS LONG AS THREE YEARS IN
SOME CASES, YOU KNOW, WHICH
CLEARLY HANDICAPS OUR ABILITY
TO, YOU KNOW, IDENTIFY BEST
PRACTICES AND THEN IMPLEMENT
THOSE BEST PRACTICES ACROSS THE
SYSTEM. SO, DOES THIS NOT SEEM
TO BE A GOOD AND REASONABLE
EXPENSE, ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING
THE BENEFITS IT MIGHT PROVIDE?
HI. JANICE SANFORD MILLER,
ACTING DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR THE
OFFICE OF RESEARCH, THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION, I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT CDCR
IS, COMMITTED AND DETERMINED TO
PROVIDE TO BETTER SERVE THE
PUBLIC, AND OUR POPULATION AND
OUR STAFF THROUGH MEASURABLE
OUTCOMES, WE HAVE IN THE LAST,
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME, WE'VE
REALLY EXPANDED OUR ABILITY TO
PROVIDE DATA ANALYSIS. WE'VE,
ACTUALLY PROVIDED MORE ON OUR
EXISTING MORE DATA ON OUR
EXISTING RECIDIVISM DASHBOARD.
WE'VE EXPANDED OUR RECIDIVISM,
OUR SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTS BASED
ON OUR STATEWIDE, RECIDIVISM
REPORT, SO WE'VE REALLY COME A
LONG WAY IN A SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME CONCURRENTLY, WE HAVE ALSO
PARTNERED WITH THE PUBLIC POLICY
INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA PC, AND
WE HAVE ALLOWED THEM
UNPRECEDENTED ACCESS TO OUR
DATA, OUR CDCR DATA, WE
ANTICIPATE A PARTNERSHIP WITH
THEM OVER A MULTI, MULTI YEARS,
AND IN FACT, OUR FIRST REPORT WE
ANTICIPATE THIS SUMMER, SO LIKE
I SAID WE, WE'VE ALLOWED THEM
UNPRECEDENTED ACCESS, THEY OF
COURSE ARE AN INDEPENDENT GROUP.
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO THOSE
MEASURABLE OUTCOMES WITH THAT
PARTNERSHIP AS WELL. SO CAN I DO
I UNDERSTAND FROM YOUR, RESPONSE
THAT HAVE WE SOLVED THE DATA LAG
PROBLEM AROUND RECIDIVISM? DOES
THAT NOW OBVIATE THE NEED FOR
THIS PILOT, OR ARE WE SIMPLY
MAKING Dð? AND AGAIN, I MEAN,
YOU KNOW, WE'RE LOOKING AT A
WHOLE HOST OF FAIRLY MEANINGFUL,
SORT OF COST REDUCTIONS. THIS IS
NOT HUGE IN THE, IN THE, IN THE
SCHEME OF THINGS. AND AGAIN, MY
UNDERSTANDING HAS BEEN TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE STARTED THIS,
THERE WAS A REAL PROBLEM
NEEDING, SOLVING AND THAT IF WE
COULD SOLVE THAT, WE WOULD THEN
BE ABLE TO SECURE A WHOLE, YOU
KNOW, A BUNCH OF SAVINGS OVER
TIME BY APPLYING, YOU KNOW,
BETTER THINKING AND BEST
PRACTICES. I DO BELIEVE THAT WE
HAVE THE CURRENT SKILL SET ON
OUR TEAM AND THE ABILITY TO
HANDLE THIS IN-HOUSE. OKAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS, ONE, I WANT
TO DITTO THE, REMARKS AND
COMMENTS MADE BY, SENATOR CIARDO
ON THE FIRE CAMP CONTRACT. SO
JUST THAT'S A PARTICULAR CONCERN
SINCE I'M FROM LOS ANGELES, I
ALSO WANTED TO TALK ABOUT THE
THIRD DAY VISITING REDUCTION, WE
SPENT A LONG TIME, REALLY
STRUGGLING TO GET THAT, TO GET
THAT DONE, AND OBVIOUSLY FOR
VERY, VERY, VERY IMPORTANT AND
BIG REASONS. AS WE KNOW,
RESEARCH HAS FOUND THAT, REGULAR
VISITS BETWEEN FAMILY MEMBERS
AND INCARCERATED REALLY IMPROVE
THE MENTAL HEALTH OF BOTH THE
FAMILY AND, AND THEIR, AND THEIR
LOVED ONE WHO'S INCARCERATED IN
PRISON, WHEN WE PASSED THIS,
CDCR SPOKESPERSON THÀNH SAID,
QUOTE, FREQUENT, HIGH QUALITY
VISITING PROGRAMS FOR INMATES
HAVE BEEN PROVEN TO REDUCE
PRISON VIOLENCE, MAINTAIN FAMILY
BONDS, BREAK THE
INTERGENERATIONAL CYCLE OF
INCARCERATION, AND SMOOTH THE
REENTRY PROCESS, THEREBY
REDUCING RECIDIVISM RATES. IT'S,
IT'S A VERY SMALL AMOUNT OF
MONEY, BUT THE IMPACT IS
ENORMOUS. AND THE KIND OF IMPACT
THAT'S NOT JUST DOLLARS AND
CENTS, BUT RESULTS IN DOLLARS
AND CENTS, NOT ONLY FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS BUT OUR WHOLE
COMMUNITY. SO COULD YOU EXPLAIN,
I KNOW DON'T GIVE ME THE CANNED
RESPONSE SINCE YOU KNOW THE.
WELL, WE HAD TO CUT IT FROM
SOMEWHERE. PLEASE GIVE ME
SOMETHING A LITTLE BIT MORE
SUBSTANTIVE. SENATOR, I FIRST OF
ALL, I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS,
AND I AND I ECHO THE SENTIMENTS
OF MY PREDECESSOR THAT MADE
THOSE STATEMENTS, JUST TO FRAME
THIS REDUCTION, THIS REDUCTION
IMPACTS 23% OF ALL FRIDAY
VISITS. SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
OUR FRIDAY VISITS, WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT 23% THAT ARE IMPACTED, IT
REPRESENTS 6% OF ALL VISITS. SO
WE'RE TALKING STATEWIDE. WE'RE
TALKING IMPACT TO 6% OF THE
VISITS. WHAT I WOULD WHAT I
WOULD SAY IS, IS THE DEPARTMENT
DOES VALUE FAMILY TIES AND
UNDERSTANDS THE VALUE OF FAMILY
TIES, AND WE BELIEVE THAT
VISITING DOES, STRENGTHEN THOSE
TIES. I WOULD ALSO JUST
HIGHLIGHT THAT WE'VE ROLLED OUT
A ROBUST TABLET PROGRAM
SIMULTANEOUSLY TO EXPANDING TO
THREE DAY VISITING, AND THAT
TABLET PROGRAM ALLOWS THE
POPULATION TO VISIT WITH THEIR
FAMILIES. AT THEIR CONVENIENCE,
THROUGH VIDEO VISITING AND
THROUGH AUDIO VISITING OR AUDIO
CALLS, SO THERE IS, THERE IS
SOME, SOME LIGHT THERE. THIS WAS
A DIFFICULT DECISION MADE
BECAUSE OF DIFFICULT BUDGET
TIMES. SO AND ALSO, IF I MAY,
THIS IS AGAIN SPECIFIC TO LEVEL
FOUR INSTITUTIONS. AND SO ONE OF
THE KIND OF REASONINGS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO KIND OF MAKE THIS
DIFFICULT DECISION IS THAT WE
WANTED TO EMPHASIZE, PROGRESSION
AND KIND OF REHABILITATIVE
EFFORTS. SO FOR INDIVIDUALS IN
LEVEL FOUR FACILITIES, BY
ALLOWING, YOU KNOW, ADDITIONAL
DAYS OF VISITATION IN LEVEL
THREE AND BELOW, FACILITIES TO
KIND OF INCENTIVIZE INDIVIDUALS
TO PROGRAM AND REDUCE THROUGHOUT
THEIR INCARCERATED CAREER. AND
AGAIN, WE BELIEVE THIS MAINTAINS
THE REHABILITATION EFFORT AND
KIND OF THE INCENTIVE AND THE
OVERALL GOAL OF THE INCLUSION OF
THE ADDITIONAL DAY OF VISITING.
YEAH, I MEAN, VISITING IS A VERY
IMPORTANT MOTIVE, MOTIVATION FOR
THE INCARCERATED TO BE ABLE TO
SEE IT, NOT A PUNISHMENT, RIGHT,
BUT A MOTIVATION. AND THAT'S
BEEN SOMETHING THAT WE WORKED
REALLY, REALLY HARD ON. I
UNDERSTAND IT'S SOMEWHERE IT
WILL IMPACT, PEOPLE IN 13
PRISONS. CORRECT. SO, YOU KNOW,
23, 13 PRISONS IS A BIG, HUGE
IMPACT. AND AGAIN, IN THINKING
ABOUT THE AMOUNT THAT'S SAVED,
WITH THESE INDIVIDUALS. SO I
WOULD REALLY URGE YOU VERY
STRONGLY RELOOK AT THAT, WHEN
YOU COMPARE THE POTENTIAL DOLLAR
SAVINGS WITH THE IMPACT ON
HUMANS, IT'S PRETTY MASSIVE. SO
APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. DONE WITH ISSUE
SEVEN. ANY MORE? I THINK OKAY,
OKAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APPRECIATE YOU. WE'RE MOVING ON
TO THE NEXT ITEM, ITEM EIGHT.
BOARD OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS, OVERVIEW OF THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSALS
.
GOD! THAT'S HUGE. GOD SO WE'RE
NOT DOING DFT TODAY. WE'RE NOT
AFTER IS. THE NEXT ONE WILL BE
THURSDAY, CæA. WHAT'S TODAY?
OKAY. YEAH, YEAH. HOW LONG DO WE
THINK THIS SERIES IS GOING TO
GO? WE ONLY HAVE TWO MORE
ISSUES, SO. OKAY. YES. WE PACKED
EVERYTHING IN. OKAY OH, THESE
ARE QUESTIONS. OKAY. WITH WHOM?
FINANCE. OH. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. YES. OKAY, DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. HELLO. I'M SKYLAR
MILES CLINTON COB. I'M
REPRESENTING THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TODAY. I'M GOING TO WALK
THROUGH AN OVERVIEW OF THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSALS FOR THE BOARD
OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS, SO, TO BEGIN WITH,
TO BEGIN WITH, OUR SOLUTIONS, IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS THE PROJECTED
BUDGET SHORTFALL, THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES A GENERAL FUND
SOLUTIONS FOR THE BOARD OF STATE
AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS TO
ACHIEVE A BALANCED BUDGET. THE
SOLUTIONS FOR THE BOARD RESULT
IN A REDUCTION OF $81.7 MILLION
IN THE BUDGET WINDOW, AND THESE
SOLUTIONS INCLUDE, AN ADDITIONAL
BUDGETARY LOAN OF $75 MILLION IN
2425 FROM UNOBLIGATED, FUNDS
FROM THE CANNABIS TAX FUND TO
THE GENERAL FUND. THESE
RESOURCES ARE NOT CURRENTLY
PROJECTED TO BE USED FOR
OPERATIONAL OR PROGRAMMATIC
PURPOSES IN THE COMING YEAR, AND
THIS LOAN IS PROPOSED TO BE
REPAID IN 2025 2026. SO THE NEXT
BUDGET YEAR, FOR THE ADULT
REENTRY GRANTS A REVERSION OF
$54.2 MILLION IN GENERAL FUND
AND 20 2324 AND A REDUCTION OF
$57 MILLION THAT WAS PROPOSED TO
BE DELAYED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET, NEXT, WE HAVE A
REDUCTION OF $9 MILLION IN
GENERAL FUND, IN 20 2425 FOR THE
CALIFORNIA VIOLENCE INTERVENTION
AND PREVENTION GRANT PROGRAM, OR
CALVET, THIS WILL BE REPLACED BY
FUNDING FROM THE NEWLY CREATED
GUN VIOLENCE PREVENTION AND
SCHOOL SAFETY FUND STARTING IN
20 2425 PER ASSEMBLY BILL 28
STATUTES OF 2023, NEXT WE HAVE
THE ELIMINATION OF $4.4 MILLION
IN GENERAL FUND PROPOSED
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR ADDITIONAL
PAYMENTS TO COUNTIES THAT MAY BE
STILL EXPERIENCING IMPACTS
RESULTING FROM ANY ADDITIONAL
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
RELEASED TO POST-RELEASE
COMMUNITY SUPERVISION. AS A
RESULT OF PROPOSITION 57, WHICH
WAS APPROVED BY VOTERS IN 2016,
THEN WE HAVE A ONE TIME
REDUCTION OF $3.6 MILLION.
GENERAL FUND AND 2024, 2025,
FROM THE ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
VERTICAL PROSECUTION GRANTS,
WHICH REPRESENTS THE REMAINDER
OF UNALLOCATED GRANT FUNDS FROM
A TOTAL OF $30 MILLION THAT WAS
APPROPRIATED IN 20 2223. OH,
SORRY, THEN WE HAVE REVERSION OF
$10.5 MILLION IN GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATED IN 20 2223 FROM THE
MEDICAL FOR THE MEDICATION
ASSISTED TREATMENT GRANT PROGRAM
, IN TERMS OF BUDGETARY
ADJUSTMENTS, WE HAVE, AND THIS
MAY REVISION, THE INCLUSION OF A
WORKLOAD PROPOSAL FOR THE BSC,
WHICH INCLUDES FUNDING FOR THE
CHAPTER LEGISLATION TO ESTABLISH
A NEW IN-CUSTODY DEATH REVIEW
PROGRAM FOR SB 519 STATUTES OF
2023. WE ARE PROPOSING TO PHASE
IN $3.3 MILLION GENERAL FUND AND
15 POSITIONS IN 2024, 2025 AND
THEN $7.7 MILLION AND 35
POSITIONS AND 2025 2026 TO
IMPLEMENT AN IN-CUSTODY DEATH
REVIEW PROGRAM THAT WILL
INVESTIGATE DEATHS THAT OCCUR IN
LOCAL CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES.
THE MAY REVISION INCLUDES
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO SHIFT
ADMINISTRATION OF 2011
REALIGNMENT GRANTS FROM THE
BOARD OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS TO THE OFFICE OF
YOUTH AND COMMUNITY RESTORATION,
HAPPY TO TAKE YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. PLEASE,
DR. SOTOMAYOR, GALIO, WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY COMMENTS YET, BUT WE
WILL BE RELEASING THEM IN THE
COMING DAYS. THANKS. COLLEAGUES
QUESTIONS? YES. SENATOR SORIANO
STARTED OFF. THANK YOU. SO,
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE POST
RELEASE. COMMUNITY SUPERVISION,
FUNDING, SO FROM PROP 40, 57,
PEOPLE RELEASED, THE STATE WAS
ABLE TO OFFSET THE COST FOR
THAT, TO THE COUNTIES, DID WE
CONFER WITH THE COUNTIES ON
THEIR IMPACT, OR ARE WE JUST
EXPECTING THEM TO ABSORB THIS
COST NOW? CYNTHIA MENDOZA,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, WE HAVE
BEEN EVALUATING THOSE IMPACTS.
THESE FUNDS WERE CONSIDERED
TEMPORARY AND DETERMINED
ANNUALLY, SO IN TERMS OF WHAT
THE COUNTIES ARE EXPERIENCING,
WE DIDN'T GO DIRECTLY TO THE
COUNTIES, BUT WE ARE WE ARE
NOTING THOSE IMPACTS, THROUGH
OUR ALLOCATION FORMULA, WHAT WE
SEE IS VERY, VERY MUCH REDUCED
IMPACTS. THIS WAS PASSED IN 2016
AND IT IS LARGELY ASSUMED THAT
THAT INITIAL GROUP OF, OF
INDIVIDUALS HAD ALREADY GONE
THROUGH THE SYSTEM AND IMPACTED
PRC S. WE CONTINUE FUNDING POST
RELEASE, COMMUNITY SUPERVISION,
THROUGH THE 2011 REALIGNMENT
FUNDS. THIS WAS JUST THAT EXTRA
AMOUNT WHERE, QUITE A FEW OF THE
COUNTIES WERE NOTED AS HAVING
ZERO IMPACTS AS WE SHOULD. SO,
YEAH, MAKING THEM PAY FOR
SOMETHING THAT WE DID IS
PROBABLY DETRIMENTAL TO THE,
GOOD RELATIONSHIPS THAT WE WANT
TO KEEP WITH OUR COUNTIES.
RIGHT. SO LET'S GO TO THE,
REDUCTION OF $3.6 MILLION FOR
THE ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
VERTICAL PROSECUTIONS. AND ALL
THIS IS DOING IS AUTHORIZE USING
OR TAKING, REDUCING THE AMOUNT
FROM GRANT, GRANT FUNDING THAT
NEVER GOT USED. CORRECT. SO THAT
WAS WE DIDN'T REALLY HAVE TO
MAKE THAT GRANT. THAT'S CORRECT.
OKAY. GOOD. AND BECAUSE THOSE
ARE GOOD REDUCTIONS, WHEN WE
FIND SOMETHING THAT WE FUNDED
AND THEN WE REALLY DON'T NEED
IT, WE SHOULD BE REDUCING THOSE,
THE $9 MILLION, REDUCED
REDUCTION FROM THE CALIFORNIA
VIOLENCE INTERVENTION THAT
THAT'S THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM, IT
SAYS THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
PROPOSED SHIFTING THE SUPPORT
FROM CAL FROM THE GENERAL FUND
TO THE NEW AMMUNITION TAX. SO
WHEN DID THE AMMUNITION TAX GO
INTO EFFECT? IT GOES, I'M NOT
SURE IF IT GOES. CYNTHIA
MENDOZA, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE,
IT GOES INTO EFFECT, JULY 1ST,
2024. OKAY SO, WE HAVE REVENUE
PROJECTIONS WHERE WE ESTIMATE
THAT THE BOARD OF STATE AND
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS IS LIKELY
GET GOING TO GET THEIR FULL
APPROPRIATION, WHICH IS A 75
MILLION ANNUALLY UP TO 75
MILLION. AND THEY BASE THAT ON
THE HOPE THAT PEOPLE CONTINUE TO
BUY THEIR AMMUNITION HERE. THAT
IS CORRECT. A LAW ABIDING PEOPLE
. GOOD. SO ANYWAY, THAT WAS AN
UNFAIR POLICY IN THE FIRST
PLACE. BUT I GUESS THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO, SO ANYWAY,
THAT'S ALL THE QUESTIONS I HAVE
FOR NOW. I APPRECIATE YOUR
ANSWERS. THANK YOU, I JUST HAVE
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS. ON THE
IN-CUSTODY DEATH REVIEWS, WHAT'S
EXPECTED IS AN INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF POSITIONS. COULD YOU
EXPLAIN WHY? WHAT'S GOING ON?
THAT WE NEED TO MORE THAN DOUBLE
THE NUMBER OF POSITIONS NEEDED,
SURE. I'D BE HAPPY TO. GOOD
AFTERNOON, SENATOR DURAZO AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I'M
KATIE HOWARD, EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE BSC. SO THE NEW
RESPONSIBILITIES UNDER SB 519,
WHICH WAS SENATOR ATKINS BILL
FROM LAST YEAR, ESTABLISH AN
OFFICE OF IN-CUSTODY DEATH
REVIEW. AND THERE IS A DIRECTOR
TO BE APPOINTED TO BE APPOINTED
BY THE GOVERNOR. AND THAT PERSON
WILL BE A MEMBER OF OUR STAFF,
AND THEN THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
BRAND NEW RESPONSIBILITIES
COMING TO THE AGENCY THAT WE
DON'T CURRENTLY DO. SO WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WAS
EXPLAINING IS THAT WE, DID DID
THE BEST JOB THAT WE COULD TO
ANTICIPATE THE WORKLOAD THAT'S
GOING TO BE INVOLVED IN
REVIEWING SOMEWHERE BETWEEN 130
AND 145, IN CUSTODY DEATHS THAT
ARE ANTICIPATED ANNUALLY, THE
NEW RESPONSIBILITIES GO INTO
EFFECT IN JULY OF THIS YEAR. SO
ON JULY 1ST OF 2024, THE
DIRECTOR NEEDS TO BE APPOINTED,
AND THAT PERSON WILL BE
APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR. AND
THEN WE NEED TO ESTABLISH THE
STAFFING AND THAT INFORMATION,
OF COURSE, IS ALL AVAILABLE. BUT
WE HAVE 15 FTES, THAT ARE
PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL FOR THAT LEGISLATION
THIS YEAR AND THEN AN ADDITIONAL
20 POSITIONS NEXT YEAR. SO IT'S
ANY NUMBER OF DIFFERENT KINDS OF
FUNCTIONS, INSPECTORS OUT IN THE
FIELD, PEOPLE WITH MEDICAL
BACKGROUNDS, THE DIRECTOR
THEMSELVES, ANALYTICAL STAFF,
DATA STAFF, AND THEN SOME OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE INFRASTRUCTURE,
ALL TOTALING UP TO 335 POSITIONS
OVER TWO YEARS. AND 15. THAT'S
RIGHT. RIGHT. 15 ARE RECOMMENDED
FOR THIS YEAR. AND I GUESS I'M,
IS IT THE IS THE NUMBER WERE WE
TRACKING THE NUMBER? I KNOW THAT
THIS IS A DIFFERENT
RESPONSIBILITY ALTOGETHER. YES.
WERE WE TRACKING THE NUMBER
BEFORE? IS IT THAT THE NUMBER OF
DEATHS IN IN CUSTODY HAVE
INCREASED? OR WHAT IS IT ABOUT
THE INCREASED NUMBER OF
POSITIONS? ÓRDENES SURE. IS THAT
BASED ON AN INCREASED NUMBER OF
DEATHS, WELL UP UNTIL THIS NEW
LAW TAKES EFFECT IN JULY, THE
BSC HAS HAD FOR MANY DECADES, AS
YOU KNOW, RESPONSIBILITIES TO
INSPECT ADULT CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
COUNTY OPERATED FACILITIES, SOME
OF THE CITY ONES AS WELL. BUT WE
DIDN'T HAVE SPECIFIC
RESPONSIBILITIES TO REVIEW,
INVESTIGATE AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO LOCAL
ENTITIES. IN THE EVENT THAT
THERE IS AN IN-CUSTODY DEATH. SO
THAT'S ALL A BRAND NEW FUNCTION,
AND THAT'S WHAT THE STAFF ARE,
YOU KNOW, BEING BROUGHT ON TO
DO. OKAY. MAY I ADD SOMETHING,
PLEASE, PART OF THIS PHASE, LIKE
THEY'RE PHASING IN OVER TWO
YEARS. IT'S REALLY TO MAKE SURE
THAT AS THE BSC IS, IS
DEVELOPING THIS PROGRAM, THEY'RE
DOING IT, NOT IN A SLOW WAY, BUT
DOING IT CORRECTLY AND TRYING TO
BRING THESE NEW POSITIONS THAT
THEY'VE NEVER HAD, THESE NEW
CLASSIFICATIONS THAT THEY'VE
NEVER HAD TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
BUILDING THE PROGRAM OUT WITH IN
A VERY DELIBERATIVE, INTELLIGENT
WAY SO THAT THEY'RE BRINGING
LIKE THE CRITICAL FOLKS ON IN
THE BEGINNING. AND THEN OVER
TIME, THEY'RE GOING TO DEVELOP
FURTHER WITH THAT. THAT'S WHY
THEY REALLY ANTICIPATED THE FULL
35. BUT IT'S JUST GOING TO BE A
PHASED IN PROCESS. THANK YOU.
AND THEN, LAST, DIRECTOR,
DIRECTOR HOWARD. THANK YOU, I
JUST WANTED TO ASK IN TERMS OF
THIS, VERY, VERY HUGE CUT OF
OVER 100 MILLION, I WANT TO MAKE
SURE I GET THIS STRAIGHT, $100
MILLION IN THE ADULT REENTRY
GRANT PROGRAM. YES. YEAH. HOW
HOW DO WE HOW DO WE MAKE UP? HOW
DO WE ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF THOSE
WHO ARE INCARCERATED, WHO WILL
BE RELEASED, HOW DO WE BE THERE
FOR HELPING THEM GET OUT AND NOT
COME BACK IN? RIGHT. LIKE
THERE'S A VERY DIRECT. YEAH,
CONNECTION TO RECIDIVISM, THE
ADULT REENTRY GRANT IS
ABSOLUTELY A VERY IMPORTANT
GRANT THAT THE BSC ADMINISTERS.
AND I KNOW IT'S ONE OF GREAT
INTEREST TO THIS COMMITTEE.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY SEVERAL
COHORTS OF ADULT REENTRY GRANTS
OPERATING AND RUNNING OUT INTO
THE FIELD, THE PROGRAM HAS BEEN
PRETTY WELL FUNDED IN THE RECENT
YEARS. AND WE ACTUALLY THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE RECOMMENDED
TO BE REDUCED HAVE NOT BEEN
COMMITTED OUT INTO THE FIELD,
INTO GRANT PROGRAMS. SO THERE IF
YOU JUST SORT OF WANT TO THINK
ABOUT IT THAT WAY, THERE'S A
LITTLE BIT AVAILABLE THAT HAS
NOT YET GONE OUT TO THE FIELD.
SO THOSE ARE THE FUNDS THAT ARE
RECOMMENDED FOR REDUCTION. BUT
WE INTEND TO PUT A BUDGET
CHANGE. SORRY, WRONG WRONG.
THREE LETTER ACRONYM. WE INTEND
TO PUT AN RFP OUT INTO THE
FIELD, SO THAT WILL COINCIDE
WITH THE WRAPPING UP OF THE
CURRENT COHORT SO THAT THERE'S
NO GAP IN THE DELIVERY OF
SERVICES OUT IN THE FIELD FOR
THE ADULT REENTRY GRANT. OKAY.
GOT IT. ALL RIGHT, SENATOR
SIERRA, THANK YOU. FOLLOW UP
QUESTION ON THE IN DEATH IN
CUSTODY DEATH REVIEWS, WHO DOES
THAT CURRENTLY, THERE'S NO
SPECIFIC STATE LEVEL ENTITY
THAT'S RESPONSIBLE FOR REVIEWING
IN-CUSTODY DEATHS. HOWEVER
COUNTIES ARE REQUIRED TO DO AN
INVESTIGATION AND PROVIDE A
REPORT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. AND WE'VE CHANGED OUR
REGULATION IN ANTICIPATION OF
THE NEW FUNCTION AT THE BSC TO
WRITE AWAY BEGINNING IN JULY OF
THIS YEAR, THAT WE WILL BE ABLE
TO GET THOSE REPORTS THAT
COUNTIES ARE REQUIRED TO DO, AND
THEN WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
RESPONSIBILITIES IN ADDITION TO
LOOK INTO THOSE, IN-CUSTODY
DEATHS REVIEW C¯ HOW THEY
HAPPENED AND THEN WHERE
APPROPRIATE, MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE LOCALS TO
IDEALLY LET'S HOPE, PREVENT
IN-CUSTODY DEATHS THAT CAN BE
PREVENTED. ONE OF THE IN-CUSTODY
DEATH ISSUES THAT IS GOING ON IS
THE FENTANYL OVERDOSE.
ABSOLUTELY WHILE IN CUSTODY.
RIGHT. AND THEY'RE GETTING THOSE
FROM VARIOUS SOURCES, VISITORS,
ETC, THAT ARE STILL ABLE TO
SNEAK THESE IN. IS THAT WHAT
WE'RE GOING AFTER SO THAT WE CAN
WE CAN IDENTIFY PROGRAMS, MAYBE
THAT WE'VE SET UP THAT ARE
ACTUALLY ENABLING THOSE THINGS
TO HAPPEN BECAUSE IF IT GOES
DOWN THAT PATH, ARE WE GOING TO
FIX IT OR ARE WE GOING TO SHY
AWAY FROM THAT? WELL, THERE'S
REASONS THAT THERE'S THOSE DEATH
RATES ARE GOING UP. WELL, THE
ISSUE OF IN-CUSTODY DEATHS
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HAVE BEEN A TOPIC OF TREMENDOUS
INTEREST TO THIS LEGISLATURE AND
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS. SO I WOULD SAY
FOR SURE, THE ISSUE OF
UNDERSTANDING, YOU KNOW, WHAT
ARE THE CAUSES OF DEATH AND TO
WHAT EXTENT IS THE USE OF
OPIOIDS ACCOUNTING FOR SOME OF
THE RECENT INCREASES? I THINK
THAT THAT'S UNDENIABLE. ONE OF
THE OTHER THINGS THAT THE BSC
HAS DONE, OUR BOARD JUST
APPROVED, A SURVEY ON OPIOIDS AT
THE APRIL BOARD MEETING. SO
WE'RE BEGINNING TO COLLECT SOME
DATA, ASKING A WHOLE BUNCH OF
INFORMATION OF ALL OF THE LOCALS
ACROSS THE STATE, BOTH THE ADULT
AND JUVENILE FACILITIES, ABOUT
HOW THEY ADDRESS OPIOIDS, IF
THEY ARE USING THOSE SUBSTANCES
LIKE NARCAN AND OTHER THINGS
WHEN AN OVERDOSE APPEARS TO BE
GOING ON. AND ALSO, WE'RE ASKING
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW THE LOCALS
BELIEVE, OR WHAT INFORMATION
THEY HAVE ABOUT HOW OPIOIDS ARE
GETTING INTO THOSE FACILITIES,
OUR BOARD'S BEEN INTERESTED IN
THIS ISSUE FOR THE LAST MORE
THAN A YEAR, AND WE WANTED TO
GET THAT SURVEY LAUNCHED. SO
WE'RE BEGINNING TO HAVE THAT
DATA TO ASSIST THE DIRECTOR OF
IN-CUSTODY DEATH REVIEW DIVISION
IN OUR OFFICE, WHICH IS A BRAND
NEW FUNCTION THAT JUST SEEMS
LIKE A BIGGER, BROADER STUDY AS
OPPOSED TO THIS TYPE OF A VERY
EXPENSIVE REVIEW OF A REVIEW,
BECAUSE WE DON'T TRUST THE
COUNTY'S REVIEW. AND THAT SEEMS
TO BE WHAT THIS IS, IS WE'RE NOT
TRUSTING THE COUNTIES TO TELL US
WHAT REALLY HAPPENED. AND SO
WE'RE GOING TO REVIEW IT AND
FIND OUT THAT IT WAS AN OPIOID
DEATH, OR IT WAS A HANGING,
WHICH IS A MOST OF THEM ARE
SUICIDES OR OPIOID OPIOID DEATHS
. AND WE DON'T HAVE 1 TO 1 24
HOUR SUPERVISION OF INMATES. SO
IT'S KIND OF LIKE AND WE'VE, YOU
KNOW, PRETTY MUCH LOADED THE
COUNTY WITH A LOT OF THESE, A
LOT OF OFFENDERS. AND SO, IT, IT
JUST SEEMS LIKE WE'RE SPENDING A
LOT OF MONEY TO FIND SOMETHING
THAT WE KIND OF ALREADY KNOW THE
ANSWER TO, AND THEN WE'RE GOING
TO AND HOPEFULLY WHAT THIS MONEY
WILL DO, REALLY, IS IDENTIFY VÌ
AND STOP THE SPECULATION AS TO
WHAT THE ANSWER IS. IDENTIFY
WHAT THE ANSWER IS AND WHATEVER
IT IS THAT WE BECOME COMFORTABLE
WITH THAT AND MOVE ON, BECAUSE
THIS OBSESSION OAN WITH GOING
AFTER COUNTIES, BECAUSE THERE'S
INMATE DEATHS RELATED TO OPIOIDS
OR WHATEVER, NEEDS TO END.
THAT'S AN EXPENDITURE OF MONEY
THAT WE SHOULD PROBABLY NOT BE
DOING. AND IF WE KNOW THAT IF WE
ALREADY KNOW WHY THEY'RE THERE,
THESE THINGS ARE HAPPENING,
BECAUSE IT'S NOT IT'S NOT ALWAYS
THE, IT JUST SEEMS LIKE THEY
WANT TO PLACE THE BLAME ON THE
AGENCIES BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE
24 OVER SEVEN SUPERVISION,
BECAUSE THEY JUST DON'T WE DON'T
WE CAN'T AFFORD THAT. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT, I DO HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS, I'M GONNA START WITH
ONE FROM FROM THIS. THE STATE
CRIMINAL ALIEN ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM, BASELINE ADJUSTMENT,
SPECIFICALLY, CAN WE STOP USING
THE WORD ALIEN AND INCORPORATE
IT UNDOCUMENTED? AND IS THERE A
SPECIFIC PURPOSE OF WHY WE USE
THE WORD CINTHIA MENDOZA,
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THIS IS A
BUREAU OF JUSTICE, PROGRAM. AND
SO WE'VE JUST MODELED IT. I
MEAN, IT'S BASICALLY FUNDING WE
GET FROM THEM. AND THAT'S THE
NAME OF IT. BUT WE ALSO AGREE
WITH YOU. IT IS, WE CAN LOOK AND
TALK WITH MANAGEMENT ABOUT
CHANGING THAT NAME AND NOT USING
IT TO MODEL IT AFTER WHAT'S WHAT
THE FEDERAL. THANK YOU. IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE OBVIOUSLY
HIGHER STANDARDS AND WHERE WE GO
THE NATION GOES AS THEY SAY. SO
IF WE CAN UTILIZE THE WORD
UNDOCUMENTED IF NEED BE, I'D
LIKE TO SEE THAT. AND THIS IS
THE LAST TIME I HOPE TO SEE THIS
ON ANY OF THE DOCUMENTATION.
THÀNH, AND THEN, SENATOR
SERRANO, WOULD YOU SAY, HOW
ABOUT VISITORS? BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT HAS BEEN BEING USED AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL. YOU KNOW,
WHATEVER IS APPROPRIATE THAT
DOES NOT DEHUMANIZE INDIVIDUALS
AND HUMAN BEINGS. SO I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT. AND I ALSO WANT
TO ASK A COUPLE QUESTIONS ON THE
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT
GRANTS, IS I SEE THAT IT'S FOR
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER, BUT THIS
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THE COURT
ORDERED MEDICATION, RIGHT? THIS
IS TWO SEPARATE FUNCTIONS. THIS
IS A GRANT PROGRAM, THAT WAS,
IT'S A PILOT PROGRAM IN MY. SO
LET ME JUST CLARIFY. AT LEAST MY
PART OF IT. THE COURT ORDERED
MEDS IS ALSO, A KIND OF A PILOT.
IT WAS DURING, COVID TO ALLOW
FOR THE COUNTY JAILS, TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE THE COURT ORDERED
MEDS FOR THOSE THAT SUFFER FROM
A MENTAL ILLNESS. AND I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE. ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT THE SAME THING OR
TWO SEPARATE THINGS? THIS IS
SPECIFICALLY FOR SUBSTANCE ABUSE
AND NOT NECESSARILY, SUBSTANCE
ABUSE IS A MENTAL HEALTH ISSUE.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TWO SEPARATE
ITEMS. IT IS TWO SEPARATE ITEMS.
OKAY I AM VERY CONCERNED WITH
THE FACT THAT WE ARE, YOU KNOW,
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE PRIORITIZING, AGAIN,
TREATMENT TWO. SENATOR SARAH'S
COMMENTS I ALSO WANT TO SAY THE
FACT THAT OUR PRISONS AND JAILS
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE SECURE
FACILITIES, THE FACT THAT DRUGS
ARE FLOODING OUR JAILS, IS A
PROBLEM. AND CLEARLY A LACK OF
OVERSIGHT. SO I DO WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE. I DON'T KNOW IF THAT
MEANS MORE DRUG TESTING. HOW HOW
DO DRUGS GET IN OUR PRISONS AND
JAILS? RIGHT. I KNOW I WOULD
LIKE THEM TO ANSWER. OKAY. YOU
KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING? SO, THE
AMOUNT, YOU KNOW, I VISITED A
COUPLE OF PRISONS AND THEY'VE
SAID THAT, YOU KNOW, NEARLY 60%
OF THE INMATES ARE ON SOME TYPE
OF DRUG. IT'S A IT'S A HUGE
ISSUE, NO QUESTION, I MENTIONED
I THINK YOU HAD JUST COME IN,
BUT OUR BOARD DID JUST LAUNCH A
SURVEY OUT TO ALL OF THE LOCAL
FACILITIES TO BEGIN TO TRY TO
GET A SENSE, YOU KNOW, A
SNAPSHOT THAT'S NUMERICALLY AND
ANALYTICALLY BASED. ALL OF THE
LOCAL DETENTION FACILITY
OPERATORS, ONE PER PHYSICAL
LOCATION COPS, NOT THE
NECESSARILY THE INMATES. YES.
THAT'S CORRECT. THE PEOPLE
OPERATING THE FACILITY WILL
RESPOND TO THE SURVEY. OKAY. I
THINK THAT IF WE'RE DOING
SURVEYS, WE NEED TO BE FAR MORE
ENCOMPASSING. AND GET A REAL
ANALYSIS OF BOTH. YOU KNOW, IN
THE PROFESSIONAL WORLD, WE HAVE
360 DEGREE PERFORMANCE
EVALUATIONS, RIGHT? THE PERSON
THAT WORKS WITH YOU, THE PERSON
ABOVE YOU, AND THE PERSON THAT
YOU POTENTIALLY MANAGE GIVES YOU
FEEDBACK RIGHT ON YOUR
PERFORMANCE. I THINK WE NEED TO
INCORPORATE THOSE STANDARDS IN
OUR PRISON SYSTEM. RIGHT. SO AS
MUCH AS POSSIBLE, GETTING THE
FEEDBACK ALSO FROM INMATES TO
SEE WHAT IS THE DISCREPANCY.
RIGHT, SO IT'S THE OLD SAYING OF
WHO GUARDS THE GUARDS, RIGHT? WE
WANT FULL TRANSPARENT ON EXACTLY
WHAT'S HAPPENING. I ALSO AGREE
WITH SENATOR SARDO ON THIS AS
WELL. COUNTIES, AS MUCH AS YOU
KNOW, PEOPLE ARE SAYING THAT
WE'RE DOING SIGNIFICANTLY
PROGRESSIVE, YOU KNOW, POLICY
REFORMS ON THE PRISON SYSTEM.
WE'RE REALLY NOT MY PERSONAL
OPINION. WE ARE MOVING FROM
STATE PRISONS TO COUNTY JAILS.
RIGHT. AND GRANTED, IT'S
BENEFICIAL IN THE SENSE THAT
THEY'RE CLOSER TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES, THAT THEY BELONG
TO, ESPECIALLY FOR SHORTER
SENTENCES AND MUCH MORE WITH THE
PROP 47 AND YADDA YADDA. BUT I
SPECIFICALLY WANT TO SEE WHAT
ARE WE DOING THAT IF PEOPLE HAVE
IDLE TIME AND WE HAVE A LACK OF
PROGRAMING AND A LACK OF
AVAILABLE SLOTS IN THESE
PROGRAMS, ING, AND YOU HAVE
NOTHING ELSE TO DO, AND YOU
COMMITTED ONE CRIME. I DON'T
WANT THE JAILS NOR THE PRISONS
TO BE A PLACE WHERE YOU END UP
BECOMING A SUBSTANCE ABUSER
BECAUSE YOU HAVE NOTHING ELSE TO
DO, RIGHT. AND STATISTICALLY,
EVIDENCE BASED RESEARCH SHOWS
THIS IN AREAS WHERE THERE IS NOT
ENOUGH TO DO. WE CAN EVEN SAY
WHEN THERE'S NOT ENOUGH, YOU
KNOW, MINIMUM WAGE JOBS AND
LOCAL JOBS. THE YOUTH TURN TO
OTHER ACTIVITIES, RIGHT? IF
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH OUT, YOU
KNOW, AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND
YADDA YADDA. I REALLY WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THIS BECAUSE THIS IS
THE SAME THING WITH IN OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM, RIGHT. AND THERE
HAVE BEEN MANY, MANY PROPOSALS.
AND I'VE SAID THIS IN OUR LAST
HEARINGS, THAT THE MORE WE KEEP,
YOU KNOW, OFFENDERS BUSY AND
EDUCATING THEMSELVES AND REALLY
KIND OF MOLDING THEM INTO BETTER
NEIGHBORS, AS NORWEGIANS SAY, WE
WOULD HAVE LESS RECIDIVISM. WE'D
HAVE, INCREASE IN EDUCATION,
WHETHER THAT'S A GED PROGRAM,
WHETHER IT'S A DIPLOMA, WHETHER
IT'S WHATEVER, TRAINING OF HOW
TO BE A GOOD PARENT, TRAINING
FOR WHATEVER HUMAN SOCIETY NEEDS
. WE NEED TO BE FOCUSING ON
THAT. SO I'M VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT, YOU KNOW, AGAIN, THE
REDUCTION TO THE ADULT REENTRY
GRANT. YOU KNOW, THAT DOES NOT
MAKE SENSE TO ME, RIGHT? WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT RECIDIVISM.
RIGHT, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE BILLS
THAT SHOULD BE YOU KNOW, I KNOW
YOU GUYS ARE WORKING WITH THE
CAL AIM PROGRAM, THAT IS TAKING
WAY TOO LONG TO IMPLEMENT.
RIGHT. AND TO GET STARTED, IT'S
NOT THAT HARD, I THINK THAT
WE'RE KIND OF, AS HE EVEN SAID,
YOU KNOW, HAVING A REVIEW OF THE
REVIEWS, IT'S GETTING TO A POINT
WHERE IT'S RIDICULOUS. AND THIS
IS WHAT I SAID EARLIER IN THIS
MEETING THAT WE HAVE DUPLICATIVE
SERVICES, DUPLICATIVE EFFORTS, A
WASTE OF MONEY. IT'S BLOATED,
IT'S INFLATED. SO I DO HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS WHEN WE'RE
NOT PRIORITIZING WHAT IS
IMPORTANT TO US, THE IN-CUSTODY
DEATHS, I THINK, HAS HIT THE
NEWS SIGNIFICANTLY. IT'S NOT
JUST IN-CUSTODY DEATHS, IT'S THE
RAPES THAT ARE HAPPENING IN THE
PRISONS, THAT IS OF DEEP, DEEP
CONCERN, AGAIN, IT'S SUPPOSED TO
BE A SECURE FACILITY. IT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE WHERE SUPPOSEDLY
BE THE SAFEST FACILITY YOU CAN
SEE, AND WE'RE STILL HAVING
PROBLEMS WITH DRUGS, WITH RAPES,
WITH DEATHS, WHEN IT'S OUR
TAXPAYER DOLLARS THAT IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE OVERSIGHT OF
THIS. SO THERE IS A LACK AND Ã
IN MY OPINION, VERY MUCH A
DERELICTION OF DUTY. IF THESE
NUMBERS ARE CONTINUING TO GROW.
SO I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT. I
ALSO, I'M VERY CONCERNED ALSO
ABOUT THE REDUCTION OF THE 3.6
MILLION FOR THE ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT VERTICAL PROSECUTION
GRANTS, CONSIDERING WE'RE TRYING
TO PRIORITIZE RETAIL THEFT,
ESPECIALLY ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT, AND I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
SEE A LITTLE BIT MORE WORK DONE
ACROSS THE BOARD, ESPECIALLY IN
THESE ARENAS. SO I APPRECIATE
IT. I'M GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT ISSUE, ISSUE NUMBER NINE.
THANK YOU.
ISSUE NUMBER NINE WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE JAMES MOORE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. FRANK JIMENEZ,
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
ISSUE NINE COVERS THE GOVERNOR'S
MAY REVISION PROPOSALS IN
TRANSPORTATION. WE'RE FIRST
GOING TO HEAR FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS JAMES MOORE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND I'M
HERE TO PRESENT AN OVERVIEW OF
THE TRANSPORTATION PORTION OF
THE MAY REVISION. YOU WILL SEE
IN THESE SOLUTIONS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION ATTEMPTED TO
MAINTAIN AS MUCH FUNDING AS
POSSIBLE. AND THE $16.1 BILLION
TRANSPORTATION PACKAGE, WE WERE
ABLE TO MAINTAIN 14.9 BILLION OF
THAT, OR 93, WHICH WE'RE VERY
PROUD OF. IF WE NARROW IT DOWN
TO TRANSIT, WE WERE ACTUALLY
ABLE TO MAINTAIN 98% OF THE
TRANSIT PACKAGE. THAT INCLUDED
THE TWO TRANSIT AND INTERCITY
RAIL CAPITAL PROGRAMS, THE TO
THE COMPETITIVE AND FORMULA TÊ
RCP'S, AS WELL AS THE ZERO
EMISSION TRANSIT CAPITAL PROGRAM
, UNFORTUNATELY, DUE TO THE
CURRENT BUDGET SITUATION, WE DID
HAVE TO MAKE CUTS TO SOME
PRIORITY PROGRAMS, BUT WE'RE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
CTC AND PROJECT SPONSORS TO
INVESTIGATE ALTERNATIVE FUNDING
PATHS, FOR THOSE PROJECTS
AFFECTED BY THE MAY REVISION,
INCLUDING, POTENTIALLY OTHER
FEDERAL OR STATE PROGRAMS FOR
WHICH THESE PROJECTS MAY
QUALIFY. WITH THAT SAID, HERE
ARE THE TRANSPORTATION GENERAL
FUND SOLUTIONS FOR THE 2020 4TH
MAY REVISION. FIRST, I'LL
DISCUSS TRANSIT AND THE
COMPETITIVE TO RCP. THE 3.65
BILLION POT, THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES A $148 MILLION
REDUCTION. THIS NUMBER
REPRESENTS FUNDING NOT USED FOR
AWARDED PROJECTS. NEXT, OUR
LARGEST SOLUTIONS FOR THE
COMPETITIVE AND FORMULA TIERS ÁP
PROGRAMS. LARGE FUND SHIFTS FROM
THE GENERAL FUND TO THE CAP AND
TRADE FUNDS. THE GRF OVER THE
MULTI YEAR ALLOW THE PROGRAM TO
MAINTAIN ITS FUNDING WITHOUT ANY
ADDITIONAL DELAYS. THESE FUND
SHIFTS TOTAL $555 MILLION ACROSS
THE TWO PROGRAMS. THIS IS IN
ADDITION TO THE 971 OR SORRY,
$791 MILLION IN FUND SHIFTS FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT A TOTAL OF $1.3
BILLION OF PROPOSED FUND SHIFTS
FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO THE GRF
FOR COMPETITIVE AND FORMULA TÊ
RCP, I WANT TO JUST REITERATE
THAT THESE FUND SHIFTS ARE NOT
EXPECTED TO HAVE ANY PROGRAM
IMPACT. THE FUND SHIFTS ARE
TARGETED TO WHERE THE LOCAL
TRANSIT ENTITIES HAVE INDICATED
THEIR PROJECTS, FIT THE GRF
GUIDELINES. THERE ARE ALSO NO
MORE DELAYS IN THE MAY REVISE
FOR THESE TWO PROGRAMS. NEXT,
THE ZERO EMISSION TRANSIT
CAPITAL PROGRAM. THIS IS THE
$1.1 BILLION THAT WAS ADDED LAST
YEAR, THE MAY REVISION PROPOSES
$680 MILLION IN DELAYS. A COUPLE
DIFFERENT SHIFTS HAPPENING, BUT
THE FINAL YEAR OF FUNDS, WHICH
USED TO BE IN BUDGET YEAR PLUS
TWO IS NOW BUDGET YEAR PLUS 3 OR
2027, 28, FOR ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION, THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES A $400 MILLION CUT TO
THE ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM. THIS, IN ADDITION TO
THE $200 MILLION CUT PROPOSED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. IT WOULD
REDUCE THE ONE TIME
TRANSPORTATION PACKAGE ATP
FUNDING FROM WHAT WAS 1.05
BILLION AT THE VERY BEGINNING OF
THIS IN 2021, TO 450,000,000 IN
1 TIME. FUNDING THIS IS IN
ADDITION TO THE $275 MILLION
THAT THE PROGRAM RECEIVES
ANNUALLY, FOR HIGHWAYS TO
BOULEVARDS. THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES TO CUT $75 MILLION OF
THE $150 MILLION PILOT PROGRAM
AND SHIFT THE REMAINING $75
MILLION FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO
THE GQF. THE ADMINISTRATION
PLANS TO WORK WITH THE SELECTED
PROJECT PARTNERS TO ENSURE THAT
ALL PROJECTS COMPLETED AS PART
OF THIS PROGRAM MEET GRF
REQUIREMENTS. THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES TO CUT THE $350 MILLION
OF GRADE SEPARATIONS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY SCHEDULED FOR 2025,
26, THE MAYOR REVISION INCLUDES
A $30 MILLION REDUCTION FOR
DEDICATED COMMERCIAL DRIVE TEST
CENTERS. DMV HAS NOT ENTERED
INTO ANY LEASE AGREEMENTS FOR
THESE CENTERS. FURTHERMORE, DMV
HAS ACHIEVED ITS GOAL OF
PROVIDING COMMERCIAL DRIVE TEST
APPOINTMENTS TO CUSTOMERS WITHIN
30 DAYS. THEREFORE, THE NEED FOR
THESE DEDICATED DRIVE TEST
CENTERS TO ADDRESS THE SUPPLY
CHAIN ISSUES HAS BEEN REDUCED.
LASTLY, THERE IS ONE VCP THAT I
WANT TO MENTION THAT IS INCLUDED
IN THE MAY REVISION. THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSES APPROXIMATELY
$70 MILLION PER YEAR FOR THREE
YEARS FROM THE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION ACCOUNT TO
INCREASE THE LEVEL OF FUNDING
THAT CALTRANS PROVIDES TO THE
INNER CITY RAIL JPA'S FOR INNER
CITY RAIL SERVICE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. THIS WILL INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING THE STATE
PROVIDES TO THE INNER CITY RAIL
PASSENGER PROGRAM FROM
APPROXIMATELY $130 MILLION
ANNUALLY TO APPROXIMATELY $200
MILLION ANNUALLY FOR THREE
YEARS. THOSE ARE THE SOLUTIONS
INCLUDED IN THE MAY REVISION. AS
I SAID BEFORE, THE
ADMINISTRATION IS COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH PROJECT SPONSORS
AND THE CTC TO DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT THERE ARE OTHER VIABLE
FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
PROJECTS THAT WERE AFFECTED
NEGATIVELY FROM THE MAY REVISION
, I KNOW WE HAVE REPRESENTATIVES
FROM DEPARTMENTS HERE TO ANSWER
SPECIFIC PROGRAM QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. LEO GOOD AFTERNOON,
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS, FRANK JIMENEZ WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE. AS
NOTED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, THE MAY REVISION USES
TWO MAIN APPROACHES TO ACHIEVE
ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND SAVINGS,
FROM TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS.
THIS INCLUDES SWITCHING FUNDING
FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND,
OR GRF, AND REDUCING OVERALL
FUNDING LEVELS FOR CERTAIN
PROGRAMS. IN GENERAL, WE THINK
THESE STRATEGIES MAKE SENSE, BUT
DO WANT TO RAISE SOME ISSUES FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER.
FIRST, THE PROPOSAL INTENDS TO
USE GRF TO REPLACE SPENDING THAT
HAS BEEN PLANNED TO BE SUPPORTED
BY THE GENERAL FUND, BOTH FOR
THE CURRENT YEAR BUDGET YEAR,
BUT ALSO FUTURE YEARS. THIS IS
PARTICULARLY TRUE FOR RECENT
AUGMENTATIONS TO FORMULA AND
COMPETITIVE PROGRAMS THAT WERE
SET ASIDE TO SUPPORT TRANSIT
OPERATIONS AND CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENTS. THIS STRATEGY HAS
A LOT OF MERIT IN THAT IT CAN
ALLOW THE STATE TO CONTINUE
SUPPORTING TRANSIT OPERATIONS,
PARTICULARLY FOR AGENCIES FACING
OPERATING DEFICITS AND KEEPING
COMMITMENTS TO PROJECTS THAT THE
STATE HAS ALREADY AWARDED TO
LOCALS THROUGH COMPETITIVE
PROGRAMS. HOWEVER AS WE'VE SAID
BEFORE, IN PRIOR HEARINGS, WE
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
EXERCISING CAUTION AND
COMMITTING SIGNIFICANT OUTYEAR
GRF. WAITING TO MAKE THESE
CHOICES ON AN ANNUAL BASIS WOULD
ALLOW MORE FLEXIBILITY TO
RESPOND TO THE STATE'S HIGHEST
PRIORITIES IN THAT PARTICULAR
YEAR, AS WELL AS PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON HOW CAP AND TRADE
REVENUES ARE COMING IN. THE MAY
REVISION ALSO PROPOSES DELAYING
SOME GRF FUNDING INTENDED TO
SUPPORT TRANSIT OPERATIONS AND
THE PROCUREMENT OF ZERO EMISSION
TRANSIT VEHICLES. THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDED THIS
FUNDING TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT TO TRANSIT AGENCIES
FACING OPERATIONAL DEFICITS.
BEFORE ADOPTING THE PROPOSAL,
THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO ASK
THE ADMINISTRATION HOW THE DELAY
WOULD IMPACT LOCALS WHO ARE
EXPECTING TO RECEIVE THIS
FUNDING. THE PROPOSAL ALSO
INCLUDES SEVERAL REDUCTIONS OR
REDUCTIONS WILL LIKELY BE NEEDED
GIVEN THE BUDGET PROBLEM, AND WE
THINK THIS IS AN APPROPRIATE
APPROACH, PARTICULARLY GIVEN,
CERTAIN PROGRAMS DO HAVE FUNDING
THAT HAS NOT YET BEEN AWARDED.
HOWEVER, THE MAY REVISION DOES
INCLUDE SEVERAL REDUCTIONS TO
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE ALREADY
AWARDED PROJECTS OR AWARDED
FUNDING TO LOCAL PROJECTS. THIS
INCLUDES THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM, HIGHWAYS
TO BOULEVARDS PILOT PROGRAM, AND
SEVERAL GRADE SEPARATION
PROJECTS THAT RECEIVE
COMPETITIVE AWARDS. THE
ADMINISTRATION INDICATES THAT
SOME OF THESE REDUCTIONS COULD
INSTEAD BE SUPPORTED IN FUTURE
ROUNDS OF ONGOING BASE FUNDING
FOR EXISTING TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS. HOWEVER THIS MAY NOT
BE THE CASE FOR ALL PROGRAMS AND
PROJECTS. BEFORE ADOPTING THIS
PROPOSAL, THE LEGISLATURE MAY
WISH TO OBTAIN ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ON HOW DISRUPTIVE
THESE REDUCTIONS WOULD BE, SUCH
AS IF LOCAL PROJECTS ARE
EXPECTING STATE FUNDING IN ORDER
TO DRAW DOWN FEDERAL DOLLARS.
THE LEGISLATURE COULD ALSO
CONSIDER BACKFILLING THESE
REDUCTIONS WITH EXISTING FUNDS
FROM STATE TRANSPORTATION
ACCOUNTS AND MAINTAINING THESE
PROJECTS, BUT ALSO STILL
MAINTAINING GENERAL FUND
SOLUTIONS. HOWEVER, THIS COMES
WITH THE TRADE OFF OF LESS
FUNDING FOR OTHER TRANSPORTATION
PRIORITIES, SUCH AS HIGHWAY
MAINTENANCE AND REHABILITATION
PROJECTS. FINALLY, AS WE'VE
RAISED BEFORE IN PRIOR BUDGET
HEARINGS, THE MOTOR VEHICLE
ACCOUNT IS ON TRACK TO BECOME
INSOLVENT IN 2526 AFTER
ACCOUNTING FOR NEW PROPOSALS FOR
DMV IN THE MAY REVISION. UPDATED
REVENUE PROJECTIONS THE
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT IS EXPECTED
TO GROW LARGER. WE'RE CONTINUING
TO ANALYZE THE MERITS OF THESE
PROPOSALS. HOWEVER, WE RECOMMEND
THAT THE LEGISLATURE SET A HIGH
BAR IN TAKING ON NEW SPENDING
FROM THE MBA. I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. DO WE
HAVE ANY MEMBERS? YES. SENATOR
DURAZZO, THANK YOU. WITH REGARDS
TO THE COMPETITIVE TRC ÁP TÊ I
RCP, THERE'S, PROPOSING A CUT OF
ALMOST $150 MILLION. SO MY
QUESTION IS VERY SPECIFIC TO
THAT POTENTIAL IMPACT TO LOS
ANGELES. LOS ANGELES BEING THE
SECOND LARGEST CITY IN THE
COUNTRY, MORE THAN A QUARTER OF
OUR CALIFORNIANS LIVE AND WORK
IN THE LOS ANGELES AREA. SO VERY
DIRECT QUESTION IS, HOW WOULD
IT, THIS, PROPOSAL TO CUT
TRANSIT FUNDING IMPACT LOS
ANGELES? THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M I'M CHIEF DEPUTY SECRETARY
CHAD EDISON FROM CAL ESTÁ, THE
$148 MILLION CUT IS COMING FROM,
FUNDING THAT HAS NOT YET BEEN
AWARDED TO ANY PROJECT, AND IT
COMES FROM TWO CATEGORIES OF
FUNDING. ONE OF THEM IS $102.051
MILLION. THAT IS, WAS NEVER
AWARDED IN CYCLE SIX OF TCP IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. WE DID NOT
RECEIVE SUFFICIENT APPLICATIONS
TO ALLOCATE THAT MONEY TO
PROJECTS, AND SO IT HAS NOT YET
BEEN AWARDED TO SPECIFIC
PROJECTS. THE OTHER PORTION IS
$148 MILLION OF FUTURE PROJECT
DEVELOPMENT COSTS THAT ARE
RELATED TO LOW SAND CORRIDOR
RESILIENCY, AND THOSE HAVE NOT
YET BEEN SCOPED, AND ARE AND ARE
STILL AWAITING AWARD. SO IT
WOULD THE CUT IS FROM THE
COMBINATION OF THOSE TWO SOURCES
AND HAS NOT BEEN SPECIFICALLY
APPLIED TO EITHER ONE OF THEM IN
IN THE GOVERNOR'S RECOMMENDATION
AT THIS POINT, DOES THAT MEAN
THAT THAT FUNDING WILL NOT BE
AVAILABLE? IT'S BECAUSE THE
GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING TO CUT
ELIMINATING 148 OUT OF THE 250,
SO THAT WILL NOT BE AVAILABLE TO
LOS ANGELES, WOULD NOT BE
AVAILABLE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
TO THOSE TWO CATEGORIES OF
PROJECTS. OKAY. IN SOME SOME,
SOME PORTION OF THAT, BECAUSE
250 IS AVAILABLE. SO THERE'S
STILL 1 OR 2 LEFT AFTER AFTER
THIS, REDUCTION IS APPLIED.
OKAY. IT'S STILL A BIG PROBLEM
FOR A CITY LIKE LOS ANGELES, AN
AREA LIKE LOS ANGELES FOR ALL OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA, THE SCAG
AND THE ENTIRE SCAG AREA. YES,
SENATOR NEWMAN, SENATOR DURAZZO
ASKED MY QUESTION TO YOUR POINT,
MR. EDISON, THAT INCLUDES ALL OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. WITH
RESPECT TO THE LOSS IN MONIES.
THAT'S TROUBLING. I SIT ON THE
LOW SAND SUBCOMMITTEE. I KNOW
THAT YOU'VE BEEN A WITNESS AT
VARIOUS HEARINGS. I THINK
THERE'S A CONSENSUS, YOU KNOW,
AMONG ALL STAKEHOLDERS, YOU
KNOW, THERE'S A REAL SOME REAL
CHALLENGES FACED BY THAT QUARTER
AND THAT SOME INVESTMENTS ARE
NEEDED. SO, YOU KNOW, THIS SEEMS
REALLY AN OPPORTUNE OAN, TO
CLAW BACK THAT $148 MILLION THAT
OTHERWISE WOULD GO TO
DESPERATELY NEEDED INVESTMENTS
IN LOW SAND. SO HOW SHOULD WE
THINK ABOUT THIS, ESPECIALLY
AGAINST ALL THE WORK THAT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE LED BY SENATOR
BLAKESPEAR HAS DONE UP TO NOW?
OKAY, THE 148, FIRST OF ALL,
ISN'T ALL DOESN'T ALL HAVE TO
COME FROM LOS. AND ALSO THAT
MONEY RIGHT NOW IS ONLY
AVAILABLE FOR PROJECT
DEVELOPMENT ACTIVITIES. IT'S NOT
AVAILABLE FOR CONSTRUCTION. AND
SO RIGHT NOW THE ONE THE 148 IS
ONLY TARGETED TOWARDS TOWARDS
PROJECT DEVELOPMENT ACTIVITIES.
SO YOU KNOW BY INFERENCE DOES
THAT MEAN YOUR SENSE IS THAT
SHOULD NOT HINDER THE WORK OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND THE
STAKEHOLDERS MOVING FORWARD
BECAUSE AT SOME POINT THOSE
MONEYS ARE GOING TO BE NEEDED
FOR PROJECT DEVELOPMENT, GIVEN
WHAT WE'VE WHAT WE'VE DISCUSSED,
YES, THERE ARE A LOT OF PROJECT
DEVELOPMENT ACTIVITIES ALREADY
UNDERWAY. THERE'S $152 MILLION
CURRENTLY BEING SPENT IN THAT
CORRIDOR ON PROJECT DEVELOPMENT.
WE ALSO HAVE OVER $4.3 BILLION
OF STATE FUNDING THAT IS GOING
TOWARDS PROJECTS IN THE
CORRIDOR, THAT ARE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION RIGHT NOW. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. I'M SURE WE'LL
PICK THIS UP AGAIN AT THE NEXT
LESSON HEARING. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU, SENATOR
SERRANO. DITTO FOR RIVERSIDE
COUNTY. NO, YEAH, WE HAVE
CONCERNS. SIMILAR TO THEIRS IS
THERE'S A LOT OF NEEDS OUT
THERE. AND, AND I THINK IT'S A
PRIORITY ISSUE. IT'S AN ISSUE OF
HOW WE PRIORITIZE MONEY THAT WE
HAVE AND HOW WE SPREAD THAT
MONEY OUT OVER A FEW YEARS SO
THAT SOME AGENCIES DON'T SUCK IT
ALL UP. AND EVERYBODY ELSE IS
LEFT OUT HANGING TO DRY, THE,
YOU KNOW, THE, THE BAILOUT MONEY
THAT WE HAD FOR OUR, TRANSIT AND
INTERCITY RAIL, THAT'S ALL
INTACT. RIGHT NOT A NOT A
SENATE-TV THAT'S BEEN TOUCHED.
YEAH OKAY. IN THE MEANWHILE,
WE'RE CUTTING MONEY TO FOSTER
YOUTH. WE'RE CUTTING MONEY TO
DISABLED KIDS. WE'RE CUTTING ALL
SORTS OF MONEY. WE'RE CUTTING
MONEY FROM OUR LOW SAND CORRIDOR
PROJECTS. ALL THIS STUFF IS OUT
THE WINDOW WHILE WE PRESERVE
THAT ONE FUNDING, MAYBE THEY CAN
REDUCE SOME OF THAT FUNDING AND
HELP MAKE SURE THAT THESE OTHER
THINGS GET FUNDED, SO THAT, WE
DON'T HAVE DELAYS UPON DELAYS IN
GETTING THOSE BECAUSE THOSE
DELAYS COST US A LOT OF MONEY
EVERY YEAR. THOSE COSTS GO UP.
MORE AND MORE OF THOSE STUDIES
GO UP. SO THAT IS A OF A CONCERN
TO ME ALSO IS, IS WE NEED TO
LOOK AT PRIORITIZING A LITTLE
BIT BETTER. AND FOR SOME
PROJECTS THAT DID A LOT OF
LOBBYING AND WERE ABLE TO GET,
YOU KNOW, A SECURE BAILOUT OUT,
THEY NEED TO SHARE IN THIS PAIN
BECAUSE FRANKLY, THAT'S SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT WE WERE DOING
WHEN WE DIDN'T HAVE THE MONEY TO
DO IT. WE WERE PROMISING PEOPLE
MONEY THAT THAT SOME OF US WERE
RAISING THE RED FLAG AND
EVERYBODY ELSE KIND OF IGNORED
IT. AND NOW WE'RE DOING THIS,
THIS STUFF. SO, THE OTHER
QUESTION I HAD WAS ON, THE VOTER
REGISTRATION IN THE DMV, NEW
MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM, WE'RE
TRYING TO EXTEND THIS TO INCLUDE
INCOMPLETE TRANSACTIONS AT THE
DMV. IS THAT WHAT WE'RE DOING?
YEAH.
GOOD AFTERNOON. SENATOR. YEAH.
YOUR REFERENCE TO 87, 96, IS
THAT CORRECT? YES 8796. YES,
YES. SO WHAT WE'LL BE DOING IS
IMPLEMENTING THE BILL, AND
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE THE
ENHANCEMENTS READY, AND THE
INCOMPLETE TRANSACTIONS. NOT
NECESSARILY TRUE. WE JUST WANT
TO ENSURE THAT AS THE VOTER, AS
THE CALIFORNIA COMES IN AND
SAYS, HEY, I'D LIKE TO, SET UP
MY, VEHICLE REGISTRATION, AND
THEN THEY START THE PROCESS OF
THE MOTOR VOTER, THE AB 786,
WHICH IS KIND OF EXPANDS ON THAT
AND ALLOWS FOR LIKE THE ONLINE
TRANSACTIONS TO BE A LOT MORE
EFFICIENT AS WE'RE SENDING
INFORMATION OVER TO SECRETARY OF
STATE, $5 MILLION. IT WAS, PART
OF THE BILL. AND WHEN WE DID THE
INITIAL ANALYSIS, IT GOES BACK
TO MY PRIORITIES THING. OKAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS. TO ENSURE THAT
EVERYONE HAS A CHANCE TO BE
HEARD. PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO 30S. AND IF SOMEONE
ELSE HAS ALREADY MADE A SIMILAR
COMMENT, PLEASE JUST ADD A ME
TOO. THANK YOU AND LET'S BEGIN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
SENATORS. MY NAME IS ED LITTLE
AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE, AND I AM SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL TO COMPLETELY ELIMINATE
FUNDING FOR CRIME SURVIVOR
FLEXIBLE ASSISTANCE GRANT
PROGRAM. I WANT TO THANK
SENATORS DURAZO AND SENATOR
WAHAB FOR YOUR THOUGHTFUL
REMARKS AND QUESTIONS REGARDING
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO UNDERSCORE THOSE
BY SAYING THAT PROVIDING URGENT
HELP WITHOUT RED TAPE FOR
SURVIVORS IS A CRITICAL PART OF
THE STATE'S SAFETY STRATEGY.
SURVIVORS HAVE WAITED LONG
ENOUGH FOR A PROGRAM THAT MEETS
THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS, AND CAL OES
IS AT THE READY TO BEGIN
DISTRIBUTING THE GRANT AWARDS.
AS AN ORGANIZATION, WE ARE
PREPARED TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION WITH OTHER
OPTIONS. INSTEAD OF TOTALLY
ELIMINATING THOSE GRANT AWARDS.
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS
MICHAEL PIMENTEL, EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION, HERE TODAY
TO VOICE OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
MAINTENANCE OF THE $5.1 BILLION
FOR PUBLIC TRANSIT AGENCY
STATEWIDE. I WANT TO NOTE ALL
THAT MONEY IS GOING OUT VIA
FORMULA, GOING OUT TO EVERY
SINGLE REGION OF THE STATE AND I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT THE FIRST
BALANCE OF THAT MONEY IS
ACTUALLY ON FREEZE BY THE
ADMINISTRATION. THAT MEANS THAT
IN THE BAY AREA, $535 MILLION
HAS NOT GONE OUT THE DOOR. LÀ
$620 MILLION. ORANGE COUNTY.
$180 MILLION. RIVERSIDE. $140
MILLION. THANK YOU. THIS IS AN
ACTION BY THE ADMINISTRATION
ASKING THAT THAT BE LIFTED.
THANK YOU. AND THE FULL BALANCE
MOVE FORWARD. THANK YOU. WE ASK
IF YOU GUYS HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
MAKE YOUR COMMENTS TO SHOOT US
AN EMAIL. EVERY SINGLE MEMBER OF
THIS COMMITTEE IS VERY
INTERESTED, AS WELL AS COMMITTEE
STAFF. SO THANK YOU. HI,
CHRISTINE SAU HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE DPW AND REVOLUTION IS ONE OF
THEIR COALITION MEMBERS BASED IN
LA AND FRESNO COUNTIES. AND I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRIORITIES INQUIRIES. THIS
COMMITTEE ACROSS THE BOARD,
REALLY GOOD, REALLY GOOD WORK.
BUT WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT
FUNDING FOR THE CBOS. I THINK I
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF PLACES TO
BE CUT, BUT, THE RECENT, OFFICE,
SORRY, I GOT NERVOUS. THE RECENT
REPORT THAT SHOWS THAT
RECIDIVISM IS, LIKE, DECREASED
FROM 70 SOMETHING PERCENT TO 21%
BY CBOS SHOWS THAT THIS FUNDING
IS EXTREMELY NECESSARY BOTH FOR
SAVING MONEY IN TERMS OF
RECIDIVISM. BUT ALSO, THANK YOU.
OKAY. THANKS. 30S GUYS. HI. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, CHRISTINA BROWN, ACTING
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE PLACE
FOR GRACE, ONE OF TPWD'S LEADING
, CBO REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS.
WE ARE IN STRONG OPPOSITION OF
THE PROPOSAL TO CUT THE THIRD
DAY OF VISITING A LEVEL FOUR
YARDS, AS THIS DISRUPTS FAMILY
REUNIFICATION. PUBLIC SAFETY. AS
THEY STATED EARLIER, TABLETS
WILL NEVER TAKE THE PLACE OF
HUMAN TOUCH FOR THE FAMILIES,
AND WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE OF
YOU ALL TO SHIFT THE FUNDING
THAT IS SENT OVER TO SAN QUENTIN
TO SUPPORT COMMUNITY BASED
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS
STATEWIDE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, HOLLY FLEMMING
WITH CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY CENTERS
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE VOCA
ADVOCACY ALLIANCE, NOT INCLUDED
IN THE MAY REVISE, BUT ESSENTIAL
TO THE SAFETY AND WELL-BEING OF
CALIFORNIANS IS THE FEDERAL
FUNDING CUTS TO CRIME VICTIM
SERVICES SHOULD FUNDING FOR
CRIME VICTIM SERVICES NOT BE
BACKFILLED BY THE STATE,
SURVIVORS ACROSS THE STATE, LOSE
ACCESS TO ESSENTIAL SERVICES,
INCLUDING CHILD ABUSE RESPONSE,
RAPE CRISIS CENTERS, DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SHELTER, HOUSING AND
MORE. SURVIVORS OF CRIME DESERVE
ACCESS TO HEALING SERVICES EVEN
DURING TOUGH BUDGET YEARS. WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO INCLUDE UP TO 200
MILLION IN ONGOING FUNDING IN
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET TO FILL THAT
GAP. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CANDICE WAKEFIELD, DIRECTOR OF
OPERATIONS AND PROGRAMS AT THE
PLACE FOR GRACE. I'M A FAMILY
MEMBER PERSONALLY IMPACTED BY
THE PROPOSED, THIRD DAY OF
VISIT. CUT FROM CDC, OUR LEVEL
FOUR INSTITUTIONS, THE THIRD DAY
OF VISIT HAS BEEN IN EFFECT FOR
LESS THAN ONE YEAR. AND THE
PROPOSED CUT IS DISCRIMINATORY,
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO
REHABILITATION AND PUBLIC SAFETY
, FAR MORE THAN THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY SAID TO BE SAVED. AND I
STRONGLY ECHO OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING OR
AFTERNOON? I'M PJ, I WORK WITH
THE ASIAN PRISON SUPPORT
COMMITTEE. I WANT TO SPEAK TO
THE PERSON WHO SPOKE IN FRONT OF
ME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THAT'S
THE WAY TO DO IT, GUYS. ALYSSA
MOORE. ALL OF US ARE NONE LEGAL
SERVICES FOR PRISONERS WITH
CHILDREN. AND OBVIOUSLY WE'RE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE HUGE CUTS TO
THE ARG GRANT. OBVIOUSLY, THE
HUGE CUTS TO IN-PERSON
PROGRAMING AND ALSO THE
MEDICATED ASSISTED TREATMENT,
FOR PEOPLE THAT ARE SUFFERING
WITH SUBSTANCE ABUSE ISSUES AND
IT IS AN ILLNESS. YES. AND A
MENTAL ILLNESS. YES. THANK YOU,
LAWRENCE COX, US ORGANIZING AN
ADVOCACY ASSOCIATE FOR LSC AND
ALL OF US ARE NONE. AND OF
COURSE, IN ESSENCE, WHILE THE
BUDGET CONSIDERATIONS ARE
IMPORTANT, WE MUST NOT THEY MUST
NOT COME AT EXPENSE OF EFFECTIVE
REHABILITATION EFFORTS AND THE
PRESERVATION OF CRUCIAL FAMILY
BONDS. WE URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
FOLLOW LÀ RECOMMENDATION TO
CLOSE AT LEAST FIVE PRISONS,
WHICH WOULD SAVE AT LEAST 100
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
AND ALSO, I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT THERE ARE OTHER ALLOCATED
FUNDS ARE APPROPRIATED FUNDS
THAT AREN'T BEING USED
EFFECTIVELY, FOR EXAMPLE, CDCR
GETS $20 MILLION A YEAR FOR
REENTRY FOR PAROLEES AND ONLY
USE 6 MILLION, THAT'S 14 MILLION
THAT'S THAT'S STILL LEFT THERE.
THERE'S OTHER MONEY THAT CAN BE
REALLOCATED. THANK YOU. AND
AGAIN, IF YOU GUYS HAVE THESE
STATS, WE'RE VERY INTERESTED.
PLEASE SHOOT US AN EMAIL WITH
THE FULL IN-DEPTH ANALYSIS THAT
YOU GUYS ARE DOING. THANK YOU.
HELLO MADAM AND CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. I'M YOLANDA NAVARETTE AND
I AM WITH INITIATE JUSTICE. I AM
IMPACTED BY THIS THIRD DAY OF
VISITING, AND I STRICTLY OPPOSE
IT. ON SATURDAY AND SUNDAYS, THE
FAMILIES GO TO VISIT YOU ONLY
GET MAYBE AN HOUR TO TWO HOURS
BECAUSE IT'S SO OVERCROWDED,
HAVING HEALTH ISSUES. FRIDAY'S
BEEN MY PRIMARY DAY THAT I GO. I
DON'T EVEN TRY TO GO ON SATURDAY
AND SUNDAY BECAUSE YOU'RE ONLY
GOING TO GET AN HOUR FOR THE
DRIVE, SO I PERSONALLY OPPOSE
AND I SPEAK FOR FAMILY, MANY
FAMILY MEMBERS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR. THANK YOU,
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, MY NAME IS
CARRIE ARZATE. I'M WITH PRISON
FROM THE INSIDE OUT AND INITIATE
JUSTICE. I'M A COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER STATEWIDE AND WORK
WITH YOUTH IMPACTED BY
INCARCERATION. AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR CUTTING THE THIRD DAY OF
VISITING, TO SAVE $4 MILLION
WHEN WE HAVE 15,000 EMPTY BEDS,
THAT. AND IF WE CLOSE FIVE
PRISONS, WE'LL BE ABLE TO SAVE
$1 BILLION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
JEAN WARD WALLER, ON BEHALF OF
CAL BIKE TRANSFORM AND THE
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL, COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY,
EXPRESSING VERY SERIOUS CONCERNS
ABOUT THE DEEPER CUTS TO THE
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM.
400 MILLION ON TOP OF THE 200
THAT WAS PROPOSED IN JANUARY,
THERE'S A SOLUTION IN THE
TRANSPORTATION BUDGET. BACKFILL
WITH THE STATE HIGHWAY ACCOUNT
FUNDS, THIS IS THE BEST PROGRAM,
MOST EFFECTIVE IN TERMS OF
CLIMATE EQUITY AND SAFETY. WE
URGE YOU TO KEEP IT WHOLE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, MARK WATTS WITH
RIVERSIDE COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. FIRST, I'D LIKE TO
ECHO MR. PIMENTEL'S CALL TO
UNFREEZE THE TRC MONEY AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. SECONDLY, I
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO APPROVE
THE FUNDS SHIFT FROM GENERAL
FUND TO GRF FOR THE TRC, AS WELL
AS, RESTORE THE ZERO EMISSION
CAPITAL PROGRAM AND GET BACK TO
THE 5.1 BILLION THAT WE'RE AT.
SO I APPRECIATE THE TIME. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. Dð COONEY, ON
BEHALF OF ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION, WE'RE HERE TO
RESPECTFULLY URGE TWO THINGS,
ONE, TO RETAIN THE THIRD YEAR OF
FUNDING FOR THE PUBLIC DEFENDER
DEFENSE PILOT PROGRAM AND TO
CLOSE AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
PRISONS, THE PUBLIC DEFENSE
PILOT PROGRAM IS A MODERATE
SHORT TERM INVESTMENT THAT HAS
ALREADY YIELDED OVER $94 MILLION
IN SAVINGS AND RETAINING THIS
LAST YEAR OF FUNDING WILL YIELD
ADDITIONAL SAVINGS. LIKEWISE,
CLOSING FIVE PRISONS WILL YIELD
AN ANNUAL COST SAVINGS OF MORE
THAN $1 BILLION, THEY'RE
CURRENTLY NOT IN THE MAY REVISE,
BUT WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT THIS
COMMITTEE WILL SUPPORT THEIR
INCLUSION. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU, SANDRA BORRERO, ON
BEHALF OF SEIU CALIFORNIA, WE'RE
OPPOSED TO ELIMINATING THE
10,000 STATE WORKER POSITIONS.
WANT TO REMIND EVERYONE THAT
THESE POSITIONS ARE VACANT
BECAUSE OF LACK OF NEED? THIS IS
GOING TO IMPACT STATE SERVICES,
ALSO WANT TO REMIND EVERYONE TO
INCLUDE STATE WORKERS WHEN THE
REDUCTIONS TO DEPARTMENT BUDGETS
ARE MADE. AND LASTLY, ON THE
COURT REPORTER AND RECRUITMENT
AND RETENTION PENSION FUNDS, WE
DON'T WANT TO PENALIZE COURTS
WHO EVENTUALLY DID THE RIGHT
THING AND USE THE MONEY TO
INCREASE COMPENSATION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. RYAN.
MORE MUNI WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES,
HERE, IN REGARDS TO THE PUBLIC
DEFENSE PILOT PROGRAM, WE URGE
THAT IT IS FULLY FUNDED FOR THE
THIRD AND FINAL YEAR, WHICH WILL
HELP COUNTIES, IMPLEMENT
RECENTLY PASSED LEGISLATION,
WHICH IS WHICH PROVIDES CRITICAL
POST-CONVICTION SERVICES,
SECOND, FOR THE VICTIMS OF CRIME
ACT, WE URGE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
CONSIDER SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING
AND THEN ALSO OPPOSE THE
ELIMINATION OF THE POST-RELEASE
COMMUNITY SUPERVISION, FUNDING
AND REDUCTION OF FUNDING FOR THE
MAT GRANTS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. ALCHEMY. GRAHAM, ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY, SORRY, THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA WATER
EMERGENCY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY AND, SAN JOAQUIN
REGIONAL TRANSIT DISTRICT ON
ISSUE NUMBER NINE, WE'RE
GRATEFUL TO SEE THE $5.1 BILLION
IN RCP AND ZERO EMISSION TRANSIT
CAPITAL PROGRAM FUNDS MAINTAINED
IN THE GOVERNOR. GOVERNORS MAY
REVISE AND WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO SUPPORT
MAINTENANCE OF THESE INVESTMENTS
AS CURRENTLY PROPOSED. THESE
FUNDS ARE CRITICAL IN KEEPING
PUBLIC TRANSIT AFLOAT AND ALLOW
TRANSIT AGENCIES TO STAY IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE
ENVIRONMENTAL AND TRANSIT
MANDATES AND OBJECTIVES. THANK
YOU. HI. MCKINLEY THOMPSON
MORLEY, ON BEHALF OF VENTURA
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION, SANTA CLARA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY AND
OMNITRANS, WE THANK THE
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR YOUR EFFORTS
LAST YEAR TO PROVIDE 5.1 BILLION
TO TRANSIT. WE UNDERSTAND THE
BUDGET SITUATION WE'RE FACING AS
A STATE AND URGE YOU TO APPROVE
THE FUND SHIFT FROM THE GENERAL
FUND TO THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND FOR TÊ RCP, AND
APPROVE THE INVESTMENT IN THE
ZERO EMISSION TRANSIT CAPITAL
PROGRAM TO MAINTAIN THE 5.1
BILLION FOR TRANSIT AGENCIES.
THESE DOLLARS ARE Kò TO OUR
AGENCIES AND THE COMMUNITIES
THEY SERVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. GOOD TO SEE YOU. CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
ALVARADO, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA EDGE COALITION HERE
TO RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO
REJECT THE PROPOSED CUTS TO THE
WORKFORCE TRAINING PROGRAMS,
SPECIFICALLY THE CALIFORNIA
YOUTH LEADERSHIP CORPS, THE
APPRENTICESHIP INNOVATION FUND,
THE WOMEN IN CONSTRUCTION UNIT,
THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM, AND THE
HIGH ROAD TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS. SYLVIA SOLIS SHAW HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA AND ITS BIG BLUE BUS
SYSTEM, WE WANT TO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF MICHAEL
PIMENTEL FROM THE TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION REGARDING THE TRC, P
AND Z TCP FUNDING. THE PAUSE ON
THE RCP CYCLE SIX IS A CONCERN
FOR THE CITY, AS WE PREPARE TO
ADVANCE OUR ELECTRIC BUS
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT
FOR OUR FLEET, ANY PAUSE OR
DELAY IN THIS FUNDING COULD
HINDER OUR EFFORTS TO FULLY
ELECTRIFY OUR FLEET. BY 2030,
WHICH WE ARE CURRENTLY ON TRACK
TO MEET. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM
CHAIR, AND MEMBERS. NICK BROKAW
FROM SACRAMENTO ADVOCATES ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION. I WANTED
JUST ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH THE
ACLU, CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES, AND
OTHERS AS IT RELATES TO THE
THIRD YEAR FUNDING FOR THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER PILOT PROGRAM.
YOU HEARD THE COST SAVINGS
ANYWHERE BETWEEN 94 TO OVER $700
MILLION FOR JUST TWO OF THE FOUR
PROGRAMS, SO I APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. KATHY
MCDONALD FOR THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS. ALSO HERE
FOR THE PUBLIC DEFENSE PILOT
PROGRAM AND URGING RESTORATION
AND CONTINUATION FOR THAT FINAL
FULL YEAR OF THIS COST EFFECTIVE
PROGRAM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. AND THANK YOU
SPECIFICALLY TO SENATOR DURAZO
FOR NOT SKIPPING, BUT DISCUSSING
THE IMPORTANCE OF VISITATION FOR
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS. I'D
LIKE TO STAND IN LINE IN
OPPOSITION FOR THE REDUCED
VISITATION THAT'S BEING
PROPOSED. ADDITIONALLY, I'D LIKE
TO POINT OUT IT WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER, THEIR SOFT CLOSURE
GOING ON WITH THE PRISONS, AND
THAT'S COSTING THE STATE
MILLIONS, AND WE DEMAND REAL
CLOSURE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, KAREN LAUP. I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF THE RED LADDER
THEATER COMPANY, AND I JUST
WANTED TO SPEAK OUT, IN
OPPOSITION TO ANY CUTS TO CBOS
FOR OUR PROGRAMS THAT THEY
PROVIDE IN PRISON, AS WELL AS
CUTS TO REENTRY PROGRAMING. WE
PROVIDE PROGRAMING IN EIGHT
DIFFERENT PRISONS THROUGHOUT
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. AND REENTRY
PROGRAMING AS WELL. AND WE KNOW
THAT OUR PARTICIPANTS SEE THIS
AS A LIFELINE FOR THEIR
SUCCESSFUL RETURN TO THE
COMMUNITY AND LOOK TO US AND OUR
COLLEAGUES TO HELP THEM NAVIGATE
THAT PROCESS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NICOLE WATERMAN, ON BEHALF
OF THE ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY, ALSO REQUESTING THE
RESTORATION OF THE PUBLIC
DEFENSE PILOT PROJECT IN ORANGE
COUNTY. IT'S ABOUT $4 MILLION
ANNUALLY IN SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY, ABOUT THREE. AND IN BOTH
CASES, WE ARE DELAYING ACCESS TO
JUSTICE FOR A LARGE POPULATION.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS LIBERTY ORTIZ, AND I AM
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA YOUTH
LEADERSHIP CORPS, OR C WILK. I
URGE YOU TO STRONGLY OPPOSE A
BUDGET CUT OF $20 MILLION TO
SILK. SILK OFFERS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS THE ACADEMIC
CREDENTIALS AND PAID WORK BASED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES TO BECOME
EFFECTIVE COMMUNITY ORGANIZERS
AND LEADERS IN THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. THIS BUDGET CUT
WOULD DENY THESE STUDENTS UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITIES TO TRANSFER THEIR
LIVES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HELLO. GOOD MORNING, HENRY.
FRANK. WILLIAM JAMES,
ASSOCIATION COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR AND TÊ P W MORE
IMPORTANTLY, I'M FORMERLY
INCARCERATED, HAD A LIFE
SENTENCE. DID 20 YEARS. GOT OUT
ON MY FIRST BOARD HEARING. DID
MY PAROLE. BEEN OUT NOW FOR 11
YEARS. AND LIKE I SAID ALSO, I'M
A TEACHING ARTIST AND CMF AT THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL FACILITY AND
ALSO ON, JUST LED A RETURNING
RESIDENT WORKSHOP AS LEAD
ARTIST. AND I JUST LIKE TO SAY
THAT WE ARE WORTH INVESTING IN.
WHEN THE COMMUNITY INVESTS IN
US, WE CAN INVEST INTO THAT
COMMUNITY. AND SO I THANK YOU
FOR THAT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE. AND INMATE IS A
DEHUMANIZING WORD. THANK YOU.
HI. WITH THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER, WHILE
THIS IS NOT ON THE AGENDA, WE'RE
PLEASED THAT FUNDING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA WORKPLACE OUTREACH
PROGRAM WAS MAINTAINED. THERE
ARE OVER 250 PEOPLE HERE TODAY
URGING THE LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE
THAT THE FUNDING IS PROTECTED
AND EXPANDED, AND THAT YOU
INCLUDE THE SAFETY NET FOR ALL
COALITIONS PROPOSAL IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. I'M BERNIE SINGH
ROGERS, AN OUTSIDE ORGANIZER
WITH INITIATE JUSTICE. I'M ALSO
WITH INMATE FAMILY COUNSEL AT A
LEVEL FOUR PRISON SALINAS
VALLEY, I'M HERE TO EXPRESS MY
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SUMMARY,
PARTICULARLY REGARDING THE LEVEL
FOUR VISIT REDUCTION. THE
TABLETS DO NOT REPLACE,
REHABILITATION. THEY'RE ALSO
CONTROLLED BY GTL AND THE PRISON
THAT'S, INVEST NATIVE TECHNOLOGY
HELPING LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND I
ALSO BELIEVE THAT WITH CDC ARE
CURRENTLY HOLDING ON TO 15,000
VACANT BEDS, I RATHER THEM TAKE
AWAY PRISONS, THEN FRIDAY
VISITS. THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
AND SENATORS KOBE PEZZATI WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS. I WOULD
LIKE TO REMIND EVERYONE THAT THE
PRISONS WERE ACTUALLY DESIGNED
FOR SINGLE BUNKING AND FROM A
TREATMENT PERSPECTIVE, AND THIS
IS THE WAY WE HAVE TO APPROACH
EVERYTHING FROM A TREATMENT
PERSPECTIVE OF WHEN YOU HAVE TOO
MANY INMATES ON TOP OF EACH
OTHER, ESPECIALLY IN MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT WARDS OR UNITS,
IT MAKES IT VERY HARD TO PROVIDE
A GOOD THERAPEUTIC MILIEU. AND
THAT'S ONE THING THAT WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED. SO YES, WE'RE WE
OPPOSE THE CLOSING OF THE YARDS,
BUT WE CERTAINLY OPPOSE THE
CLOSING OF THE FIVE PRISONS
BECAUSE WE WOULD RATHER EXPAND
IT, THE, THE YARDS AND
TREATMENTS. SO WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO HAVE TREATMENT FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WITHOUT HAVING
A FEAR OF, YOU KNOW, THANK YOU
BEING IN THOSE UNITS. AND JUST
ONE MORE THING. IF YOU WANT TO
FIND A PLACE TO FIND MONEY, IT'S
FOR THE OUTSOURCING OF CONTRACTS
TO MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS THREE
TIMES THE AMOUNT THAT A REGULAR
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. I'M
LAURA LARIOS, AN OUTSIDE
ORGANIZER. ADVANCINGJUSTICE. I'M
HERE TO EXPRESS MY STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET SUMMARY, PARTICULARLY
REGARDING THE PROPOSED LEVEL FOR
VISITING REDUCTION. ALSO,
ELIMINATE ALL SOFT CLOSURES OF
PRISONS IN THEIR SOFT CLOSURE
MODE. THEY ARE STILL COSTING THE
STATE MILLIONS. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. HELLO, COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, MY NAME IS
DAX PROCTOR. I'M A CONSTITUENT
OF SENATOR TERRAZZO. AS NOTED
TODAY, CDCR CURRENTLY OPERATES
15,000 EMPTY BEDS IN ITS PRISON
SYSTEM, WHICH TRANSLATES INTO
FIVE POSSIBLE WHOLE PRISON
CLOSURES AT A MINIMUM COST
SAVINGS OF $1 BILLION PER YEAR.
IF WE ENACT A BUDGET THAT
PRIORITIZES INCARCERATION OVER
OUR VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES, THEN
WE Þ OUR VULNERABLE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WHO WILL BEAR THE BRUNT
OF THE PROPOSED CUTS TO SOCIAL
SAFETY NET AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND DO NOT HAVE THE
LUXURY OF ATTENDING THIS HEARING
TODAY. AN EXPLANATION AS TO HOW
OPERATING EMPTY PRISONS FOR
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS CONTRIBUTES
TO THEIR PUBLIC SAFETY, TO THEIR
PUBLIC HEALTH, AND TO THEIR
ECONOMIC STABILITY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION, WE WOULD ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF THE CHILDREN'S
ADVOCACY CENTERS AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES REGARDING THE EMERGENCY
BACKFILL FOR LOST FEDERAL
VICTIMS OF CRIME ACT FUNDING,
INCLUDING FOR VICTIM
NOTIFICATION. AND WE WOULD URGE
THE FINAL BUDGET TO INCLUDE THIS
FUNDING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. HELLO, TANA OPPLIGER
WITH CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET OR CURB. THE
MAY REVISION REFLECTS A 7.95%
REDUCTION ACROSS ALL DEPARTMENTS
, INCLUDING CDCR, WHICH AS A
FLAT CUT WOULD AMOUNT TO A
SIGNIFICANT $1 BILLION. HOWEVER,
THE DOF STATES THAT PORTIONS OF
PRISON OPERATIONS WILL BE EXEMPT
FROM THESE CUTS, AND THESE
EXEMPTIONS WON'T BE DETERMINED
UNTIL FALL. SO I ASK THIS
COMMITTEE, HOW IS THE COMMITTEE
SUPPOSED TO IDENTIFY SAVINGS AND
BALANCE THE BUDGET IN JUNE, IF
WE DON'T RECEIVE THIS DATA UNTIL
THE FALL, WE WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THE URGENT NEED FOR IMPROVED
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCESS TO
INFORMATION AND CLOSE FIVE
PRISONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HI, I'M ALICIA MONTEIRO WITH
CURB, DESPITE REDUCTIONS IN
PRISON POPULATIONS AND OCCUPIED
PRISON BEDS, SPENDING ON
CORRECTIONS HAS CONTINUED TO
INCREASE OVER THE LAST DECADE,
REACHING AN OVERALL 19 BILLION.
WHILE THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED
MASSIVE REDUCTIONS ON EDUCATION,
HEALTH AND OTHER SERVICES. IN
THE MAY REVISION, THE PROPOSED
BUDGET FOR CORRECTIONS HAS
ACTUALLY GROWN SINCE THE JANUARY
BUDGET, WITH AN INCREASE OF $58
BILLION SINCE THEN. WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO PRIORITIZE PRISON
CLOSURES AND CURB PRISON
SPENDING AS RESPONSIBLE APPROACH
TO OFFSETTING CUTS, A VITAL
OTHER VITAL SERVICES AND
CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET WILL DO WHAT
YOU ASKED AND SEND OVER SOME
DATA. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE THAT AS WELL. AGAIN,
HAVING HEARD FROM ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC, MEMBERS, ARE THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SEEING NONE, I DO WANT
TO TELL THE PUBLIC AGAIN, IF YOU
GUYS HAVE STATS OR INFORMATION,
PLEASE SEND IT TO US. WE REALLY
WANT TO HEAR ALL PERSPECTIVES. I
WANT TO THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY. IF
YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
AGAIN, PLEASE SEND YOUR COMMENTS
AND WRITING TO THE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE OR EVEN
MY OFFICE, OR AND VISIT OUR
WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT, AND
WE WANT TO INCLUDE IT IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION. WE
HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR
TODAY'S HEARING. THE SENATE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE, NUMBER FIVE
ON CORRECTIONS, PUBLIC SAFETY,
JUDICIARY, LABOR AND
TRANSPORTATION IS ADJOURNED